Heute ohne Previously.
Heute ohne Previously. Die Sommerpause kann offiziell jetzt als beendet angesehen werden.
Die Pause wird jetzt pausiert bis zum nächsten Sommer.
Aber es hat sich halt noch nicht ausreichend rumgesprochen, glaube ich.
Ich schätze mal, David hat noch die Füße oben.
Und ich wollte ihn jetzt irgendwie im August auch nicht terrorisieren mit meinen
volatilen Terminplanungen.
Verstehe.
Der hat sich doch auch in Urlaub verdient.
Ja, absolut hat er sich in Urlaub verdient. In dem Zusammenhang kann man auch
nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass er sich dass David nichts dagegen hat,
wenn auch andere Leute mit kreativen Previously Ideen daherkommen.
Wir hatten das ja schon einmal und wenn euch da irgendwie was Schönes einfällt,
also es muss ja nicht unbedingt jetzt immer so im eigentlichen Wortsinne des
Previously sein, also es muss sich nicht unbedingt,
auf die letzte Sendung beziehen Es kann sich natürlich auf die letzte Sendung...
Darf sich aber nur auf vorherige Sendungen beziehen.
Ach, es darf sich einfach...
Wenn wir da schon einen Ausschnitt aus der Zukunft haben, hätte ich jetzt auch nichts dagegen.
Man kann auch kreativ sein.
Den Teil, wo wir die Lotte zahlen, der Woche durchgehen.
Den Bitcoin-Kurs.
Den Bitcoin-Kurs der Woche.
Ja, Dennis, da warten wir ja schon seit Jahren drauf.
Mehr oder weniger mache ich das ja seit Jahren. Hat ja keiner auf mich gehört.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Wir hören nicht auf dich. Aber das macht nichts.
Auf mich hört ja auch keiner.
Heißt, es ist wieder Freakshow. Und zwar Nummer 203 habt ihr auf den Ohren jetzt
entweder live oder aus der Retorte und wir sind wieder da.
Und natürlich nicht in vollständiger Truppenstärke, aber so ein bisschen.
Doch, doch, die Truppenstärke ist voll.
Die Stärke ist okay, die Besetzung ist wie immer volatil.
Ja, Roddy ist da.
Hallo.
Hallo, Roddy. Bist du auch gut durchgeurlaubt worden? Ausgereichend,
oder ist das jetzt eine bestimmte Frage?
Naja, ich habe seit dem letzten Mal keinen Urlaub gemacht, aber, sondern nur davor.
Verstehe. Urlaub, das ist irgendwie nicht, finde ich total 2016 das Thema, sozusagen.
Total. Naja, man kann ja in der Firma auch Urlaub machen, wenn alle anderen weg sind.
Ist ja eh keiner da, sozusagen.
Ja, es ist dann eine etwas ruhigere Zeit und man ist nicht da,
wo alle anderen Urlaub machen.
Ich sehe schon so mit Cocktailschirmchen irgendwie im Glas sitzt du dann da,
wie die Beine hochgeschlagen.
Quasi.
Wir sehen es genau vor uns.
Clemens war auf jeden Fall auch im Urlaub, da werden wir heute noch ein bisschen...
War mehrfach im Urlaub.
Du warst nur im Urlaub.
Multi-Urlauber.
Genau, multi-parallel High-Bandwidth-Urlauber.
War ziemlich eng aneinander geklebt dieses Jahr.
Genau, man konnte das ein oder andere auch auf deinem Twitter-Ström verfolgen, wenn man den wollte.
Ja, so.
Prag, Schweden, so huch. Genau.
Man ist bei dir da nicht überrascht. Und Dennis war vielleicht auch im Urlaub, keine Ahnung.
Ja.
Machst du sowas?
Bisschen.
Sieht so ein bisschen belichteter aus als sonst.
Ja, ich komme ein bisschen mehr raus.
Verstehe.
Wow.
Also ich meine, eigentlich ist dieser Apple Watch Test eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Oh ja.
Genau.
Apple Watch abnehmen.
Wobei ich es aber weniger getragen habe. Ich muss mir mal ein neues Band versorgen.
Ja, ja.
Das kann mich jeder Uhr so noch haben.
Ich hab da auch so einen Streif. Gut, aber trotz Sommerpause starten wir gleich
durch mit einem Gast, nämlich dem Aal. Hallo Aal.
Moin.
Aal wie Fisch oder Aal wie Aal wie R? Arl.
Der Arl-König.
So ungefähr, ja.
Kaum aus der Sommerpause zurück, schon wieder mit schlechten Wortwetzen am Start.
Gerne geschehen.
Al wollte eigentlich nur mal kurz vorbeikommen, aber ich habe ihn dann gleich
verhaftet, weil du machst ja auch interessante Dinge.
Ja, sagen Leute.
Sagen Leute, genau. Ich behaupte das jetzt einfach mal und du musst jetzt zusehen,
dass du den Versprechungen, die ich gemacht habe, dann auch erfüllen kannst. Naja, so bin ich.
Nee, aber du kannst ja mal vielleicht ein bisschen von dir erzählen.
Du bist ja auch so ein Netzwerker. Kann man so sagen.
Ja, Mama sagt, ich mache irgendwas mit Computern. Genauer halt irgendwas mit
Infrastruktur, Netzwerken.
What my mother thinks I do.
Genau.
Nee, also ja, generell, beruflich, privat, seit immer schon irgendwie Netzwerke
bauen, Infrastruktur bauen und ja, so verbringt man auch seinen Urlaub inzwischen.
Auch glorioses Noctim der Republika.
Ja, Noctim Republika, Noctim Kongressveranstaltungen, Camps und sonstige Geschichten.
Ich glaube auf einen Bereich kommen wir heute nochmal, aber später dann.
Ne, können wir eigentlich auch gleich mit durchstarten.
Wir sind ja alle vorgestellt.
Oder? Wir haben zu trinken. Hau rein. Ich mach vielleicht nochmal,
doch wir kommen da gleich mal drauf, dann machen wir jetzt erstmal Einführungsrunde.
Ende sind halbwegs gut strukturiert.
Und ich schiebe erstmal nochmal den Elefanten aus dem Raum.
Weil ich hatte ja eine Sprechpause. Ja, genau. Und da sollte man dann vielleicht
mal drauf kurz zu sprechen kommen.
Ist gar nicht aufgefallen.
Ist gar nicht aufgefallen, weil ich das ja geschickterweise ohnehin in den Urlaub gelegt hatte.
Und die Vorproduktionen hatte ich. War jetzt eigentlich nicht so.
Ich hatte auch noch ein paar Vorproduktionen, aber dann keine weitere Nachproduktionen mehr.
Ja, also ich hatte das in meinem Blog auf Metaebene ME auch schon mal kurz angerissen,
dass ich mir so ein Problem mit meiner Stimme eingefangen habe.
Ich will da jetzt nicht zu plastisch werden, aber da hatte sich so ein Auswuchs
gebildet, der musste irgendwie wieder eingefangen werden.
Das ging dann so medikamentös eigentlich auch ganz gut, aber verschwand halt
nicht vollständig und deswegen war da noch so ein Nachschleifen fällig.
Schlachttag.
Genau, und da muss man dann halt einmal so durch den Narkosetunnel durch.
Ist ja insofern eigentlich auch ganz irgendwie entspannt, so eine OP,
weil man kriegt so eine Pille und dann wacht man auf.
Wie die Partys damals?
Genau. Wie eine Party war das.
Ja, und jetzt ist es insofern wieder okay, als dass ich, finde ich zumindest,
aber ich weiß es auch nicht, weil ich habe mich ja jetzt schon wieder daran
gewöhnt, im Wesentlichen eigentlich wieder so die Stimme habe,
die ich auch vorher hatte.
Ja.
Sie ist aber noch nicht in dem Maße belastbar. Das merke ich schon.
Also es ist schon noch ein bisschen anders. Also ich bin nicht mehr so laut.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob sich das fängt. Ja, nee, ist nicht so okay.
Stimmt, du hast ja Kinder.
Für uns ist das gut.
Und ich habe Co-Podcaster.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Also mal schauen. Also bedarf zumindest noch einer gewissen,
Aufmerksamkeit einerseits und vielleicht auch einer gewissen Nachpflege.
Aber jetzt bin ich auf jeden Fall erstmal wieder da und denke, ich kann...
Hast du eine Quota?
Bitte?
Hast du eine Quota mitgekriegt?
Eine Quota?
Naja, das ist ich.
9000 Worte am Tag.
5000 Silben am Tag. Oder so.
Also jetzt so rein vom Medizinischen her sei ich wieder uneingeschränkt belastbar.
Uneingeschränkt belastbar.
Also zumindest gibt es jetzt nichts, was mir irgendwie explizit untersagt worden sei.
Inwiefern das dann mit meiner eigenen Realität sich koppelt.
Das werde ich dann halt nochmal sehen.
Ich bin halt jetzt im August bestimmten Dingen einfach aus dem Weg gegangen.
Also ich habe halt versucht,
mein Sprechrepertoire in einem gewissen Rahmen zu halten.
Ich habe jetzt kein Schweigegelübde abgelegt und dann irgendwie die ganze Zeit
nur mit Handzeichen vom Sofa. So war es jetzt auch nicht.
Sondern halt normal. Und jetzt bin ich wieder da.
Und ich hoffe, wird alles gut. Und wenn nicht, dann...
Noch Fragen?
Weil auf Huckel hingewiesen wurde.
Huckel passt sich im Atlantik rum. Der ist, glaube ich, on the boat, oder?
Der ist Skipper Skipper.
Madeira war in der letzten Fotos.
Glaube ich. Aber das ist schon wieder drei Tage her und ich glaube, länger hat er da nicht.
Ich gucke mal kurz, wo ist. Das ist ja mein Kumpel Huckel.
Genau, dein Kumpel Huckel.
Wenn er Netz hat.
Wir checken mal, wo Huckel ist, aber Huckel ist nicht da. Letty lässt sich auch
entschuldigen. und haben wir sonst noch jemanden, den man entschuldigen muss?
Nö, ne? Eigentlich nicht.
Wir entschuldigen uns halt. Aber das müssen wir eh immer wieder.
Genau, das machen wir dann am Ende der Sendung.
So, Al. Ja. Jetzt nochmal zu dir.
Ja, warte, bin ich laut genug? Die Leute beschweren sich, dass ich zu leise bin?
Ja, das sind immer so mal so, mal so. Also man kann es da jetzt erstmal nicht jedem recht machen.
Na gut.
Aber ich kann dich auch auf Overdrive setzen, wenn es irgendwie geboten scheint.
Mir soll das egal sein.
Soll ich dich mal auf Overdrive setzen?
Mach mal. Ja.
Overdrive.
So ist gut.
All Overdrive. Also es gab ja vor einigen Wochen, Monaten mittlerweile dieses
doch viel beachtete Ereignis in Hamburg.
Das Sommerfest, ja. Die Fusion in Hamburg.
Wir reden natürlich von diesem G20-Summit, der da stattfand und ja...
allerlei Auswüchse mit sich gebracht hat.
In der einschlägigen Szene in Hamburg war das ja irgendwie auch schon vorher
irgendwie klar, hatte ich so den Eindruck, dass man schon in etwa wusste,
also jetzt nicht in allen Details, was jetzt so passieren würde,
aber man hat zumindest schon mal auch so den Braten gerochen und sich gedacht,
ey, da geht bestimmt irgendwas,
schief die Wand hoch und wir müssen uns von vornherein da mal einen eigenen
Kanal zu legen. So habe ich das zumindest wahrgenommen.
Wie ist das so in der Entstehungsgeschichte gewesen?
Entstehungsgeschichte, worüber wir gerade reden, ist das alternative Medienzentrum FCMC.
Gibt es auch eine URL, wer nochmal nachgucken möchte, fcmc.tv und da kann man
wunderbar nochmal nachgucken.
Da gibt es die ganzen Recordings, da gibt es die ganzen Pressekonferenzen etc.
Entstehung dazu oder die Idee dahinter war,
das gehypte Wort Fake News irgendwie ein bisschen zu,
in den Griff zu kriegen anzugehen und zu gucken, okay was passiert eigentlich
aktuell, was machen die offiziellen Kanäle, ich sag mal, Beispiel Polizei Hamburg hat getwittert,
und die Sorge, die dort bestand, war einfach, dass die Leute,
oder die offiziellen Kanäle Sachen raushauen, die vielleicht nicht so der Realität
entsprechen, vielleicht im Nachgang dann ein bisschen korrigiert werden,
aber wichtig ist immer die Erstdarstellung.
So weit machen unsere Deutschen, wir hören noch nie.
Die Hamburger schon.
Total, die anhört auf.
Und es ging halt auch darum, selber nochmal ein bisschen Berichterstattung zu
machen und zu sagen, okay, wie neben andere das war, die vielleicht,
keine Akkreditierung bekommen haben oder auch keine haben wollten,
gab es auch für das offizielle Pressezentrum und wir wollten halt ganz klar
auch einen Gegenpol da zu setzen und sagen, okay.
Wir schaffen einen Raum, der sich selber bespielt.
Also die Idee war nicht, wir liefern Content, sondern die Idee von dem FCMC
war halt, wir liefern Infrastruktur.
Und jeder, der möchte, kann da reinkommen, kann sich akkreditieren,
kann Content produzieren und den in Absprache mit einer sich selbstbildenden Redaktion,
also es war so eine jeden Tag sich neu findende, natürlich mit vielen Stammgästen
besetzte Redaktion und da im Prinzip den Content dann verbreiten.
Wir hatten einen Livestream gebaut, der 24 Stunden am Tag gestreamt hat und
da gab es dann Beiträge aus der Konserve, die in den, jetzt muss ich lügen,
vier Studios haben wir aufgebaut, also vier Videostudios.
Und da nochmal vielen, vielen Dank an die Leute von C3WOG, also auch wieder
aus dem Clubumfeld, ganz viel geholfen wurde.
Und ja, die Idee war halt, einen Raum zu bieten, wo Leute einfach mal ihre Darstellung
kundtun können und aufbereiten können und ein bisschen professioneller rausposaunen können.
Und das Ganze halt in konzentrierter Form, sodass nicht irgendwie jede Gruppierung,
jede Struktur rund um Aktivismus oder Gipfelgegner, die natürlich vornehmlich
da auch vertreten waren,
irgendwie so Einzelschauplätze aufgemacht haben, sondern man gesagt hat,
okay, das ist Anlaufpunkt, da kommen wir mit Leuten hin, da gibt es die Information.
Da kann ich beispielsweise, ich habe auf der Straße gesehen,
dass da irgendwie eine Mülltonne gebrannt hat.
und der Tweet der Polizei war aber halbes Stadtviertel brennt und dann konnte
man halt hinlaufen und vielleicht Bilder einreichen, Videos einreichen die wurden dann mal gesichtet,
Entsprechend getaggt, vorbereitet und dann konnten halt die Leute vor Ort daraus
Content produzieren. Das war so die grobe Idee dahinter.
Wer ist denn wir?
Wir sind, ich will jetzt aus bestimmten Gründen da keine konkreten Namen irgendwie nennen.
Nee, Namen nicht. Was für eine Art Kollektiv hat sich da zusammengefunden?
Ein komplett neues tatsächlich. Also das ist halt entstanden in Hamburg.
Da waren einige Hamburger, die so im, ja man würde heute vielleicht sagen linke
Szene, bitte nicht mit links extremistisch verwechseln, sondern eher so linksorientierte
Menschen, die gesagt haben, wir müssen da was machen.
Da haben sich dann, ich sag mal, das ist so ein Teil, zum Beispiel alte Leute
aus der Hafenstraßenbesetzung, die waren dabei.
Irgendwelche Leute, die in dem Projekt der Fuchsgenossenschaft zum Beispiel
in Hamburg unterwegs sind.
Was ist das?
Die Fuchsgenossenschaft ist ein Versuch, ein selbstverwaltendes Gebäude in Hamburg
zu betreiben für gewährbetreibende Künstler.
Umsonstladen, der Hamburger CCC ist da mit drin.
Die haben ein Gebäude gekauft in Hamburg, eine alte Kaserne war das früher,
schon Denkmalschutz, war zuletzt von der Uni bespielt und das wird jetzt in
Eigenregie renoviert und als alternatives Stadtteilkonzept sozusagen betrieben.
Und aus der Szene sind halt einige Leute gewesen, die gesagt haben,
hey, wir müssen da was machen und die haben sich dann zusammengetan, haben mit dem FC St.
Pauli gesprochen und haben gesagt, oh, wir würden das ganz gerne machen,
haben mit denen einfach einen Mietvertrag tatsächlich zustande bekommen und
ja, irgendwann standen die bei mir auf der Matte und sagten,
du machst doch irgendwas mit Infrastruktur, die bräuchten wir für sowas auch.
Ja und so bin ich dann da praktisch mit reingerutscht und wir haben dann halt
mit einigen Leuten, die sich auch mit Presse auskennen, da sind auch einige,
die Presseausweise haben, die wissen, wie man eine Reaktion macht,
da sind Leute gewesen, die Grafiken machen konnten und und und und und.
Wie viel Vorlauf hat er das alles?
Das ging über einige Monate tatsächlich. Das ging, die ersten Ideen,
da war ich noch nicht involviert, muss ich fairerweise sagen,
die gingen so Ende letzten Jahres los.
Und wirklich dann die komplett, die wirkliche Arbeit, die dann losging,
ich würde mal sagen, das waren so drei bis vier Monate Vorlauf, die wir dann hatten.
Also so, wo es dann darum ging, einfach zu organisieren, okay,
wie soll das Ganze aussehen, wie wird es bespielt, wo kriegen wir die Technik
her, wer kommt da vorbei, wer darf da rein,
dann muss man das ja irgendwie Sicherheitsdienst bestellen, man muss das ja
als geschlossene Veranstaltung machen, weil ja keine Versammlungen erlaubt waren
in Hamburg, in dem Bereich, wo wir waren.
Wer das in Hamburg kennt, wir waren ja auch irgendwie nur 500 Meter,
nein, einen Tick mehr, 800 Meter vom G20-Gipfel selber weg,
was dann solche lustigen Sachen hatte, wie die Bundesnetzagentur hat die Auflage,
Sonderauflage gehabt, dass wir alle Funkgeräte auf der Veranstaltung mussten
einmal durchgeprüft werden, die Verstärker mussten für die Funkgeräte geprüft
werden, die kriegten alle ein Siegel,
jede Funke wurde mit einer Karte ausgestattet, wo eine Zulassungsnummer dann
für die Veranstaltung drauf war und und und.
Also dieser ganze Kram, der war so drei Monate, vier Monate vorher.
Die haben aber diese ganzen Schreibtischtäter dieser Republik mal voll aktiviert.
Ja, also tatsächlich, wenn es heißt, wir haben alles mobilisiert und nach Hamburg
geschickt, ich würde sagen, das stimmt von beiden Seiten, ja.
Ich muss mal ganz kurz dein Headset austauschen. Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl,
mit deinem Mikrofon ist was nicht in Ordnung. Mal ganz kurz.
Zack. Das geht da hier alles ganz schnell und professionell. Das sogar ohne...
ekliges Mikrofon knacken. So, jetzt gucken wir mal. Oh Gott.
War das jetzt das nicht, das ohne ekliges Mikrofon knacken?
Das war jetzt ein super...
Wie klingt denn das mit?
Oh nee, das ist ja noch schlimmer als vorher. Es tut mir leid.
Mal wieder auf das andere zurück. Ich hab gerade keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas ist da faul. Hab ich es dann irgendwie schlimmer gemacht, als es vorher war.
So.
Jetzt hast du es zerstört.
Jetzt habe ich es zerstört.
Wo ist jetzt der Lernpfad?
Aber gut zu wissen, am Mikrofon liegt es immer nicht.
Offenbar nicht.
Oder liegt der Fehler, der sich weitergibt.
Das macht mich jetzt allerdings gerade nicht.
Sag mal immer Hauptweid-Aal.
Der Aal ist gerade mal kurz abgedingst. Sorry, was ist denn da?
Der Aal ist abgedingst worden. Oh Mann.
So, Rodi, was trinkst du denn heute für ein Bier?
Ich trinke heute ein Hofbräuhaus München helles Vollbier.
Ich finde eine andere Lösung, Sekunde.
Und es taucht.
Es geht.
Du, es gibt in München sechs Brauereien und nur eine ist gut und die gehört nicht dazu.
Alles klar. Wie nur sechs?
Sechs in München.
Ja, und? Okay, München ist auch ein geografischer Popel.
Außenrum gibt es noch ein paar. Aber das sind die sechs, die eben auch aufs Oktoberfest dürfen.
Nur diese sechs Brauchereien haben dort auch Zelte.
Und du sagst, die anderen fünf sind eher so nicht so?
Also Augustina ist die eine, die ich gut finde. Und alle anderen,
naja, so Löwenbräu, Hofbräu,
Hackerpschor, trotz des netten Namens. Naja.
Ich verstehe.
Ihr seid live, ihr wisst es, ne?
Ja. Ich versuche jetzt hier gerade Überbrückungsprogramm zu machen, statt...
Wir sprechen mal ganz entspannt über Bier. Das ist doch eigentlich auch okay, oder?
So, noch werden immer Headsets durch die Gegend gereicht. Hören wir was?
Hallo, hallo.
Ah, ein Aal.
Hallo, hier bin ich. Ich kann wieder reden. Nee, ihr könnt mich wieder hören.
Versuch einfach mal da weiterzumachen, wo du...
Ja, wo war ich denn vor dem Hot Button?
Weiß nicht ganz genau. Wir waren dabei, dass alle Leute alle Truppen hingeschickt haben.
Selbst die Bundesnetzagentur hat ihre Truppen.
Auch die BNZ-A hat da irgendwie groß aufgefahren und ganz tolle Sonderregeln.
Die dient natürlich total der Sicherheit, wenn du Aufkleber auf deinen Funkgeräten
hast und verhindert Terrorismus.
Weil ein Terrorist würde zwar an seinem Funkgerät manipulieren,
aber er würde niemals, niemals,
den Aufkleber abreißen.
Das stimmt, viel zu aufwendig. Die kleben ziemlich gut, aber...
Wie die Schweizer mit ihrer Munition. Kennst du diese Story?
Kennst du?
Du guckst so gerade so ein bisschen.
Ich kenn's auch nicht.
Schweizer haben ja immer noch Militärdienst, wo man so hin muss,
als männlicher. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Weible, aber egal.
Und nach dem Militärdienst kriegst du deine Knarre mit nach Hause.
Aber ohne Munition.
Doch, du kriegst auch Munition. Die ist in einer Büchse und auf dieser Büchse ist ein Siegel drauf.
So und selbst wenn so ein Schweizer mal so richtig crazy ist oder so,
dann greift er sich auch seine Knarre, so richtig Maschinengewehr und lalala
und nimmt auch gerne mal diese Büchse in die Hand.
Aber angeblich, dann sieht er dieses Siegel und das wird nicht aufgemacht.
Weil drauf steht Warranty Void.
Nein, nein, nein. Das ist wohl extremst, schwerst, höchst verboten,
außer wenn die Deutschen kommen.
dann darf man diese Siegel abmachen und die Patronen entnehmen,
aber offensichtlich, also weil wir immer so sagen, so in Amiland ist es halt
so schlimm weil da jeder eine Knarre hat und jeder nimmt die sofort aus dem
Schrank und ballert damit rum, die Schweiz ist nicht viel besser,
nur die haben alle Angst vor dem Siegel das finde ich schon okay.
Angst vor dem Siegel Davon haben wir nicht sonst Patronen besorgt.
Für ihre Knarren.
Ich glaube Patrone.
Ist ja einfach zu sagen aber ich glaube.
Wir müssen wieder zurück Ich finde es ja schon ein bisschen interessant Also
vielleicht mal kurz zusammenzufassen,
aus der Szene heraus hat sich das sozusagen mehr oder weniger von alleine entwickelt
und dann haben sich die Szenen dann einfach gefunden und da hat sich dann eben
auch so eine technische Szene, unter anderem auch CCC, aber nicht nur und dann, was ist dann genau,
in dem Fall vielleicht noch und,
Wann kam da der FC St. Pauli ins Spiel?
Der FC St. Pauli war im Prinzip oder ist der Inhaber von dem Stadion.
Ja, weiß. Aber ich meine, haben die das von vornherein bekannt gegeben oder was?
Naja, das war kein Geheimnis. Also das war, man kann ja einfach...
Nee, ich meine, haben die das nicht bekannt gegeben, haben die sich,
haben die das von vornherein angeboten oder wurden die dann gefragt?
Nee, die wurden gefragt.
Die wurden gefragt. Also wer in Hamburg so müssen die Strukturen kennt,
der weiß, dass die Leute, die auch da in diesem, ich nenne es mal Kollektiv
jetzt irgendwie unterwegs waren, dass die natürlich einen Bezug zum FC St. Pauli irgendwie haben.
Also die gehen eher halt ins Willern-Tor als ins Volksparkstadion.
Und durch die Lage war das natürlich ideal. Und ja, da gab es dann im Prinzip
relativ, soweit ich das weiß, weil da war ich nicht involviert in den Verhandlungen,
gab es aber relativ schnell Einigkeit.
Und halt einfach von St. Pauli halt auch den entsprechenden Statement,
da muss man das Rückgrat haben zu sagen, wir lassen sowas hier zu.
Ja, da ist die Stadt bestimmt hingegangen und hat gesagt, Oh,
oh, oh, wenn ihr so diese schlimmen, fiesen, linksgrünen, versifften Terroristen da behaust oder sowas.
Dann kriegt der für die nächste Spielsaison gar keine. Das ist gar nicht so
witzig, wie es klingt, weil es gab ja eine Gefahreneinschätzung zu dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Also es gab dann ja, ihr habt ja irgendwie Verfassungsschutz und wer nicht alles
irgendwie Dokumente erstellt.
Und man lässt sich dann auch anwaltlich beraten bei so einem Projekt,
weil es ist ja nicht ganz ohne. Man muss ja da einige Sachen beachten.
es geht über Jugendschutz hin bis halt wirklich irgendwie, okay,
was dürfen wir senden, ohne uns strafbar zu machen weil kannst du ja,
wenn du irgendwie irgendeiner macht einen Beitrag und da steht drin geht mal
alle zu dieser Demo und dann gab es ja diese Demo-Verbotszone und wir senden das,
dann machen wir uns halt strafbar im Sinne von Aufruf zur Begehung einer Straftat.
Oder man stelle sich vor, ihr habt 501 Zuschauer in einem Stream.
Ja, das ist ja nicht wiederkehrend, das war ja so eine einmalige Geschichte.
Ich glaube, das ist halt und es gab halt so eine Gefährdungseinschätzung zu
jeder Demonstration, jeder Veranstaltung.
Also da war dann so diese Demo der Parteien, die halt eine Woche vor dem Gipfel
war, die war halt gering gefährlich eingestuft, die Welcome to Hell,
die war etwas anders eingestuft und irgendwo tauchten wir dann so bei Veranstaltung
Nummer 40 irgendwo in diesem ganzen Pamphlet auf und da war dann halt tatsächlich
eine Gefährdungseinstufung,
dass das FCM-TW ja eine potenzielle Gefahr darstellen würde,
weil in einer der ersten Presseerklärungen zu dem Projekt drin stand,
dass es eine polizeifreie Zone sei.
Und das haben wohl einige Leute den falschen Hals bekommen, gerade so auf der
Seite der staatlichen Organe.
Und plötzlich hieß es, ja, wir sind eine Gefährdung.
Es ist ja nicht weiter eskaliert, aber es ist schon komisch zu wissen,
wenn man so ein Pamphlet liest und man sieht, okay, die Demo gefährlich,
das ist gefährlich, das weniger gefährlich.
Und plötzlich ist das Projekt, wo man selber sehr viel drinsteckt,
also man muss dazu sagen, ich zum Beispiel habe eine Woche in dem Stadion gewohnt,
obwohl ich in Hamburg wohne, also ich bin da nicht rausgegangen,
weil ich nicht wusste, ob ich wieder reinkomme in die Zone.
Also ich bin halt mit dem Material eingezogen und mit dem Material wieder ausgezogen.
Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, es liegt zentral für die Leute, die sich vielleicht
in Hamburg nicht so gut auskennen, müsste man vielleicht nochmal kurz beschreiben.
Also dieser eigentliche Event, dieser G20-Event hat sich ja im Messegebiet quasi
niedergeschlagen, was halt mitten in der Hamburger Innenstadt liegt, direkt an St.
Pauli grenzt und insbesondere das Stadion liegt dann mehr oder weniger direkt
neben diesem ganzen Areal.
Daneben ist dann noch der Heiligen Geistfeld, genau, Dom wollte ich gerade sagen,
das ist ja nur der Event, wo dann immer die ganzen Polizeihubschrauber auch
irgendwie gelandet sind. Also das war sozusagen,
enger hätte es eigentlich fast gar nicht sein können.
Ist denn dann dieses Stadion, ich meine, St. Pauli, da reitet dann doch aber
auch die Polizei jetzt mal nicht so eben ein, oder?
Ja, also wir hatten halt ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass das halt unter Presse
fällt und haben auch im Vorfeld versucht bei unserem Innensenator,
dem Andi Grote, tatsächlich, den haben wir direkt angefragt und haben gebeten,
dass er mal eine offizielle Stellung abgibt.
Gilt das jetzt als Pressezentrum oder nicht? Hat er leider bis heute nicht gemacht.
Also ich glaube, er weiß bis heute nicht, was es ist.
und ne, also dass die Polizei da wirklich einreitet, hatten wir halt nur Sorge,
wenn Ausschreitungen sind und man jetzt sagt, okay, man lässt Verletzte zum
Beispiel in den Innenbereich des Stadions rein.
Dann gibt es ja so dieses Problem, der Polizei, die dann da steht und sagt,
okay, da sind aber möglicherweise irgendwie Tatverdächtige und ohne jetzt das
zu beurteilen, ist dann so die Frage, lässt man die rein, lässt man die nicht
rein, muss man sich dann halt vorher überlegen.
War denn die Polizei jemals drin?
Nein, die Polizei war tatsächlich nicht drin.
Also auch nicht in Form irgendeines Vertreters oder nur nicht in Form von Kampfmontur?
Also ich habe tatsächlich keinen in Uniform gesehen und keiner der mir bekannten
Zivilbeamten war da vorstellig.
Okay.
Also da hatten wir halt auch ein bisschen Sorge, dass die irgendwie,
man kriegt das ja manchmal mit, dass dann doch nochmal irgendwie Beweismittelsicherung
durchgeführt werden möchte so.
und wir wussten halt auch nicht, okay,
wie interessant ist das Material, was wir da irgendwie sammeln,
weil wir waren ja im Prinzip so ein großer Datenspeicher,
wo eine ganze Menge Material lag und so ein bisschen war halt schon so,
ja kommen die, kommen die nicht, wollen die das haben, wollen sie es nicht haben,
also man lebt halt schon eine Weile mit einem mulmigen Gefühl da irgendwie.
Aber toi, toi, toi, die haben uns zumindest vor Ort in Ruhe gelassen,
Mit Ausnahme der gefühlt 38 Milliarden Hubschrauber, die da übers Dach flogen und landeten.
Ja, das war eine krasse Akustik die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das war, also wie gesagt, wenn man da drin geschlafen hat,
also ich habe tatsächlich momentan, wenn ich einen Hubschrauber höre,
würde ich ganz irre. Also das trägt noch nach.
schon wieder Kabel rein.
Ich versuche nur den Grund zu finden. Ich glaube, ich komme der Sache gerade
näher. Aber ich höre dir zu.
Das war im Prinzip die Grundidee dahinter.
Und ich glaube, zumindest soweit ich das recherchiert habe, war das das erste
Mal, dass sowas überhaupt gemacht wurde bei einer politischen Großveranstaltung in diesem Format.
Und wir sind, um das mal vorwegzunehmen, sehr zufrieden, was da passiert ist.
Wir glauben, dass da guter Content rausgekommen ist und haben in der Regel halt
auch sehr positives Feedback bekommen, also was die Pressekonferenzen anging,
was die Konserven, die wir produziert haben, anging und generell auch der Ablauf.
Also das Lustige war, wir hatten irgendwann, ich weiß gar nicht mehr von welchem
Medium, der kam dann von dem offiziellen Pressezentrum, kam der dann zu uns
irgendwie rein und der sagte irgendwie, boah, hier gibt es zumindest Catering
und dann auch noch besser als das, was ich sonst gewohnt bin.
Also solche kleinen Anekdoten, da merkt man dann, okay, man hat an allen Ecken
und Enden haben sich halt Leute Mühe gegeben, um das zum vernünftigen Event zu machen.
Hat man auch irgendwie gemerkt, also ich fand, das kam alles sehr...
Also ich will jetzt nicht das Wort professionell benutzen, aber man merkte,
es war irgendwie engagiert und es war technisch auch sehr breitbandig.
Also es ist einfach an viel gedacht worden.
Ja, also ich sag mal, die Technik muss man jetzt fairerweise sagen,
das hat halt zum großen Teil eine Crew gestemmt, die kennt schon Veranstaltungen.
Wie gesagt, die Leute vom Videoteam vom Chaos Computer Club,
die waren da teilweise involviert.
das war jetzt keine CCC-Veranstaltung aber es gab eine hohe Schnittmenge an
Leute was zumindest die Technik anging also so das ganze Streaming-Setup,
da sind ja noch Sachen neu entstanden die zum Beispiel auf dem Kongress nicht
stattfinden wo wir dann nochmal irgendwie ich hab Material aus Berlin geholt
hatte jemanden bei mir im Auto auf dem Beifahrersitz und der hat nochmal irgendwie
kurz einen Converter geschrieben damit irgendwie nochmal Video und Audio-File
synchron in den Stream fließen können auf der Fahrt von Berlin nach Hamburg,
und Und ja, vom Netzwerk, also ich habe hauptsächlich das Netzwerk gebaut,
war halt auch immer so ein Thema, dass dann die Betreiber der Leitung halt gesagt haben, ja,
was ihr da macht, das finden wir ja toll, aber wir wollen damit vielleicht nicht
so unbedingt in Kontakt gebracht werden, also da haben wir dann noch irgendwie.
Was ist jetzt die Provider vom Stadion?
Ja, also der Provider vom Stadion, dem war das relativ egal,
mit dem hatte ich keinen Kontakt, aber die IT vom Stadion, die war sehr engagiert,
die hatten ein cooles Mindset, aber die haben halt auch so gedacht,
ja okay, der nimmt doch unser Netzwerk, wo ich dann gesagt habe,
ungerne, weil wenn ich Netzwerke bauen, verlassen sich die Leute darauf,
dass da nicht gelockt wird, dass da nicht gefiltert wird und den Ruf wollte
ich mir nicht versauen, deswegen haben wir gesagt, wir schalten deren Netz ab,
die war noch so cool und haben das mit sich machen lassen.
Und dann haben wir einfach mal komplett, wie auf allen anderen Veranstaltungen,
wo ich bin, auch Netzwerk, komplett Equipment mitgebracht.
Wer das irgendwie verfolgt hat, wir haben dann auch tatsächlich Infrastruktur
oder Netze von außerhalb irgendwie durchgetunnelt, sodass man eigentlich nicht
sehen konnte, von wo, also wer jetzt eigentlich der Provider dahinter war. Also nicht so einfach.
Also das war, man hat sich halt in alle Richtungen so ein bisschen abgesichert,
weil man wusste halt nicht, wie schlimm wird es wirklich.
Weil da gab es ja viel Ankündigung, ja und da passieren komische Dinge und ganz
viel Sicherheit und doch nochmal, erst waren es 10.000 Polizisten,
dann 15, jetzt 20, SEK und Cobra und so weiter.
Und das ging halt auch in diesen Bereichen, okay, wir wussten,
wir sind auf jeden Fall sichtbar, wir haben auch so tolle Fälle gehabt,
dass komischerweise plötzlich von uns ein LKW, alle anderen LKWs durften durchfahren,
ein LKW von uns wurde direkt vom Stadion angehalten, festgehalten, durchsucht etc. pp.
Also wir wussten, wir sind auf dem Schirm und wussten aber nicht,
gegen was müssen wir uns da irgendwie schützen.
Da geht es ja auch viel darum, wenn Leute Content produzieren,
der vielleicht nicht ganz so genehm ist in der.
Sendelandschaft, dann will man die Leute halt auch schützen und denen Raum bieten,
wo sie ja einen Safe Space vorfinden.
Sowohl sozial, also halt das Stadion selber so als eine Art Safe Space.
Also viele, die ich kannte, die auf Demos auch waren, wir waren dicht an diesem
Arivati Park und Schanzenviertel war halt auch irgendwie 300 Meter entfernt,
also man konnte vom Dach sozusagen die Feuer sehen,
und das war so ein bisschen Safe Space für die Leute, die da eh drinnen waren,
die aber auch mal rausgehen wollten und war aber halt auch ein technischer Safe
Space, dass die Leute wussten, okay, wenn ich hier bin,
ich muss auf mein Gerät aufpassen, aber ich weiß, die Leute,
die es betreiben, die tun mir nichts, die liefern mich nicht aussachlich,
um es mal ganz krass auszudrücken und Und da trifft man dann halt ein bisschen Vorkehrungen.
Ich finde das übrigens ganz dramatisch, weil das ist eine andere Form dieser Geschichte,
wovor man ja immer gewarnt hat, wovor sich das Verfassungsgericht eingelassen
hat bei ihren Urteilen zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Also jetzt da genau dieser Effekt eintritt, dieser Chilling-Effekt.
Ich traue mich gar nicht mehr irgendwie was zu machen, obwohl es komplett legal
ist, weil irgendjemand könnte das später mal umdeuten.
Und das geht jetzt so weit, dass du, du hast zwar jetzt noch Support,
das heißt du hast noch irgendwelche Leute gegeben, die dir noch Dienstleistungen
gegeben haben, aber wenn die jetzt schon hingehen und sagen,
ja mach mal, aber nenn uns bloß nicht, dann sind wir genau da.
Das ist alles komplett legal, was ihr dort tut und auch sinnvoll und hin und
her, aber sie haben trotzdem Schiss.
vor diesem Repressionsautomatismus dieses Staates, vor allen Dingen war es in
Hamburg, wir haben ja mal tief in die Kriegkiste gegriffen, ganz tief,
und wenn jetzt da solche Provider, der Schritt ist jetzt nicht mehr so weit,
dass das nächste Mal oder bei einer anderen Situation der Provider sagt,
ja ich würde gerne, aber ich traue mich nicht, gebe dir die Leitung oder die
Dienstleistung oder sonst sowas, nicht mehr egal, ob du mich jetzt nennst oder nicht,
weil wenn denn die Polizei das rausfindet, dann kriege ich nie wieder einen
Auftrag von der Stadt oder was auch immer da für eine Logik dahinter steckt
und das finde ich sehr erschreckend.
Das finde ich sehr erschreckend, dass das in unserem Land stattfindet schon.
Ja, es ist halt wahr tatsächlich, also ich bin ja nun seit einigen Jahren in
diesem Umfeld aktiv, wo man einfach mal Netze baut, die einfach mal funktionieren
sollen und die mal nicht irgendwie politisch gefärbt sind.
Das heißt einfach mal, hier fällt Internet raus, das kannst du benutzen und,
ja, wenn du Scheiße baust, bist du zwar doof, aber ich kann es hier nicht nachweisen
oder ich logge halt nicht und da kann auch später keiner kommen,
also das ist ja auch das, was...
Nein, die sind nicht ganz ungefärbt, politisch ungefähr. Wenn jetzt der völkische
Beobachter bei euch angeklopft hätte, die gesagt hätte, dürfen wir mal irgendwie
für unsere Sachsen mal live von den Linkskaroten senden, hätte da wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so einen Spaß gemacht, oder?
Richtig, also okay, in dem Sinne schon politisch gefärbt, aber ich versuche
halt nicht so möglichst neutral zu betreiben, sodass ich halt sage,
mir ist es egal, was da durchfließt, in Anführungsstrichen,
und das war trotzdem halt ein mulmiges Gefühl, und das hat sich bei mir auch
sehr stark verfestigt, als dann so das erste Mal mich jemand fragte,
hast du eigentlich anwaltliche Beratung?
Warum anwaltliche Beratung? Ich mache ja nichts. Ich baue ein Netzwerk, das so.
Aber dann hielt es halt doch jemand für sinnvoll, dass man zumindest mal so
die elementaren Teamkomponenten so weit abdeckt, dass da auf jeden Fall mal ein Anwalt am Start ist.
Wenn man Kleinigkeiten Du würdest durch eine Polizeiabsperrung ins Stadion durch
und die würden dich nicht durchlassen. Ist alles nicht vorgekommen. Toi, toi, toi.
Aber womit man sich dann halt schon beschäftigt in so einem Vorlauf,
wo man eigentlich nur Technik baut, fängt man plötzlich an, sein Verhalten zu
überdenken und zu sagen, was tue ich, was darf ich sagen, was darf ich anziehen?
Darf ich einen Rucksack mitnehmen?
Und solche Sachen halt. Also ich bin irgendwann mal, irgendwann habe ich einen
Lagerkoller gekriegt und habe gesagt, ich muss mal raus.
habe mich mit jemandem verabredet zum Essen, hatte die Funke dabei und bin auf
dem Fahrrad nochmal umgedreht,
weil ich dachte, okay, wenn ich jetzt mit der Funke und Knopf im Ohr einen Rasierer
am T-Shirt irgendwie durch die Stadt fahre, die ja komplett leergefegt war,
weil ja alles abgesperrt war und das Einzige, was da war, war halt irgendwie
blau-weiße Autos und Menschen in schwarzer Uniform.
Das war tatsächlich dann so ein Punkt, wo ich gemerkt habe, okay,
das verändert einen dann doch, obwohl man eigentlich nur was Technisches macht,
ist man doch irgendwie dann plötzlich mittendrin.
Weil du gerade sagtest, Anwälte auch, es gibt ja da noch diese andere Truppe
von Freiwilligen, die sozusagen da jetzt, du hast ja jetzt eher so Netzwerktechnik
für Presse, für freie Presse oder wie auch immer,
aber es gibt ja da auch diese Gruppe von Anwälten, die sich da aus der ganzen
Republik zusammensammeln und da auch Schichtbetrieb und tralala machen.
Hattet ihr mit denen irgendwelche Kooperationen oder Berührungen oder sowas?
Meinst du was wie RAV, ne?
Ja, es gab, es gibt diesen Verein, der extra,
nee, Rote Hilfe ist doch noch was anderes, aber es gab extra,
es wurde für die Veranstaltung G20 wurde von Anwälten ein Verein gegründet,
die sich dort organisiert haben und im Prinzip Gefangenenbetreuung,
also der Leute, die in Gewahrsam in die Gefangenen Sammelstelle gekommen sind,
die da im Prinzip unentgeltlich supportet haben.
Die brauchen ja auch Infrastruktur, das wäre ja vielleicht keine schlechte Synergie gewesen.
Ja, also tatsächlich muss ich sagen, wir haben da, wo wir Kunden Sachen angeboten,
wir haben auch in dem Medienzentrum, kann ich jetzt nicht so in Details gehen
aus beständlichen Gründen,
da gab es halt auch so Anlaufpunkte für sensiblere Themen, die wir natürlich
dann auch nochmal gesondert irgendwie betreut haben mit Technik.
Also dieser Anwaltsverein, der sich da gegründet hat, der war einfach geografisch
zu weit weg, weil der war nämlich an der Gesa, also in Neuland,
genau andere Seite der Elbe.
Ja, da war einfach, das war nicht leistbar. Also man darf nicht vergessen,
das war ein Projekt von Freiwilligen, das war alles spendenbasiert,
da hat keiner für Geld bekommen.
Also wenn hier Leute von Urlaub reden, das war mein Sommerurlaub.
Das habe ich gerne gemacht, das haben alle, die da waren, gerne gemacht,
aber das kann man halt auch nur, man hat nur eine gewisse.
Es skaliert nicht so einfach, das ist schon klar. War jetzt nur die Frage,
ob es da irgendwelche, weil die hätten, wäre ja eine schöne Kooperation gewesen,
die hätten deine Laster durch die Sperre gebracht und ihr hättet denen halt
eben auch Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stehen können, die die auch genauso gut gebraucht haben.
Ja, aber das war tatsächlich, da merkt man auch, dass es halt ein,
in Anführungsstrichen Hobbyprojekt oder ein idealistisch getriebenes Projekt war.
Das hat ja nicht stattgefunden, weil wir einfach in Arbeit ertrunken sind.
Ah, okay.
Also wo noch eine Kooperation, da nochmal großen Dank an die Leute von dem Freifunk Hamburg.
Mit denen habe ich was Schönes noch gebaut, so für einen Backup-Fall,
falls tatsächlich der Provider irgendwie weiche Knie gekriegt.
Wir haben dann auch sowas gebaut, wie es gibt eine Funkstrecke,
die wir komplett unter eigener Kontrolle haben mit Endpunkten,
wo ich die Leute persönlich kenne und wo ich weiß, die schalten mich nicht ab.
So dass wenn die Polizei gekommen wäre, hätten wir noch zumindest darüber berichten
können, auch wenn wir uns die Leitung kappen.
Also an dieser Stelle nochmal ein großes Dankeschön, weil die in kürzester Zeit
tatsächlich nochmal ganz fiese Richtfunkstrecken an irgendwelchen komischen
Mauern festgetackert haben,
damit dann quer durch Hamburg an vertrauenswürdige Stellen nochmal so ein Backup-Uplink
vorhanden war, den wir Notfalls hätten schalten können.
Toi, toi, toi, nicht gebraucht, aber war schön zu wissen, dass da ein paar mehr
Leute noch mitgezogen haben.
Wie ist denn das so eine Woche im St. Pauli-Stadion und so als Hass-Fauler?
Im Tempel?
Ich hab's mir extra verkniffen. Ich hab's mir extra verkniffen.
Nee, ganz ehrlich muss ich sagen, ich hab sehr viel Sympathie für diesen Verein gewonnen in der Zeit.
Weil die Leute, also auch von St. Pauli, die waren sehr, sehr cool drauf.
Unabhängig von unserem Projekt haben die ja irgendwann gesagt,
nachdem die ganzen Camps in Hamburg verboten wurden, okay, wir machen jetzt
nochmal hier die eine Tribüne auf, da schaffen wir nochmal 200 Schafplätze,
damit die Leute irgendwie unterkommen.
Die haben eine Vorküge gehabt, also eine Küche, die im Prinzip so aus dem aktivistischen
Umfeld betrieben wurde.
Dafür hatten sie eine andere Tribüne auf. Das heißt, wir haben im Prinzip drei
Tribünen bespielt mit dieser ganzen G20-Nummer.
Einmal das FCMC hat so den Ballsaal, wer das kennt, in St. Pauli-Stadion bespielt
und die Tribüne, da war so die Pressekonferenz ein bisschen chill out.
Die eine Tribüne war halt offen für Schlafplätze und die andere war halt für
so eine aktivistische Küche.
Und das hat mir ganz schön Respekt abgerungen, dass sie wirklich gesagt haben,
okay, wir müssen jetzt mal was tun, wir positionieren uns, weil es ist ja auch
dann für so einen Verein eine Positionierung auch,
Entgegen der, ich sag mal, Interessen der Stadt sozusagen in dem Moment.
Und also die Leute waren sehr cool, die da gearbeitet haben.
Also muss ich halt vorstellen, die kennen mich nicht, ich kenne die nicht und
die geben mir halt einen Schlüssel für ihren Serverraum und für ihre Geschäftsstelle.
das muss man erstmal machen das kenne ich von anderen Veranstaltungen und anderen
Gebäuden wenn man da irgendwie neu reinkommt, ganz anders und da also ich ganz
persönlich habe einen sehr sehr positiven Eindruck gehabt,
von den Leuten die da sind und die haben auf jeden Fall für die Aktionen da
meinen Respekt sich verdient und da,
naja das ist halt für mich war das ein bisschen wie Camp ich habe mir halt irgendwo
eine Abstellkammer wo irgendwie Garderobenwagen standen gesucht da meine Isomatte
hingeworfen und mein Schlafsack,
und ich habe in der Gästekabine immer geduscht, das war sehr interessant.
Wie angemessen.
Also wir durften nicht in die Pauli-Kabine, aber in die Gästekabine durften wir.
Das war schon ganz lustig, wenn man in einer riesigen Kabine durch den Sicherheitsdienst
begleitet, dann durfte man da rein in den Trakt, das ist so wirklich Heiligtum,
genau wie Rasen, nicht betreten, aber ansonsten waren die echt cool drauf.
Also das war trotzdem cool.
Ich muss ja auch dazu sagen, das Stadion hat ja ohnehin auch schon Räume für
die Community, für die Fangruppen und so weiter, das ist ja auch nicht normal
bei anderen Vereinen, also insofern,
Ich hatte auch schon immer eine sehr gute Meinung von dem Verein,
aber das hat es natürlich noch mal ein weiteres Mal bekräftigt.
Definitiv. Also tolle Truppe.
Vielleicht noch mal so zum Abschluss kannst du noch mal ein paar Zahlen so runterrattern,
was da so größenordnungsmäßig so aufgefahren wurde, so technisch.
Technisch, man muss sich vorstellen, also fangen wir mal an mit diesem,
also Kernthema war ja diese Videoproduktionsgeschichten. Wir haben irgendwie
davon vier Studios gebaut.
Studios, wer ein bisschen mal so Kongress schon mal gesehen hat.
Studio entspricht einem Saal.
Also wir haben vier Seele gebaut, nicht für 3000 Leute, aber das Setup halt
viermal dahin gebaut. Wir haben Pressekonferenz-Tribüne gebaut mit irgendwie
drei Kameras und nochmal einen extra Mischer.
Wir haben Dolmetscher, also die Pressekonferenzen wurden simultan gedolmetscht.
Also da gab es dann auch irgendwie, konnte man zwei Sprachen auswählen im Livestream,
also so wie man das halt so ein bisschen kennt.
Das war ganz schön. Wir hatten halt wenig Bandbreite leider,
wir hatten nur 200 Mbit, weil mehr gab es da leider nicht zu holen.
Damit haben wir gearbeitet, haben irgendwie, ich sag mal so,
Datenspeicher einfach in der Größe, ich sag jetzt nicht, wie voll der gelaufen
ist, aber so hatten irgendwie zwei Terabyte nochmal irgendwie für kleinere Dateien,
die Leute eingereicht haben.
Wir hatten 15 Arbeitsplätze, die durch Spenden und Leihgaben zustande gekommen
sind, wo Videoproduktion und Bildproduktion gemacht werden konnte,
also Grafiken und sowas.
und wir hatten größenordnungstechnisch, ich glaube, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
800 akkreditierte Leute ohne Team und hatten halt da nochmal so 200, 230 Leute,
Arbeitsplätze bereitgestellt, die dann halt irgendwie Netze hatten, wo Drucker waren.
Also wir haben halt irgendwie, lass mich lügen, nochmal 40 Access Points da irgendwie verteilt.
Und ja, also ich habe keine Aufzeichnung davon, wie viel Daten durchgegangen
sind, damit ich immer auch sagen kann, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, sehr gut. Aber es war auf jeden Fall schon jetzt auch nicht unkomplex.
Das war, also von der Technik her kenne ich deutlich komplexere Sachen.
Die Komplexität hat sich durch die Logistik ergeben. Also, weil das ganze Ding
war, wie gesagt, spendenbasiert und also ich bin bestimmt, also ohne zu übertreiben,
4000 Kilometer durch die Republik gefahren und Material irgendwie einzusammeln,
hinzubringen, abzuholen, dann wieder zurückzubringen.
Also es war ein logistisches Meisterwerk, weil, was man nicht vergessen darf,
ist, bis zu dem Tag, wo wir eingezogen sind, das war der 2.7., ja, 2.7.
sind wir in das Stadion eingezogen, den Sonntag und in der Nacht von 1. auf den 2.
7. fand aber noch die Abschlussveranstaltung von einer Ausstellung statt im
Stadion und zwar in der Fläche, die wir bespielen wollten.
Das heißt, die haben rausgeschoben und wir haben von hinten dann reingeschoben.
Logistisch war es sehr komplex und die Leute waren halt nicht eingespielt.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass wir das gemacht haben und die haben zwar alle Event-Erfahrung,
aber das Team war neu und in der Geschwindigkeit und mit dem Druck,
den wir arbeiten mussten.
Wir hatten keine 48 Stunden, um das komplette Setup hochzufahren und live zu gehen.
Das war nämlich die Ankündigung in der Pressekonferenz. Wir haben sie gehalten.
Toi, toi, toi. Wir sind Dienstag um 18 Uhr live gegangen.
Das war dann aber auch so, also ich habe 20 Minuten vorher nochmal den Uplink-Komplex
umkonfigurieren müssen, weil das Setup, was wir ursprünglich geplant haben,
nicht gelaufen ist und wir den Fehler nicht gefunden haben mit, ich glaube,
zwei sehr fähigen externen Beratern, die wir da hatten, aber die haben wir nicht gefunden.
Das heißt, wir haben 20 Minuten vor Go-Live, haben wir dann nochmal den Uplink
komplett neu gebaut und er hat gehalten.
Klingt so ein bisschen wie Kongress auf mich.
Nee.
Und habt ihr den Fehler noch gefunden?
Nee. Nein, wir haben es einfach abgebrannt und haben es neu mit einem anderen
Verfahren das wieder hochgebaut.
Kongress ist deutlich entspannter.
Ja, mittlerweile. Aber früher war das ähnlich chaotisch.
Ja, aber man gewöhnt sich halt dran. Man gewöhnt sich dran, dass man da mit
Vollprofis zu tun hat in allen Bereichen.
Und ich habe auch zu einem Kollegen aus dem Clubumfeld, der auch auf der Veranstaltung
war, gesagt, ich bin durch.
Und ich bin einfach durch, weil ich so selbstverständlich einfach gewisse Dinge
erwarte, die aber nicht selbstverständlich sind. Also für alle,
egal an dieser Stelle nochmal, die irgendwie im Kongress mitwirken,
das ist ein anderes Level und das ist deutlich angenehmer und einfacher.
Aber was ich so ein bisschen mitgenommen habe, ist eigentlich,
dass so diese Idee, alternatives Medienzentrum so ein wenig jetzt geboren wurde.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, dass wenn wir nicht das letzte Mal gesehen haben,
dass politische Großveranstaltungen konfrontativer Natur in gewisser Hinsicht
jetzt nochmal so ein eigenes Anti-Wahrheitsministerium bekommen.
bekommen.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, ich kann da jetzt noch nicht viel zu sagen, ich weiß aber, dass,
eine Version 2 davon in einem anderen Kontext auf jeden Fall gerade in Planung
ist, in einem sehr frühen Stadium, deswegen würde ich gar nicht zu viel sagen,
aber tatsächlich, ich denke auch, dass wir es geschafft haben zu zeigen, es geht.
Wenn man will, wenn man genug Unterstützung kriegt, wenn man einfach mal sich
traut rauszugehen und zu fragen, wer hilft, Wer kann irgendwie,
also ich meine, wir haben um Monitore und Tastaturen Leute gefragt,
weil wir die nicht hatten. Also wo sollen die herkommen?
Und das muss man dann einfach mal machen und man muss sich einfach mal hinstellen
und sagen, man geht mal zu einer Location und sagt, ich möchte das jetzt ganz
offiziell einfach mieten.
Und da muss man sich halt irgendwie auch mal trauen zu sagen,
das kriegen wir schon irgendwie finanziert.
Und das ist so tatsächlich so ein Prototyp gewesen, den haben wir jetzt auf die Beine gestellt.
Und ich möchte tatsächlich alle, die irgendwie mal eine Idee haben,
dass sie das in dem Bereich machen wollen, macht das.
Seid ihr denn auf eure Kosten gekommen letztlich? Oder steht da noch was aus?
Wir haben lange jetzt kämpfen müssen, um irgendwie die Kosten zu decken.
Da gab es viele Parteien, die dann nochmal Geld drauf geworfen haben.
Es ist natürlich schon ein mittlerer fünfstelliger Betrag, den man da versenkt,
obwohl es alles ehrenamtlich ist und keiner bezahlt wurde.
Da ist ja, sagen wir mal, jetzt auch für das Ergebnis eigentlich ein Witzbetrag.
Ja, also wenn man es nicht hat.
Hat man es halt erstmal.
Genau, aber das kann man irgendwie finanzieren und fragt die Leute mal.
Also oftmals hilft es einfach, mit Menschen zu reden.
Und ich glaube und ich hoffe, dass wir damit so einen Startpunkt gesetzt haben,
dass die Leute sagen, ja, das kann man machen, man muss nicht irgendwie NDR, ZDF,
RTL oder you name it sein, sondern ich glaube, wir sind da angekommen und wir
haben bewiesen, dass jeder nicht nur Konsument, sondern auch Content Creator
sein kann und einfach mal, das Internet ist jetzt da.
Wenn er sich das jetzt heutzutage noch traut.
Ja, aber ich würde alle bitten, traut euch. Also wenn wir jetzt einknicken und
das aufgeben, dann wäre ich sehr traurig, weil ich dann einfach, ja.
Bietet ja auch einfach ganz neue Gelegenheiten, also wenn ich mir das mal mit
meinem Grundoptimismus so anschaue, also gerade so für Journalisten,
ich meine, ihr habt ja wirklich jetzt mal so ARD gespielt, ich witzel da ja
mal so ein bisschen hier in der Meta-Ebene damit, aber,
nicht weniger war das, ja, da wurde komplette Produktion gefahren,
da hat man Programmleitungen gehabt, da hat man Sendeleitungen gehabt, die Technik war da,
Übertragungswagen. Und ich weiß, wie das aussieht.
Wenn so eine ARD am Start ist.
Naja, ebenso, ich meine, die haben da sehr viel mehr Kohle, die sie da reinschieben können. Oh ja.
Die schöne Erkenntnis ist, man hat halt jetzt auch die Technologien sind jetzt einfach beisammen.
Es ist jetzt auch in den letzten Jahren, insbesondere in diesem VOG Realm natürlich
auch sehr viel Open Source entstanden und solche Ereignisse treiben ja dann
auch die Entwicklung entsprechend voran, um dann sozusagen so auch mal so,
ein Medienzentrum OS zu bauen, dass man sich halt in zunehmendem Maße so direkt
von der Klubpapierrolle abmachen kann, wenn es noch einen Weg zu geht sicherlich,
aber wir sind dem schon sehr viel näher, als er noch vor wenigen Jahren war.
Thema Open Source vielleicht nochmal, für die, die es interessiert.
Wir haben tatsächlich den Stream komplett mit Open Source betrieben und Fun
Fact, alle lächeln ja immer über diese Spieleindustrie oder diese Spieler,
die irgendwie Online-Spiele betreiben.
Also das Programm, was wir da benutzt haben, kommt genau aus dem Bereich,
das ist eigentlich dafür mal entwickelt worden.
Welches?
UBS, Open Broadcaster Software. Und Und das ist eigentlich mal entwickelt worden
ursprünglich, um Leuten, die irgendwie Online-Spiele machen oder die Spiele
machen, das irgendwie live ins Internet zu streamen.
Und damit kann man, wenn man da ein bisschen mit rumspielt und da haben wir
ein bisschen auch rumgedoktert und ein paar Wochen in Vorbereitung gemacht,
kann man da tatsächlich ein Fernsehprogramm draus machen.
Und das war auch, wir wussten auch nicht, ob das geht.
Aber wir haben gesagt, wir machen das und Dienstag 18 Uhr drückte jemand auf
Start Streaming und plötzlich viel was daraus.
Und also kann man sich einfach mal angucken.
CDN habt ihr aber außerhalb gehabt, nicht wie beim Kongress on-site, sondern...
Ne, also wir haben tatsächlich, also wir haben das alles rausgepumpt ins CDN.
Das ist inzwischen auch alles verfügbar auf media.ccc.de oder auf media.fcm.ctv
kann man sich auch alles angucken, in mehreren Sprachen etc. pp.
Und ja, also ich kann alle nur ermutigen, wenn ihr sowas habt,
auch vielleicht in kleineren Kontext, vielleicht muss man nicht mit dem G20 ich anfangen.
Der nächste ist ja auch in einer sehr brisanten Location, dass man da eventuell
mal im Kleinen anfängt und sagt, okay, hier möchte ich Berichterstattung machen.
Einfach machen, traut euch.
Das wäre so meine Bitte, weil dann
habe ich das Gefühl, dass wir was da angefangen haben, was wichtig ist.
Jo, super. Das wollte ich schon immer mal wissen. Klatsch, klatsch.
Ja, ist ja mein Einsatz. schon noch ein bisschen, da geht ja auch eine ganze Menge,
man investiert in so ein Projekt Zeit, Geld, Geld was man nicht verdient,
Geld was man reinsteckt,
Zeit okay der Ahl ist noch jung aber trotzdem,
das war jetzt kein Witz aber das ist jetzt was anderes als zum Bundestagswahlkampf
von Partei X sich mal zwei Stunden am Sonnabend auf den Wahlkampfstand zu stellen
und zu sagen, tu jetzt was für diese Republik.
Ich möchte damit jetzt nicht schlecht machen, aber das ist schon nochmal eine
andere Größenordnung da.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal.
An gesellschaftlichen Engagement. Ich war ganz schön ausgebrannt tatsächlich
danach, was auch viel mit den Randerscheinungen, also das ja nicht nur das FCMC
da war, sondern da war ja noch diese Veranstaltung, dieser G20 mit seinen Auswüchsen,
die da am Rande irgendwie waren.
Und das brennt natürlich ganz schön, wenn man zum Beispiel in diesem Redaktionsraum
steht, in diesem Livestreaming-Raum und dann irgendwie die, wir hatten drei
Kameras auf der Welcome to Hell,
und wenn man natürlich viele Leute da irgendwie hat, die man kennt,
die da vor Ort sind und plötzlich bricht da die Hölle aus, das zehrt schon an
einem, aber man kann da auch vielleicht,
kleiner einsteigen. Man muss ja nicht gleich so bekloppt sein wie ich und sagen,
okay, ich ziehe mir den ganzen Schuh an,
und verbringe da Monate mit, sondern vielleicht einfach mal sagen,
okay, man hört davon oder man hat eine Idee und sagt, okay, ich kümmere mich
jetzt mal darum, dass ich mal zwei Stunden Welcome Desk mache,
dass Leute, die da ankommen, irgendwie wissen, wo sie hinlaufen müssen.
Also nicht immer denken, man muss da unheimlich viel investieren,
sondern einfach also viele kleine Teile bewegen halt am Ende dann das Große
sozusagen und da, ja, einfach machen.
Also man kann heute einfach machen. Wir sind da angekommen, dass wir das Internet
benutzen können und sagen können, ich...
Ja, bestimmt sicher auch ganz viele Mithilfe außerhalb vom Stadion,
die irgendwie euch am Rechner irgendwie helfen, Zeug zu organisieren und zu machen und zu tun, oder?
Ne, das haben wir tatsächlich eigentlich alles intern gehabt.
Echt?
Ja. Also wir haben...
Kein Backup außen irgendwie, die sozusagen frei sich bewegen können und machen und tun können?
Ne, wir konnten uns ja auch frei bewegen. So war es ja nicht.
Wir hatten ja keine Auflagen.
Hätte sich aber schlagartig ändern können.
Können und es, ja, es gibt natürlich, ähm, es gab Backup-Pläne für alle möglichen
Positionen, also hätten die uns, also hätten die uns dicht gemacht,
hätten wir von außen noch darüber berichten können.
Ja, das ging, das hatten wir schon vorbereitet, ne, oder wenn ich jetzt irgendwie,
ähm, man sagt ja mal Busfaktor, ich nenne es mal Wasserwerferfaktor.
Wie viele Leute müssen von einem Bus oder Wasserwerfer überfahren werden?
Genau, richtig, also da gab es dann schon so, okay, wie viele Leute müssen wir
jetzt zum Beispiel mit Anwälten versorgen, weil die extrem wichtig sind,
ähm, und wie viel, und wer macht ein Backup für die.
Also, doof gesagt, wer hat noch das Root-Passwort für den Router? Also, ne?
Und da muss man sich dann überlegen, mit wem spielt man das Spiel?
Und das haben wir natürlich schon gemacht, aber das ist halt der große Kontext.
Aber so generell, ich würde einfach alle bitten, die irgendwie coole Ideen haben,
die meinen, hier muss man drüber berichten, mach das einfach.
Also, im schlimmsten Fall reicht ein Laptop mit der Webcam. Also,
auch damit kann man... Ja, du sagst es gerade.
Ihr habt drei Kameras gehabt auf der Demo selber. Die haben jetzt nicht bloß
rumgeperiskopt, oder sowas, sondern die haben mit euch.
Die haben live gestreamt, ja.
Zu euch rein und ihr habt das dann über euren Mischau und tralala wieder raus.
Okay. Über Mobilfunk oder was?
Genau, das waren dann ähm, ich weiß gar nicht genau, welcher Typ Kamera,
ich bin kein Videomensch, ähm, da klemmt ein LTE-Stick drin mit, ähm,
Sehr freundlichen Tarifen, sag ich mal, die man vielleicht auch nicht so einfach
bekommt, aber die waren zufällig da.
Und da war es tatsächlich möglich, also klar, wenn da irgendwie wir von Welcome
to Hell, ich weiß nicht, was waren da 15.000 Leute oder so auf der Demo,
das mag die Zelle nicht, weil die wollen alle irgendwie sich kundtun und mitteilen, aber es ging.
Also wir konnten tatsächlich relativ gut da irgendwie Berichterstattung,
wir hatten eine Kamera, weil die Welcome to Hell natürlich an der Hafenstraße
lang ging und man kennt ja zwei, drei Leute, die da wohnen und die haben ja auch WLAN.
Da kann man dann sich schon vorher überlegen, okay, an welchen Stellen positioniere ich welche Kamera.
Dann haben halt zwei irgendwie einen LTE-Stick drin, die andere hatten einen
WLAN-Stick drin, die dann halt eher zurückhaltend war.
Aber sowas gibt es, oder gibt es jetzt so Standard-Videokameras,
die man so mit einem LTE-Stick reinstecken kann, wo die auch einen 3-Waffler haben und so?
Das ist geil.
Was ist denn das? Ist das jetzt Sony oder ist das was Speziales?
Nee, das ist einfach, ich glaube, JVC-Kameras waren das.
Okay.
Und das hat halt hier einen USB-Anschluss, kein USB-C, sondern einen alten USB-Anschluss
halt, USB-B, glaube ich, oder wie auch immer sich der heißt.
A.
Und da steckst du einfach, ja, einen Huawei-Stick rein.
T-Punkt irgendwie steckst du da rein, eine SIM-Karte drin.
Du musst ja trotzdem was haben, um das zu aktivieren und so weiter. Das bringen die mit.
Das heißt, die bringen Treiber und so was für so was mit. Da kannst du auf dem
Kameradisplay die Einstellungen machen oder so.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, mussten wir den Pin rausnehmen. Aber dann...
Du musst einfach nur den Standard-APN aktivieren und fertig.
Genau, reinstecken. Und dann sagst du hier, bitte jetzt live gehen.
Und dann, wenn das Netz gut genug ist, dann kannst du da auch anständig irgendwie
720p mal durchpumpen und das juckt den überhaupt nicht.
Was machen die für ein Protokoll?
Ich habe es mir nicht angeguckt, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Also ich habe das Videoencoding, bla,
habe ich mich rausgehalten, ich hatte da zu viele andere Baustellen.
Das heißt, man braucht jetzt heutzutage dafür eben auch nicht mehr diesen tollen,
Fernsehreporter-Rucksack mit 20 Kilo, lalala, pipapo, nimmst du eine JVC-Kamera
für dreistellig, steckst den Huawei-Stick in den Po und kannst da sozusagen
auch Krautreporter dann machen.
Also du brauchst keinen Ü-Wagen mehr, leih dir eine Kamera, klick dir eine Kamera.
Wir sind Ü-Wagen.
Genau, du bist Ü-Wagen, genau.
Eine Ü-Person.
Also das kann man tatsächlich da noch irgendwie...
Aber jetzt ohne Backchannel oder sowas hast du jetzt nicht wie bei anderen Kameras,
dass du da noch sozusagen einen Audiokanal von der Regie hast oder sowas?
Ne, das haben wir anders gelöst. Hast du ihm noch ein Telefon in die Hand gedrückt? Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wir hatten ja, hatte ich ja am Anfang erzählt, wir hatten Besuch von der BNES
A, weil die unsere Funkgeräte und Verstärker sich angucken wollten.
Und so ein Stadion hat ein ziemlich hohes Dach.
Man kann da ganz tolle Antennen anbringen. Wenn die dann von der BNES A abgenommen
worden sind, also abgenommen sind von ihr dürft die betreiben.
Genau, wenn wir einen Kleber bekommen haben und einen Stempel mit einem Adler
drauf, dann darf man die da oben auch hängen lassen.
Und das ist ganz interessant, wie weit man dann doch mit einem Repeater,
der in der Toleranz, aber am Grenzbereich fährt, funken kann.
Und dann, was wir gemacht haben, jede Kamera hat eine Funke bekommen.
Und dann konnten wir aus der Regie praktisch dann mit denen funken und mit dem
Tool, mit dem OBS, was ich gesagt habe, kann man dann halt auch,
schon mal so ein Preview-Bild machen, dann kannst du mit denen über Mikrofon
mit denen sprechen, ja geh mal lieber dahin, zieh dich mal zurück oder auch
eine Info rausgeben, Achtung, Wasserwerfer fährt an,
geh mal da aus dem Bereich raus und das war,
Obwohl man im Stadion war, war man halt irgendwie doch mittendrin,
zumindest die Leute im Regieraum, die dann halt irgendwie Access auf die Funken
hatten und die halt dann über einen rebieteten Kanal auch alles,
wie gesagt, egal, alles irgendwie erlaubt, muss man sich auch vor ein bisschen darum kümmern.
Aber das kann man dann schon machen. Das läuft ganz gut.
Hier kam gerade ein Link rein das ist von so einer JVC Kamera mit LTE ist das
so in etwa so das Modell hier von der Optik her von der technischen Beschreibung
her passt es also so LTE macht Live Streaming.
Ich glaube in dem vielleicht sogar noch mal kleiner so optisch würde ich jetzt
fast sagen, aber so in dem Bereich.
Wir sind im richtigen Bereich GY-HM850 HM890 wird hier genannt und da ist halt
hier so, kann irgendwie auf FTP hochladen und kann aber auch irgendwie Live
Streaming wobei sie jetzt hier gerade mal nicht sagen, was genau,
aber im Prinzip das, was du gesagt hast.
Ist halt alles möglich. Also einfach so ein USB.
USB oder WiFi.
Genau, einfach reinkloppen und dann RTSP.
RTP, RTSP.
Genau, die machen einfach RTSP und fertig.
Zixi natürlich mal wieder.
Keine Sau, wie es wird, Zixi ist.
Das ist so eine Fehlerkorrekturgeschichte, keine Ahnung, ob das ein Standard ist.
Und das ist noch X264, demnächst kommt ja dann X265, dann geht dann noch ein
besseres Bild noch kleiner drüber.
Aber wie gesagt, hier geht es darum, erst mal zu machen.
Wir betrachten das ja auch technisch. Richtig. Aber wie gesagt, man kann das machen.
Also wenn die neuen Formate kommen, die besseren Kameran, dann werden die alten
günstiger. Guckt mal auf dem Gebrauchtwarenmarkt eurer Wahl.
Wenn euch das interessiert, einfach einen LTE-Stick rein klemmen,
Karte rein. Wenn ihr T-Mobile-Karte habt, kann man ja für einen Fünfer irgendwie
am Tag Unlimited sich klicken.
Und dann kann man schon mal so ein Event-Bit leiten. Fakt euch vielleicht nochmal
zwei, drei Akkus in den Rucksack und dann läuft das.
Da war jetzt nur mal so eine Frage, weil du das erwähnt hattest,
dass du ja Kameras hattest und wir sind ja auch ein marginal technisch angehauchter Podcast.
Ich hörte davon.
Und deswegen dachte ich, ich frage da nochmal, hast du sonst noch irgendwelche
coolen Basteleien oder sowas?
So wir machen was, wofür die AAD einen fetten Ü-Wagen irgendwo hinkarrt,
das haben wir ja mit Leuten auf Fahrrädern gebaut oder irgendwie sowas,
so in dieser großen Ordnung.
Ja, nee, haben wir jetzt so nicht gehabt, da fehlte uns die Zeit,
wir hatten ein paar Ideen tatsächlich,
ich weiß aber nicht, ob die funktionieren würden, deswegen bin ich da jetzt
vorsichtig mit, aber ich sag mal so,
was halt ganz schön ist, was sowas wie die ARD oder so nicht kann,
weil die müssen ja erstmal einen Stempel haben, da muss irgendwie bei SAP im
Programm eine Genehmigung erteilt werden,
das war halt viel schöner, weil jetzt zum Beispiel diese 200 Betten da freigegeben
wurden im Stadion, haben wir dann, oh, wir haben noch WLAN-Hardware,
oh, wir haben noch Richtfunkantennen.
Und dann haben wir die einfach mal bei uns mit angeklemmt. Und solche Sachen
halt dann machen zu können, das war schon ganz schick.
Aber so wirklich technische Spielereien, da freue ich mich dann eher auf Ende des Jahres wieder.
Leibsch.
Ja, genau. Also es war relativ plain, es war nicht fancy. Es gab irgendwie V4, V6 halt, also Internet.
Und konnte jeder benutzen.
Ja. Aber so nichts, was irgendwie jetzt wirklich erwähnt wird,
ist, was über dieses Kamerasetup irgendwie hinausgeht.
Also, schönes Videosetup gehabt, schöne Synchronisationsgeschichten drin gehabt,
die waren ganz fancy, aber so rein infrastrukturtechnisch ansonsten war das,
ein Event-Netzwerk, aber kein besonders fancy.
Gut abgehandenes.
Ja, wir haben auch auf uralte Gebrauch-Tatware zurückgreifen müssen,
weil woher kriegst du jetzt mal irgendwie zwei WLAN-Controller,
woher kriegst du mal irgendwie schnell ein paar Access-Points,
weil die Anfrage bei mir halt auch sehr spät reinging und die Anforderungen bei mir,
also der Netzplan und die ganze Idee und Materialsammlung hat sich in vier Wochen abgespielt.
Und da hast du nicht viel Zeit, gerade weil ich tatsächlich das zumindest planungstechnisch
alleine begleitet habe.
Ich habe während der Veranstaltung dann ein paar Aktivisten,
die da noch vorbeikamen, die auch ein bisschen was mit Netzwerk konnten,
die habe ich mir dann noch gegriffen und irgendwie einfach gesagt,
so, du gehörst jetzt dazu, hier ist dein Platz und hilf mir.
Weil ich kam einfach irgendwann nicht mehr hinterher.
Aber Fancy war da nichts, es war herausfordernd aufgrund der geringen Zeit und
der Umstände drum herum.
Ja, super. Super Bericht. Müssen wir aber langsam auch wieder auf die banalen
Bedürfnisse des modernen Luxuslebens im 21.
Jahrhundert und sonstigen Konsumschwächen zu sprechen kommen.
Man kann sich ja nicht immer nur mit Zukunfts- und Politik beschäftigen.
Ja, hast du hier Gläser? Weil wir müssen uns jetzt was? Wir müssen uns jetzt
eine sich langsam erwärmende Cola teilen hier.
Dennis und ich. Wir haben ja eure Fanta-Vorräte schon vollkommen weggedanft.
Unsere Fanta-Vorräte haben wir jetzt schon Nein, das ist eine eiserne Reserve hinten.
Jetzt wird erstmal das andere Zuckerwasser hier geteilt. Dankeschön.
Okay, Dennis, dann bist du ja schon ausreichend bezuckert. Wollen wir dann vielleicht
nochmal den Nachklapp zur letzten Sendung mal machen?
Weil da ist ja dann doch auch echt einiges passiert.
Der geneigte Hörer, die geneigte Hörerin wird natürlich wissen, was jetzt kommt.
Was? Nein.
Ja, wir haben uns ja über den Bitcoin-Skid unterhalten und der Dennis hat dann
irgendwie so eine technische Breitseite gefeuert.
Na, das war ja letztens hauptsächlich.
Aber mir fehlte dann in der Nachberichterstattung, fehlte mir dann irgendwie
so ein Begriff, der irgendwie nicht gefallen ist.
Ja, das lief auch alles so ein bisschen gleichzeitig und das war ja auch mehr
so eine Androhung und dann weiß man nur, wie machen die das jetzt wirklich und so weiter und so fort.
und sie haben es aber auch gemacht und da sind halt Leute, die sind der Meinung,
so wie das mit dem Bitcoin Core läuft,
sind sie nicht so einverstanden, sie wollen gerne größere Blöcke,
weil das Bitcoin-Net ist ja gerade voll, deswegen sind die Gebühren so hoch,
weil nicht alle Transaktionen in einen solchen Block passen.
So und die nennen sich Bitcoin Classic, der Client dazu heißt Bitcoin ABC,
also die haben natürlich einfach den Code kopiert und so ein paar Änderungen
vorgenommen und die haben dann irgendwie kurz nach dem 1.
August einen Block gemeint, der tatsächlich größer ist als ein Megabyte,
was von dem normalen Bitcoin Core ja nicht akzeptiert wird.
Und genau an dem Tag hat sich die Blockchain dann geforkt. Das heißt,
die gibt es jetzt ab dem 2. August zweimal.
Das heißt, auch jeder, der zu diesem Zeitpunkt auf der originalen Blockchain,
wie viele Bitcoins auch immer hat, der hat jetzt, sagen wir mal,
5 Bitcoins, aber er hat auch 5 Bitcoin Classic. Du hast das jetzt, du hast jetzt zwei.
Classic oder Cash? Cash heißt das doch.
Cash, ja, warum sage ich eigentlich mal Classic?
Das weiß ich auch nicht so ganz genau. Ja, Cash war es.
Du hast heute irgendwann mit Classic angekommen.
Nein, nein.
Nicht?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht. Also nochmal, ich fasse mal mit meinen Worten zusammen.
Also es gibt Bitcoin seit Jahren, wir haben viel darüber geredet.
Manche Leute haben welche, manche haben sie nicht. Wer auch immer sie hatte, hat nach so einem Fork.
Das ist ja das, was Fork eigentlich auch sagt. Also wer den Begriff nicht kennt,
Fork kommt ja so aus dem. Auf dem GitHub?
Nein, Vorkommt eigentlich aus der Unix-Welt. So hat man ja einen neuen Prozess gestartet.
Man startet ja einen neuen Prozess, indem man erstmal den existierenden,
Doppelt, quasi klont eigentlich. Das ist halt der Fork, da gabelt es sich sozusagen.
Und dann gibt es erstmal dasselbe zweimal und so ist es ja hier quasi auch.
Man hat jetzt quasi so zwei Welten, bloß die eine, die ich jetzt Classic eigentlich
nennen würde, also das klassische Bitcoin, was jetzt nach wie vor,
Core, genau Bitcoin Core, das klassische Bitcoin, das lebt natürlich einfach so weiter.
aber dieser andere Ast, der halt irgendwie größere Blöcke haben will,
das sind halt irgendwie jetzt New Kids on the Block Train. New Kids on the Block Train.
Naja.
Pun intended.
Die Hälfte der Hörer weiß nicht, was gemeint ist.
Das macht nicht.
Die andere liegt unterm Dritten. Von daher ist das egal.
Ich fand den jetzt gar nicht so schlecht. Der war gut.
So, und die haben ja sozusagen die alten Datenstrukturen so,
ne, man hat da ja auch was, die Frage, der Unterschied ist ja nur,
wenn sozusagen die anderen nur dem einen trauen und dem einen weiterminen,
dann lebt das halt weiter und man ist dann sozusagen allein in der Garage.
Das ist aber jetzt so nicht passiert, sondern wie ich das verstanden habe,
haben ja durchaus sich auch ein paar Miner da drauf geworfen,
weil auf einmal zumindest kurzfristig da einfach auf einmal solche Steigerungsraten,
weil das wurde ja dann auch bewertet, ne, also diese neue Währung,
die quasi die abgekoppelte alte Währung ist.
Hat natürlich auch einen Kurs.
Hat dann auch schnell einen Kurs bekommen, weil Leute irgendwie bereit waren,
auch da in die Zukunft zu vertrauen, warum auch immer.
Und ich weiß nicht, was ist jetzt so der derzeit gängige?
460, 70 so Euro.
460 Euro. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt einen Bitcoin besessen hat,
zu diesem Zeitpunkt des Splits, der dann ja ungefähr 3.000, 4.000 Dollar wert war zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Oder war das danach? Das war vorher, glaube ich.
Ein bisschen weniger wahrscheinlich. 2.000, 3.000 irgendwie.
Ein bisschen mehr.
Und danach hat man nicht nur diesen einen Bitcoin, sondern man hat sozusagen
auch automatisch einen Bitcoin Cash, der jetzt irgendwie wie ein Wunder auch
auf einmal Geld wert zu sein scheint, weil es Leute gibt, die dem jetzt zumindest vorher...
Man könnte jetzt sagen, das hört sich ja so ein bisschen wie Free Money an.
Ja.
Man muss aber auch sagen, es könnte aber auch sein, dass die Bitcoin Core Einheit
genau um diesen Wert weniger wert geworden ist. Also wahrscheinlich werden das Bitcoin...
Cash jetzt absterben würde, würde wahrscheinlich diese 460 Euro zu den Bitcoin rüberwandern.
Also sozusagen die klauen sich gegenseitig die Energie, könnte man so ein bisschen auch denken.
Also es ist nicht so ganz einfach, dass man sagt, ich kriege hier Geld geschenkt,
sondern wahrscheinlich fehlt es dafür auch so ein bisschen auf der anderen Seite.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, dieser neue Brand, dieses Bitcoin Cash ist ja auch deshalb
gewählt worden, weil man jetzt so dieses hippe irgendwie, ich bin das Bitcoin,
mit dem man mal schnell was bezahlen kann, ohne Stress.
Ja, nee, weil gar niemand nimmt Bitcoin Cash an, weil das ist ja nicht mehr
so richtig kompatibel mit dem anderen Bitcoin.
Du musst das jetzt schon ja getrennt behandeln. Du brauchst einen anderen Klein,
wenn du damit jetzt auch kassieren willst. Das machen viele noch nicht.
Die Exchanges natürlich schon, weil denen ist es ja egal. Die wollen ja Geld
verdienen. Die ziehen das schon nach. Manche sagen aber auch,
sie machen das erst Ende des Jahres.
Also das ist alles nicht so ganz einfach.
Das Interessante aber daran war, also weil du ja schon meintest,
die Miner haben das ja dann schon benutzt.
Das liegt daran, dass so ein Miner, der will natürlich Geld verdienen,
der guckt sich natürlich an, was kann er mit seinen ASIC Minern,
wo verdient er Geld und wenn der sieht,
hier bei Bitcoin Core, da ist es ja voll kompliziert, da muss ich ja so und
so viel Strom in ein Bitcoin setzen, was mir irgendwie 4000 Dollar bringt.
Aber hier bei Bitcoin Cash muss ich deutlich weniger reinstecken und kriege
aber immer noch trotzdem 460 Euro.
Also das heißt, die gucken, was sich am meisten lohnt und springen dann halt da drauf.
Warum muss man da jetzt weniger reinstecken?
Na, weil die Difficulty, das ist ja, bei Bitcoin Core gab es ja auch die Difficulty,
wie schwer es ist, einen Block zu finden, wo jetzt gerade 12,5 Bitcoins rauskommen.
Die ist runtergesetzt worden.
Und genau, dieser Bitcoin Cash, die haben den Algorithmus so gemacht,
dass er sich irgendwie schneller anpasst. Die haben so ein, EDA heißt es,
Emergency Difficulty Adjustment oder sowas.
Das heißt, wenn da lange nichts gemeint wurde, was ja der Fall,
also das haben die halt vorgeplant, dass die Miner halt gar nicht darüber springen,
weil sie weiterhin einfach Bitcoin Core minen, haben sie das schnell angepasst.
Die Difficulty ist tierisch abgesackt.
Die Miner haben das gesehen, oh, da ist die Difficulty gerade so günstig,
wenn wir da minen, verdienen wir mehr Geld als hier und schwumm, alle rüber.
Also nicht alle, aber so deutlich.
Und dadurch aber, weil das hat komplexe Auswirkungen, haben die dann bei Bitcoin
Cash so alle 1-2 Minuten natürlich einen Block gefunden und alle 2016 Blöcke
passt sich ja die Difficulty wieder an, so wie bei dem Co.
auch ganz normal und dann ist sie natürlich sofort wieder um 300% gestiegen,
die meine haben das natürlich sofort gesehen und schwupp weg waren sie wieder,
das heißt das ist so 3-4 mal so hin und her oszilliert und jetzt hat sich es gerade eingepegelt.
Der Nachteil ist aber, dass Bitcoin...
Cash, ich muss vorher aufpassen, dass ich nicht Classic sage, Bitcoin Cash,
dadurch, dass die Blöcke da so schnell gefunden wurden, sind jetzt irgendwie
so 2.000, 3.000 Blöcke voraus im Gegensatz zu Bitcoin Core und alle zwei Jahre
oder 216.000 Blöcke passiert ja diese Blockhalbierung,
also dieses, wie viel Bitcoins man pro Block bekommt.
Und was jetzt bei 12,5 ist, das wird dann auf 6,25 gehen.
Und Bitcoin Classic ist natürlich jetzt schon ein bisschen schneller in diese Richtung gezischt.
Und wenn der Tag kommt und deren Output auf die Hälfte sinkt.
Nicht Bitcoin Classic, Bitcoin Cash.
Bitcoin Cash, ja. Wenn das dann auf die Hälfte sinkt, dann haben sie ja wieder
einen Nachteil gegenüber dem Bitcoin Core.
Und dann wechseln die Miner noch seltener, weil nur noch die Hälfte rauskommt.
Also es hat alles Auswirkungen und so. und teilweise haben die das so ein bisschen
vorgeplant, aber nicht so ganz perfekt.
Deswegen ist alles noch nicht so ganz klar. Aber das mit dem Oszillieren hat
jetzt anscheinend aufgehört.
Die haben sich jetzt so ein bisschen eingepegelt und jetzt läuft eigentlich
alles gerade so sehr human parallel.
Der Kurs von dem Cash ist auch ein bisschen abgesackt, aber hat sich jetzt auch
so wieder ein bisschen gehalten, so 460 rum, weil letzte Woche war dann noch so bei 550.
Und jetzt muss man mal gucken.
Ja, ich glaube, also aus meiner Perspektive ist so, der Reiz an diesem Cash
ist halt, ich meine, es gibt ja, haben wir ja auch in der letzten Sendung gehabt,
ne, es gibt so an die 100 Kryptowährungen, die derzeit so unterhalten werden.
Ja, so Richtung 1000 eher.
What?
Also auf diesen Portalen, von denen du auch meintest, waren so 100.
Ne, da haben wir doch mal runtergescrollt, da waren wir doch bis 700 gekommen
schon, das ist doch ein paar Wochen her.
Es gibt auf dem iPhone so eine App, die heißt 9, könnt ihr mal installieren,
da sind alle Währungen gelistet und da scrollt sich.
Okay, dann war es tausend.
Ich habe eine Stelle vertan. Also, da wird viel experimentiert.
Jeder Hannes und sein Bruder macht sein eigenes Ding da.
Ja genau, aber die haben ja auch alle andere Algorithmen und brauchen alle andere
Hardware, also mag sich ähneln oder so, nur das neue Bitcoin Cash ist ja quasi
derselbe Kram wie Bitcoin.
Genau, der hat den gleichen Mining-Algorithmus.
Genau, das heißt, da gibt es viel Hardware da draußen, da gibt es viel Knowledge
darüber, wie man das sozusagen fährt.
Das ist irgendwie dem ganzen alten Ding irgendwie relativ nah.
Und ich habe so den Eindruck, dass sich dieser Kurs, der ja eigentlich auf den
ersten Blick durch nichts gerechtfertigt ist, weil ja, keiner hat den Client
installiert, die Leute haben das, wissen das aber eigentlich gar nicht, dass sie das haben.
Es ist ja alles noch so total in so einem Chaos-Zustand, aber dass man eben einfach sagt, naja,
aber vielleicht ist das ja sozusagen so eine Zweitwährung,
die irgendeine andere Rolle mal spielen kann und die jetzt sozusagen einen Vorsprung
hat gegenüber den ganzen anderen Ideen, weil sie halt eben auf so viel bekanntem
und bereits etabliertem Fuß vielleicht halt auch am Ende nicht.
und es stellt sich raus, nee, da ist only one Bitcoin und mehr wollen wir irgendwie
nicht haben und das kümmert dann vor sich hin.
Na, das kann man ja nicht so absehen, was da nun genau kommen wird,
aber dass sie sich natürlich jetzt mit Brüsten, dass sie ganz geringe Transaction
Fees haben, also Gebühren,
weil die Blöcke halt nicht voll sind, ist halt auch deswegen,
weil es halt niemand benutzt, also ist halt alles leer, was,
ich meine, die brauchen gar keine größeren Blöcke als ein Megabyte,
weil, also haben die schon welche erstellt, aber weil stundenlang halt keine
von den Minern gefunden wurde, aber die haben sozusagen, dass die Probleme,
die das originale Bitcoin Coat haben, die nicht, weil es halt nicht benutzt wird.
Wie der John Gruber immer sagte, ich gehe nicht in das Restaurant,
das ist doch scheiße, weil da ist immer voll.
Das ist ungefähr so, als ob, genau, bei Bitcoin sind die Busse alle voll und
bei dem neuen Bitcoin haben sie jetzt irgendwie sich größere Busse,
aber da fährt halt keiner mit.
Genau.
Und das könnte sich vielleicht nochmal ändern, aber vielleicht halt auch.
Und dann glaube ich auch, dieses Segwit, was ja auch ein bisschen,
wie sagt man, kontrovers gesehen wird.
Ich denke schon, dass es die Grundlage für ganz viele Dinge ist.
Es geht jetzt schon auch einigermaßen los, dass sie da anfangen,
das zu benutzen und das haben die bei Bitcoin...
Cash? Ja, auch nicht. Das wird demnächst fehlen als Merkmal,
dass sie halt keinen Segregated Witness da haben und dann gucken wir mal, wie das da abgeht.
Aber ich glaube auch, die Währung wird nicht so schnell absterben,
weil wenn man sich dieses Coincap, diese 700 Kryptowährungen anguckt,
da ist wirklich jeder Idiot und sein Bruder macht Kryptowährungen und die werden
da alle, auch wenn es Mikrocent sind, werden die da gelistet und wenn eine Währung
erstmal da ist, dann verschwindet die nicht.
Also bevor einer sagt, ich schmeiß die jetzt weg, sagt der andere,
ja, aber ich zahle dir ein hundertstel Cent pro was auch immer Einheit.
Also irgendeinen Wert wird irgendwas immer haben. Es ist einfach so und deswegen, ja.
Ja, vor allen Dingen glaube ich, Bitcoin Cash, nachdem es ja ein Fork war,
existieren ja die Coins bei den Leuten da draußen.
Also das ist ja eine Währung, die vorher in Betrieb war.
Jetzt halt irgendwie viele Leute vielleicht nicht mehr wissen,
dass sie das noch haben oder noch kein Interesse daran haben,
aber im Prinzip sind halt die Coins verteilt und können nach wie vor getradet werden.
Na hier, Bitcoin Cash hat auch an Market Capitalization, haben die auch Platz
Nummer 3 natürlich gleich eingenommen.
Also Nummer 1 ist natürlich Bitcoin an sich, dann kommt glaube ich Ethereum
und dann kommt schon Bitcoin Cash mit, was haben die hier, Market Capitalization
von knapp 8 Milliarden Dollar.
Das Bitcoin selbst hat 62 Milliarden Dollar.
Also die Seite sagt hier 75 für Bitcoin und 9 für Cash.
Ja, ich glaube bei mir war Euro jetzt gerade nicht.
Ah, okay.
Aber sind auf jeden Fall Platz 3 von allen Kryptowährungen. Das ist schon nicht
so schlecht, so mal aus dem...
Sind aber nur kurz über Ripple XRP, was auch immer das ist.
Na, Ripple ist halt.
Wende ich auch nicht so gut, aber ist auch so eine Kryptowährung.
Naja, man muss halt gucken, was da passiert. Aber wenn es erstmal stabil ist,
können die auch eigentlich nebeneinander leben.
Und was ich vielleicht aber jetzt noch kurz erklären sollte,
ist, wie man dann an seine Bitcoin Cash-Münzen rankommt.
Wie kommen wir an unser Geld?
Also sagen wir mal, wir nehmen jetzt mal an, du hast irgendwie mal so eine Handvoll Münzen, ja?
Ja, habe ich.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal an.
Habe ich.
Wenn du die jetzt nach dem 2. August noch nicht weiter berührt hast,
dann hast du da erstens eine riesen Blockchain liegen von deinem Client und
zweitens halt diese Wallet.dat-Datei, wo deine Münzen drin sind oder besser gesagt die Kies dafür.
Was man jetzt machen muss, ist...
Also, sagen wir mal jetzt, man hat den Bitcoin Core Client, den originalen.
Dann kann man jetzt diesen Bitcoin ABC installieren, der findet da die Blockchain,
sieht auch die gleichen Münzen, nur dass es jetzt halt Bitcoin Cash ist und
man könnte die dann irgendwo hin ausgeben.
Das Problem ist aber, dass der Client irgendwie nicht so ganz klar kommt,
weil er sieht ja auch jetzt schon Blöcke, die zwar einen, wie soll man sagen,
der sieht den Fork sozusagen nicht.
Du musst jetzt den Block, den Bitcoin Core damals gefunden hat,
den muss man für illegal erklären, damit der Block, der größer als ein Megabyte
war von Bitcoin Cash, damit der gefunden wird. Hat das jemand verstanden?
Das ist noch nicht gesicherte Erkenntnis, aber...
Na, so habe ich das gemacht.
Ach, der Client ist es.
Aber der hat doch eine klare Nummer, dieser Fork. Also ich meine, da kann man auch...
Ja, aber das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Aber dieser Client hat das nicht hartgecodet
in sich reinprogrammiert.
Ach so.
Weil das macht man eigentlich auch nicht.
Der geht sozusagen davon aus, dass...
Die längste Kette gewinnt. Und die längste Kette ist ja auch für ABC legal,
weil alle Blöcke sind ja kleiner als ein Megabyte.
Andersrum natürlich nicht. Der Core würde diesen 8 Megabyte Block oder den größer
als 1 Megabyte nicht annehmen, aber andersrum ja schon.
Und deswegen muss man mit einem speziellen Kommando, muss man den bestimmten
Block, den Core gefunden hat, den muss man löschen oder für illegal erklären.
Damit dann… Dass man sozusagen eine Blockchain-Kopie hat, die ausschließlich
die alten Dinger enthält.
Genau, und jetzt mit APFS könnte man sich auch prima eine Kopie machen,
weil es macht zack und die Kopie ist da.
Und dann hat man das zweimal, habe ich jetzt nicht so gemacht.
Ich habe mir auch Sicherheitsgründen das alles auf eine US kopiert,
wo nichts drauf ist, damit dieser Bitcoin-ABC-Client halt nicht an meine Bitcoin-Keys
rankommt, falls der irgendwie kaputt ist oder Malware-Scam, was auch immer ist.
Also ich habe meine Münzen sozusagen vorher erstmal zur Seite geschoben.
Und dann diesen Bitcoin ABC meine Wallet gegeben. Die war sozusagen Bitcoin
Core-mäßig leer, Bitcoin Cash-mäßig noch nicht, weil war ja nach dem August
und so weiter. Also ist alles ein bisschen komplex.
Kommt vielleicht in der Sendung auch nichts rüber, kann ich es schwer erklären.
Aber wenn ihr das macht, da gibt es Anleitungen im Netz und macht das ordentlich und vorsichtig.
Und da muss man ein bisschen sich mal hinsetzen und das in Ruhe machen und aufpassen,
weil je nachdem, wie viele Coins ihr da habt, kann das ja auch schon eine Menge Geld sein.
Ist dieses Bitcoin ABC auch ein Fork von dem Core Ja, eindeutig.
Haben so ein paar Sachen geändert, aber eigentlich auch nicht allzu viel.
Weil, ja, GUI-mäßig mussten die, glaube ich, auch gar nicht so viel ändern.
Naja, sie hätten mal eins bauen können.
Ja, nee, das ist ja alles zu viel Arbeit. Das wollen die alle nicht.
Wir haben alle wie die Weltmeister und haben dann das Limit von 1 Megabyte auf
8 Megabyte hochgestellt und noch so zwei, drei kleinere andere Änderungen und
das war's halt. Also so richtig viel ist da noch nicht passiert.
Tja. Na gut.
Was habe ich sonst noch so auf meiner Bitcoin-Liste? War da noch irgendwas?
Du hast irgendwelche Links da noch mit irgendwelchen Wallets und Krypto-Exchanges.
Genau, also wenn man die Bitcoin-Cash-Münzen hat und man will die loswerden,
man kann die natürlich prima auch wieder nach Bitcoin tauschen oder andersrum.
Ihr könnt das ja auch andersrum machen, wenn ihr das Bitcoin-Core nicht glaubt
und ihr meint, Cash ist die Zukunft, dann könnt ihr natürlich auch in die Richtung
das tauschen, je nachdem.
Oder ihr tauscht gar nicht, aber wenn ihr tauscht, ist eine Empfehlung von mir
dieser Crypto-Exchange Changely.
Da kann man halt mehr oder weniger, ohne dass man seine Münzen,
irgendwo zwischenlagert, kann man sagen, ich hätte gerne jetzt von Cash nach
Core irgendwie die Münzen und dann überweist man an eine Adresse und dann dauert
es bei denen eine Weile und dann verticken die das bei irgendwelchen anderen
Exchanges und dann bumm,
kriegt man auf seine andere Adresse seine Münzen zurück. Also das ist so Input, Output fertig.
Hat es ja letztes Mal schon erwähnt, den Dienst, da gab es dann in den Kommentaren
aber so einige Zurückhaltungen von Leuten Also ich habe denen auch schon viel benutzt.
Und meine Kumpels auch und bisher hat sich noch keiner beschwert.
Du und deine Kumpels auf der Blockchain.
Die Ja, ich und meine Kumpels Meine Kids.
Mein Blockchain Ja,
Deine Chain Deine Chain Gang Dann schmeißt doch nochmal hier deine Wallet irgendwie
rein Du hast doch hier noch so eine Hardware Wallet Genau.
Habe ich auch mal mitgebracht,
Kann man schwer erklären, aber die Idee ist...
Wir beschreiben das jetzt mal, was wir sehen. Wir sehen mal so einen typischen
Taschendongel mit so einem kleinen...
Also wir reden von Tresor mit Z.
Tresor mit Z, mit so einem kleinen Schlüssel. Ja, sieht eigentlich aus wie ein
Autoschlüssel, aber da kommt da was wie ein Display oder sowas raus.
Genau, hat keine Batterie, weil kriegt erst Strom, wenn man da USB ranmacht.
Hat unten ein USB-Löschlein, ein Mikro-USB-Löschlein.
Gemacht ist das Ding von einem Typen aus Prag.
Und zwar heißt der mit Nickname Slush. Das ist auch einer der,
oder das ist der erste Bitcoin-Pool, den es gab.
Also der Typ ist auch schon seit 2010 irgendwie dabei.
Und die Idee an dem Ding hier ist, wenn du deine Bitcoin-Adresse,
wenn du die auf deinem Rechner erzeugst, dann ist ja da auch sozusagen der Private
Key ist auf deinem Rechner.
Das heißt, wenn irgendjemand deinen Rechner übernimmt, da ist der Key eventuell
weg, wie es ja auch schon passiert ist. So, man kann den verschlüsseln,
aber in dem Augenblick, wo du dann was bezahlen willst, muss der entschlüsseln,
schwupp, ist der Key weg. Also wie auch immer, irgendwann ist der Key weg.
Und mit dieser Hardware-Wallet ist es so, dass der Key auf diesem Gerät erstellt
wird und du schließt ihn an deinen Rechner an und überweisen kannst du auf die Adressen ja immer.
Also dazu brauchst du das ja Gerät nicht online machen, sondern du merkst die
Adresse und dann kannst du da hin überweisen.
Aber wenn du halt von dem Tresor überweisen willst,
dann machst du das hier mit so einer Web-Oberfläche, die sich irgendwie zu dem
Ding connectet und signiert wird auf diesem kleinen Teil,
also deine Keys verlassen dieses Ding nicht und was du signierst wird hier im
Display angezeigt, also welcher Betrag auf welche Bitcoin-Adresse und dann musst
du auf diesem kleinen Ding bestätigen und dann drückst du und dann verlässt
es das Gerät wieder, aber der Key bleibt immer hier drauf und.
Das ist dann sicher. Eigentlich wie so eine Art TAN-Generator von einer Bank,
nur dass diese Ding hier noch ein schöner Display hat und dir vorher sagt,
was du da gerade signierst.
Wie die TAN-Generatoren das eigentlich auch machen sollten.
Und werden jetzt keine TANZ generiert, sondern die ganze Krypto ist halt einfach
ein PKCS-11 Device oder sonst irgendwas, nehme ich mal an.
Na, die machen hier sogenanntes HD-Wallet, das heißt hierarchisch deterministisch,
die jetzt erzeugen einmal so ein Random Seat, von dem aus dann alle Keys deterministisch
sozusagen erzeugt werden können.
Du hast also auch, du kriegst 24 Wörter, was der Key ist, das heißt,
wenn das Ding hier verloren geht oder kaputt geht, dann nehme ich meine 24 Wörter,
mache die in einen neuen Tresor rein und dann weiß er das wieder.
Und auch alle folgenden Adressen, man erfolgt ja für jede Überweisung,
die du drauf machst, erzeugt er danach eine neue Adresse, damit du immer das
schön auf Adressen verteilst und nicht alles auf einer landet,
damit man nicht sehen kann, wie viel Geld du eigentlich hast.
Soll man ja so machen. Das ist die HD-Wallet. Und das macht das alles so.
Und das Schöne auch für die Hacker, die sich damit beschäftigen wollen,
man kann ja auch anders so Passwörter speichern oder generieren und man kann
auch sein SSH damit machen.
Das heißt genau das Gleiche. Du kriegst dann so einen neuen Agent hier,
so ein Tresor-Agent heißt das.
Der connectet sich hier hin, guckt, ob das alles passt. Du musst hier auf diesem
Ding bestätigen und dann kannst du dich irgendwie einloggen und vorher geht das nicht.
Das Secret Key verlässt sozusagen auch nicht deine...
Das habe ich mir jetzt noch nicht so genau angeguckt, weil da weiß ich nicht,
wie das geht, aber so beschreiben die das.
Dass das geht. Ja, im Prinzip, ich meine, ich nehme mal an, dass das Protokoll
so ist, dass dieser Key selber nie das Gerät verlassen kann.
Ja, sonst würde es ja keinen Sinn machen.
Ja, sonst würde es ja auch keinen Sinn machen. Das heißt, man kann quasi SSH
von Maschinen aus machen, auf denen man gar keinen Key abgelegt hat.
Man muss halt nur über USB was ranstecken dürfen.
Genau, und das ist auch egal, ob der Rechner übernommen ist,
weil der Key verlässt deinen kleinen Tresor nicht.
Außer sie finden halt einen Exploit über USB, aber die komplette Software von
dem Tresor ist Open Source. Auf GitHub kann man sich alles angucken, und, ja.
Naja, es ist nicht ganz egal, wenn jemand deine Kröte übernommen hat,
dann wartet der einfach darauf, bis du das Ding reinsteckst und dann legt der los.
Ja und dann, ich bestätige ja nicht, du siehst ja hier, wo du dich einloggst,
du siehst ja den Fingerprint zur Not vom Server oder bei Bitcoin siehst du Adresse.
Wo du hinüber weißt. Bei SSH zeigt dir der auch jetzt erstmal an,
was du da gerade connectest.
Habe ich jetzt noch nicht gesehen, gehe ich aber ganz stark von auf,
weil das Prinzip ist ja einfach so.
Das heißt, in dieser langen Anleitung oder diesem Review, den ich gefunden habe,
das ist wirklich der längste Review, den ich je über irgendein Device gesehen
habe, also den sollte man, wenn man sich für Tresor aktiviert,
sollte man sich den angucken, weil der hört wirklich gar nicht mehr auf.
Also auch mit Screenshots von allen einzelnen Vorgängen und so,
da habe ich gescrollt und gescrollt und gescrollt und es hat überhaupt nicht mehr aufgehört.
Okay, ja, das ist extensive. Verstehe. Mir war das gar nicht so klar,
dass das Ding quasi auch über hier.
Da siehst du zum Beispiel schon, da zeigt es ja hier, wenn du auf das Bild da
mal klickst von dem Tresor jetzt.
Das zeigt dir jetzt dann hier auch an, wie das so aussieht und wo du dann bestätigen
sollst und so. Das ist jetzt aber glaube ich zum Bezahlen, kann das sein?
Weiß ich nicht, hab grad nicht gesehen.
Also es gibt sowas ja schon länger in der Kryptowelt, deswegen guck ich gerade
PKCS-11 Devices, wo du halt eben auch Private Keys und Zertifikate und so ein
Zeugs da rein klatschen kannst.
Was ich kenne, ist halt so dieser Yubi-Key, aber der hat halt kein Display.
Du weißt ja nie, was du da gerade genau drückst.
Aber Yubi-Key ist eigentlich nur in deinem Normalfall einfach nur eine Tastatur
Das ist ein Human Input Device, der in dem Moment auf den Knopf drauf drückt,
halt Dinger rein tippt, als Tastatur Dinger eintippt.
Was ich jetzt wirklich meine, sind eben diese Devices, wo du nicht nur den Private
Key, sondern auch die Kryptomechanik in dem Ding drin hast, sodass der Private
Key das Ding nie verlassen muss.
Ja, ist ja hier so. Der erzeugt den Key auch selber.
Übrigens wie eine SIM-Karte auch. Eine SIM-Karte, das selbe Spiel.
Das Private Key und die Kryptomechanik drin.
Kommt sozusagen nur Challenge rein, Ergebnis raus und die ganze Krypto findet
in dem Ding selber statt.
Außer man sagt, man will keine.
Klar, nee, aber ich sag nur, wenn du da Krypto machen willst,
dann macht der sozusagen die wichtigen Operationen auf dem Ding selber.
Das heißt, da kann keiner dir die...
Naja, dann kann dir immer noch das Ding klauen, aber gut.
Naja, da ist noch ein Pin drauf und den gibst du auch nicht,
an deinem Rechner ein, sondern am Rechner kommt nur so ein Feld mit neun Tasten,
aber unbeschriftet und auf dem kleinen Tresor kommt auch,
kommen die neun Tasten beschriftet, aber in random Reihenfolge,
das heißt auf dem Rechner musst du zwar klicken, aber so wie es auf dem Tresor
angezeigt wird, so dass der Rechner auch nicht weiß, welche PIN du da eingegeben hast.
Wollte dich gerade fragen, wie gibst du mit zwei Tasten in den PIN ein?
Du machst das auf dem Rechner, aber der Rechner weiß nicht, welche Tasten er was bedeutet.
Ja, Roddy zeigt mir das immer alles, gerade was du erklärst in diesem Review oder sowas.
Also das Review ist wirklich, also das ist mal ein Review.
Ja, krass. Gibt ein Sternchen.
107 Euro.
Ich hab da in Prag bei Satoshi Labs, nennen die sich, direkt bestellt.
Das kostet irgendwie 89 Euro, aber da ist halt noch keine Mehrwertsteuer dabei und kein Shipping.
Also am Ende hab ich dann doch 120 bezahlt oder so.
Aber es ist halt ein Tresor, da geht's um Sicherheit. Da wollte ich nicht bei
Amazon bei irgendwelchen Leuten bestellen.
Und nicht so gemeint mit 107 Euro. Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Ich wollte nur sagen, dass man bei so einem Weißes vielleicht an der Quelle
bestellen und nicht bei irgendwie.
107 Euro geben die Leute auch für so ein Lederportemonnaie aus.
Ja.
Ich bin auch nicht unbedingt Nerds.
Gut.
War das das alles da? Ja, das war es erstmal.
Dann kommen wir mal zu Urlaub.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Was ist eigentlich Urlaub? Wie muss man sich eigentlich fühlen?
An der Stelle möchte ich mal kurz auch auf die letzte oder vorletzte,
ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist
es auch schon die vorletzte Ausgabe von Methodisch Inkorrekt verweisen.
Die beiden Herren stellen ja immer so wissenschaftliche Studien vor und die
letzte Sendung vor der Urlaubsphase war grandios,
weil unter anderem halt Studien über Urlaub vorgestellt wurden und was denn
Urlaub sozusagen lebenswert macht und was dazu führt,
dass Urlaub einen glücklich macht und positiv in Erinnerung bleibt und generell
einem die Investition sozusagen wert erscheint.
Das kann ich jetzt in der Gänze und Breite nicht wiedergeben,
aber es waren so ein paar grundlegende Feststellungen drin, wo man dann schon
so innerlich so ein bisschen rumnickt und denkt so, ja, so habe ich da noch
nie drüber nachgedacht, aber jetzt,
wo ich das so mal an mir selber überprüfe, da ist da schon was dran.
Your mileage may vary, also so Sachen wie Urlaub ist schon mal generell dann
besser, wenn du ihn irgendwie mehrere Monate, also umso länger du ihn gebucht
hast, dann kannst du die ganze Zeit dich schon mal drauf freuen.
Das mal sozusagen schon mal so als Faktor.
Also Spontanreisen sind eigentlich eher nicht so...
Genau, sowas.
Spontanveranstaltungen.
Oder wie verteile ich die Aktivitäten innerhalb meines Urlaubs?
Wann sollte ich sozusagen anfangen, so richtig in die Vollen zu gehen?
Und wann sollte man eigentlich eher so ein bisschen runterfahren?
Sinuskurve quasi soft einsteigen, volles Aktivitätsdrama so in der Mitte entfalten
und dann möglicherweise... die letzten Tage vorher nochmal runterfahren.
Aus verschiedenen Gründen, die ich jetzt nicht zusammenfassen kann,
aber das hat mich auf jeden Fall sehr in Wallung gebracht, darüber nachzudenken,
was mich eigentlich froh macht.
Und ich habe halt festgestellt, dass ich, also mich macht ein Urlaub,
oder mich macht ein Urlaub vor allem dann froh,
wenn ich Netz hab. Also dieses,
Urlaub ohne Internet, ich weiß es, es gibt da so eine romantische Verklärung
mit ach Junge, lass doch mal das Gerät zu Hause und immer diese Daten und das
willst du doch gar nicht und dann bist du ja immer,
erreichbar und so und ich meine, okay, jetzt predige ich hier wahrscheinlich
zu den Konvertierten bei uns ist es ja eigentlich genau andersrum also so dieses
nicht erreichbar sein, irgendwie, das macht einen ja so unruhig.
Also schlechtes Netz macht einen total fällig.
Wenn es mit dem erreichbar sein, das ist auch so ein altes scheiß Klischee,
was ja schon vor 25 Jahren, als wir GSM angeknipst haben in Deutschland,
immer propagiert wurden.
Ich habe damals schon immer gesagt, ich muss jetzt ja nicht selber erreichbar
sein, ich finde es gut, wenn ich jederzeit andere Leute erreichen kann.
Das ist halt einfach mal...
Oder Informationen.
Aber Aber ich meine, man muss jetzt auch mal gucken, wenn man über Urlaub redet,
da gibt es jetzt schon unterschiedliche Bilder von, wie so ein Urlaub aussieht.
So das klassische Bild, so für die CDU und CSU-Wähler unter unseren Zuhörern,
das kennen die denn so, ist so,
Papa geht arbeiten das ganze Jahr und kriegt dann irgendwann mal 14 Tage Urlaub
und Mama lässt dann auch mal die Schürze fallen und die Kinder haben dann auch
irgendwelche Schulferien und dann fahren die zusammen irgendwo,
packen die ihr ganze Zeugs ein und fahren unter dem üblichen Gequengel irgendwo
in die Berge oder ans Meer.
Egal, so das ist ja so der Klassiker, oder? So richtig Klassik,
so mit allen Klischees, die man so finden kann.
Und das trifft aber auf, denke mal, so auf uns eigentlich auch gar nicht so zu.
Weil wenn ich jetzt mal so in die Runde schaue und ich weiß ja auch,
was wir alle so gegenseitig so machen oder sowas, das passt ja so gar nicht.
Also vielleicht wirst du es noch, hier so diese Familienväter wie so diese Roddis
oder sowas mit einem geregten Job oder sowas.
Aber auch du, deine Kids sind ja noch nicht schulfein, oder? Oder schulpflichtig.
Der Große, der kommt jetzt in die Schule.
Das heißt, du fällst jetzt auch so ein bisschen in diese Slotted Urlaubsbusiness mittelfristig Ja.
So ein bisschen schon. Deswegen bin ich dieses Jahr noch mal so früh gefahren,
weil irgendwie ich es mir noch mal leisten konnte, die Jungs irgendwie außerhalb
der Ferien zum Urlaub machen zu schleppen.
Was sich jetzt so wettermäßig nicht so gut gemacht hat, weil das war genau in
der Woche, als Berlin abgesoffen ist und es an der Ostsee auch ein bisschen
geregnet hat. Aber ja, ja.
Aber ich will nur sagen, also Urlaub ist jetzt, man kann jetzt nicht sagen,
es gibt den Urlaub. Den gibt es nicht.
Aber ich habe dieses Jahr, hatte ja auch schon mal erwähnt, ich habe mir so
einen Wohnwagen zugelegt und bin da ganz begeistert davon.
Das ist wirklich toll und ich habe es tatsächlich geschafft,
in diesem Sommer irgendwie 31 Übernachtungen in diesem Gerät abzufeiern.
Einen ganzen Monat.
Einen ganzen Monat habe ich sozusagen im Wohnwagen, also jetzt nicht am Stück.
Hast du da eine Strichliste in deiner Bank oder so? wie im Knast oder jede Nacht so.
Nö, aber ich meine, das konnte ich jetzt irgendwie vielleicht nicht an einer
Hand, aber an wenigen Händen abzählen und wenn man das jetzt mal so intensiv
auch tut und dann auch noch mit dieser ganzen,
Frühbegeisterung von neues Device, ja, ich meine, der ganze Wohnwagen ist für
mich ja ein neues Device,
was man alles da so entdecken kann, wo da so Rohre lang gehen und
wie kommen denn überhaupt die Kabel, wie ist denn das mit der Batterie verschaltet
und wo muss ich denn jetzt hier eigentlich einschalten, um heißes Wasser zu
bekommen und so, diese ganzen tollen Dinge, die ja dann alle auch immer so einen
geilen Luxusfaktor haben.
Ich meine, ich habe ja nun auch
schon irgendwie so mein Festivalleben irgendwie in allen erdenklichen,
erbärmlichen Übernachtungsszenarios verbracht so und irgendwann ist dann halt
auch mal gut so und jetzt fand ich sozusagen dieses andere Extrem einfach extrem unterhaltsam.
Tür auf rein, warm.
Mückenfrei.
Ja, und dann morgens erstmal so aufstehen, so schön aus den Federn irgendwie
aussteigen, erstmal einen Kaffee machen und alles da und Kühlschrank und so, geil.
Und Netz. Genau, dann halt Netz.
Und auch so richtig nerdmäßig, man kommt so an und kaum, dass das Ding einfach
nivelliert ist, also die Stützen ausgefahren sind und man sich so mit Wasserwagen beschäftigt hat.
Du hast doch schon die LTE-Antenne nachnivelliert.
Muss man erstmal schauen, wie ist denn das jetzt hier eigentlich mit Strom und
wo kommt denn irgendwie das Netz her und so.
Boah, Tim spießt auf.
Das ist aber schon gewagt.
Tim spießt auf.
Nee, momentan ist er an Amateur-Level. Er lässt die Stützen runter,
bevor er weiß, ob er da Strom oder Netz hat.
Nein, so wollte ich das jetzt nicht sagen, aber naja, egal, man muss es sich
ja dann teilen, also wenn das mal so einfach wäre.
Wie auch immer, die vor ein paar Sendungen hat sie ja diese Fritzbox,
die 6820 mal ein wenig gelobt.
Und so ein Gerät habe ich dann auch im Einsatz, habe mir dann,
weil ich ja so eine Hardware-Null bin,
habe ich mir dann irgendwie auf Amazon irgendwie so ein Umbau-Kit für 30 Tacken
irgendwie geklickt, wo so ein paar kleine Bauteile drin sind,
die man sich wahrscheinlich auch hätte billiger besorgen können,
aber naja, war halt schon so fertig mit so einer kleinen Austausch.
Wofür musst du noch sagen?
Um halt die LTE-Antennen, die defaultmäßig so kleine Mini-Platinen im 2-3 cm
Format sind, die im Gerät sind, dann entsprechend extern rauszuführen mit diesem SMA Steckern.
Also ein Kabel.
Um sich da ordentliche Antennen ranmachen zu können.
Damit man irgendwie mal ordentlich Dings hat.
Ist da eigentlich auch eine Stummel-Antenne dabei, wenn man jetzt nicht die
Mega-Antenne aufs Dach klemmen will, sondern das Ding weiter so als 68.
20 Minuten oder sowas Geld. Bei diesem Umbaus-Head nicht dabei,
aber die habe ich mir halt noch dazu geholt, also so zwei kleine Flügel-Klangen,
die man so ranballert und hab mir dann so aus Spaß an der Freude halt auch nochmal so ein,
4G-Flach-Planar-Antenne geholt, die man so schön mit,
Saugnapf sich an irgendeine Wohnwagenseite ranballern kann, Kabel irgendwie
rausgeführt und dann kann man halt auch noch direkt da irgendwie so in die Richtung leuchten.
Mit Kabel rausgefüllen ist es nicht so einfach.
Ne, ist nicht so einfach, aber da habe ich auch schon Lösungen für gefunden.
Glasbohrer.
Ja, ne, du hast ja dann, das gibt ja dann schon immer so, du hast ja dann schon
mehr oder weniger so Bettkästen, direkten Zugang zu Laderäumen,
wo es dann auch nicht mehr so,
wo du nur noch ein Loch finden musst, dann bist du da vorne bei den Gasflaschen
und da ist ja dann sowieso ein Loch im Boden, weil das Gas ja da rauslaufen muss im Notfall.
Ja, aber dazu gleich nochmal pro Tipp, keep the antenna cable short.
Sonst hast du den ganzen Gewinn, den mit deiner schönen X20DWM Antenne,
die du da draußen einfängst, das pumpst du alles in das Kabel rein und mehr
und dann bist du hinterher schlechter als mit der Stummelantenne.
Am rumspielen und ich wollte vor allem erstmal möglichst viel halbwegs finanzierbares
Zeug dabei haben, damit ich dann sozusagen vor Ort alle Optionen habe,
überhaupt erstmal nichts zu haben.
Hast du die Antenne dann auch ausgemessen, weil die Box hat ja so einen Ausmessmodus,
wo die Leuchtdioden dann auf Pegel umschalten, dass man seine Antenne dann drehen
kann und der zeigt dann relativ schnell den Pegel an.
Das Ding war jetzt auf der letzten Tour, wo ich wirklich alles dabei hatte,
während es noch bei den Festivals davor...
Also ich fuhr sozusagen auf dieses Gelände direkt an so einem LTE-Mast vorbei,
wo wirklich so alles drauf war und an dem Punkt, wo ich dann war,
blickte ich wirklich nackt auf dieses Gerät in 200 Meter Entfernung und von
daher konnte ich sogar noch,
ohne externe Antennen, selbst wenn ich noch alle meine Alu-Lichtschutz,
Verschließscheiben zumachen, hat er immer noch Aber diese besseren Antennen so.
Die bringen schon was. Das ist kein ESO-Scheiß, und das bringt auch nicht nur
so ein bisschen, sondern so richtig ordentlich?
Naja, bessere Antennen kannst du vor allen Dingen dann benutzen,
wenn du draußen, sagen wir mal, einen Richteffekt haben willst.
Das ist zum Beispiel durchaus, noch haben wir ja immer so ein bisschen,
gib dir mal ein ganz banales Beispiel, noch haben wir ja immer noch in Teilen
UMTS am Start, wird zwar zurückgerollt und wird auch nicht mehr neu ausgebaut, aber gibt es noch.
So, das kann durchaus sein oder sagen wir mal wie Edge oder wie auch immer,
jetzt springst du dieses Ding am Start und der sucht jetzt alle möglichen Netze
und findet alle möglichen Scheiß, findet aber eben auch den, den er am besten findet,
das ist aber nicht das, was du haben willst, aus welchen Gründen noch immer.
Ist jetzt ein theoretisches Beispiel, weil du kannst nach Fritzburg auch sagen, mach mal nur LTE.
Aber du kannst dann dadurch hingehen, durch deinen Richtfunk,
erstens hat du normalerweise Gewinn, den du hoffentlich nicht wieder auf 10
Meter Antennenkabel wieder verknallst.
Aber du kannst dir dadurch eben auch trotzdem deinen Dienst aussuchen.
Du kannst auch zum Beispiel deiner Fritzbox an der Ostsee sagen,
selbst auf polnischer Seite, nein, wir holen jetzt mal lieber das LTE von der
Telekom aus Deutschland, anstatt halt eben den nahen Mast zu nehmen,
den du normalerweise vielleicht gar nicht sehen würdest mit deiner Stummelantenne.
Weißt du, also für solche Sachen ist das gerade auf Reisen, ist das nicht blöd.
Weil zu haben, wo du zumindest so eine Richtung vorgeben kannst,
zu sagen, nee, ich möchte lieber das da hinten.
Ja.
Ist da natürlich mehr Fummel, ist jetzt, wir sind noch einfach tariflich noch
nicht in der Situation, wo du einfach sagst, ich fahr meinen Spargel aus und
egal, was ich kriege, ist mehr, kostet alles das selber und bla und blub.
Ja, weil wir haben ja zum Beispiel, wir haben zwar jetzt EU-Roaming,
aber das gilt leider nicht für Dayflat, ha ha ha.
Ja.
Und solche Sachen, das heißt, du willst eben dann unter Umständen wie gerade
eben sagte, an der polnischen Ostseeküste möchtest du halt gerne mal rüber über
den wie heißt dieses Ding da, nicht Bodden, sondern die sind da Grenze?
Grenze ja auch, aber willst du auf die anderen Seite dieser Bucht mal gucken,
was da so steht zum Beispiel,
oder auch Rügen ich hab's jetzt auch auf meiner Fahrt nach Schweden gemerkt
diese Dinger, die treffen sich ja fast da gibt's auch Netz an Bord,
das stinkt aber wie immer dafür aber umsonst, aber,
wenn du dich draußen hinstellst,
du verlierst die deutschen Netze nicht komplett, bevor du die schwedischen siehst oder die dänischen.
Es gibt auch Stellen mitten auf der Ostsee, da machst du mal so Netzsuche,
dann macht er so Grübel, Grübel, Grübel, Grübel und du hast den ganzen Bildschirm voll.
Mit Netzen, weil du, weißt du, ich vier dänische Netze siehst,
vier schwedische, drei deutsche und dazu noch das von dem Boot,
die sind Maritimzeugs und da noch seinen doofen Bruder von. Egal.
Hast du die Antenne dann auch da so ein Löchlein gebohrt und dann so herangesteckt,
sodass es halt so ein bisschen stabil ist oder hast du die irgendwie da so durchgeführt,
die baumelt dann irgendwie so rum und bringst sie um anders an?
Also so eine Stabantenne, jetzt nicht deine Fläche natürlich, aber...
Na die Stabantenne ist jetzt einfach erstmal direkt an der Box,
damit ich die einfach irgendwo durch die Gegend tragen kann.
Ich habe ja noch so einen Akkupack, wo auch irgendwie...
Ja, aber die Box hat ja keinen Ausgang. Das heißt, du musst ja entweder das Kabel da rausnehmen.
Das ist ja dieses Kit, was er da kommt hat.
Ich habe dieses Kit gekauft.
Achso, ist das mit Gehäuse oder was?
Wenn du die 6820 auseinander machst.
Habe ich ja schon, habe ich ja schon getweetet.
Genau, da sind dann die Ausführungen, wo die Ethernet-Buchse ist und so weiter.
Da ist so ein Plasteteil, so ein Halter dafür.
Und da kommt mit dem Kit kommt halt ein neuer, wo dann zwei Löcher für diese SMA-Schraubbuchsen.
und die schraubst du dann da ran, machst sie mit einem kleinen Ringschlüssel
richtig schön fest und dann klemmst du das einfach alles wieder zusammen und
klemmst halt vorher die internen Antennen ab und machst halt dann diese Kontakte
von diesen Buchsen da ran und dann hast du quasi das, was du vorher auch hattest, nur eben extern.
Richtig profimäßig anscheinend.
Es war, hat funktioniert und war jetzt, ich habe die Investition jetzt nicht
bereut, hat funktioniert und dann habe ich mir halt, wie gesagt,
noch diese kleinen Stummelantennen gekauft, damit ich erstmal einen Start hatte
und dann habe ich halt so ein bisschen geguckt, was mache ich jetzt noch,
was ist, wenn ich da jetzt so mal so richtig schlechtes Netz habe und dann habe
ich keine Richtantenne, sondern so eine kleine Planarantenne, die,
angeblich laut Katalog 35 dBi machen soll, was irgendwie sehr viel zu sein scheint,
was ich auch irgendwie erstmal nicht so glaube, aber naja, gegen was.
Ist halt die Frage.
Ich verstehe diese Einheit auch nicht so richtig weil ich habe so andere mega
teure, super High-End Antennen die dann mit sehr viel niedrigeren Werten kommen,
deswegen ist das irgendwie nicht so vergleichbar. Kann man das jemandem mal erklären?
Die einen sind wahrscheinlich in alle Richtungen und dein Teil ist halt nur
in eine bestimmte Richtung.
Also es kann sein, dass sie gegen einen Kugelstrahler vergleichen,
was so viel heißt wie gar keine Antenne.
Und dann mag das durchaus sein.
Sorry, Lerik, hab gerade nicht aufgepasst. Was war deine Frage?
Was einem diese DBI-Werte eigentlich real sagen, weil es gibt halt so 17-Euro-Antennen,
die irgendwie 35 DBI-Gain versprechen und andere haben nur sehr viel weniger
und sind sehr viel teurer.
Und ich hab überhaupt keine Ahnung, ob das so ein Boguswert ist,
der einem eigentlich überhaupt nichts sagt.
Naja, DB ist ja immer ein Vergleichswert.
Genau.
Also du vergleichst ja immer gegen irgendetwas.
Ja, DBI-Vergleich gegen was?
Das weiß ich nicht genau, aber es kann sein, dass es gegen einen Kugelstrahler
vergleicht und das wäre dann keine Antenne in dem Sinne, weil ein Dipol ja schon
mehr macht als einen Kugelstrahler.
Ich sehe schon im Chat, komm so, sowieso art-typing. Jetzt kriegen wir gleich
wieder richtig auf die Omme. Ja, richtig so.
Waren die Antennen bei dem Set dabei?
Auf den erdachten Isotropen-Kugelstrahler.
Also ich kann das Set mal kurz raussuchen.
Das kannst du mal verlinken, weil das hätte ich auch gerne.
Ja.
Bist du schon fertig mit deinem Fritzbuff? Weil ich habe ja auch ein bisschen rumgefoggt.
Ja, ich weiß, dass du da auch noch was hast. Lass mich mal kurz überlegen.
Also grundsätzlich kann ich bestätigen, mit dem Ding hat man eigentlich viel Spaß.
Mit diesem externen Dingsbums kann man halt schön rum experimentieren.
Ich habe dann halt noch mir so einen Akku gekauft, hatte ich ja neulich schon
mal erzählt, der auch so einen 12-Volt-Ausgang hat. Ich bin damit auch noch so ein bisschen autark.
Jetzt bin ich gerade dabei, das halt so direkt an meine Batterieinfrastruktur
ranzublanschen und Kabelverlegen und so weiter.
Das geht ja alles ganz schön, ein Anfang ist gemacht.
Ich suche das jetzt mal raus und du kannst ja mal deine Erfahrungen mit der Fritzbox.
Ich wollte das Ding ja auch,
Und eigentlich, das habe ich noch nicht gemacht, aber ich bin ja auch am Basteln
noch irgendwo einsetzen, wo ich halt nicht so guten Empfang habe oder wo eigentlich
niemand guten Empfang hat, aber es gibt dort schon ein Wäldchen in der Nähe.
Das heißt, man muss einfach eigentlich nur eine bessere Antenne haben.
Aber ich hätte dort halt keinen Strom, weil das ist halt auch mitten im Wald sozusagen.
Und ich habe ja von deinem Akku da gehört mit den 12 Volt, das Ding wäre mir
aber ein bisschen zu fett gewesen und vor allem auch ein ganz schöner Preis.
Das war ja auch nicht so billig jetzt dein Ding, 150 Euro oder was?
Ja, es gibt ja auch noch andere mit 12 Volt, die sind ein bisschen günstiger.
Ja, aber ich dachte mir, das muss ja noch irgendwie anders gehen und hätte es
halt gut gefunden, am besten, wenn das Ding halt dann doch irgendwie mit 5 Volt
funktioniert, weil die normalen USB-Akkus da haben alle 5 Volt.
Und deswegen bin ich halt hier zu Segor gefahren, habe mir den passenden Stromstecker
für dieses Ding ausgesucht, den ich gleich getestet habe.
Ich habe zum Glück auch gleich, der erste Stecker war gleich der,
der gepasst hat von den hunderten Steckern, den die da haben, den Stromstecker.
Segor ist hier so der angesagte Elektronik-Höcker in Berlin.
Ja, wer Segur nicht kennt, der hört jetzt eh nicht mehr zu, oder? Kann Segur nicht?
Komm ich aus Berlin?
Weiß ich nicht.
Nee.
Ist der weltweit bekannt?
Ach, Dennis.
Europaweit.
Du bist deutschlandweit. Nicht mal Deutschland. Okay, Kreuzberg.
Nee, Kreuzberg.
Charlotte Mo.
Nein, das ist so wie Reichelt oder Konrad, aber es ist halt so ein ganz kleiner
Laden, so wie eine Apotheke.
Die Preise sind auch so ein bisschen wie eine Apotheke, aber du kannst halt
hier in Berlin, du kannst halt direkt hinfahren und kannst sagen,
ich brauche hier diesen...
74 08 Stein abmal oder so. Oder du sagst, du brauchst jetzt hier das und das.
Die haben immer alles da und der Typ hinter dem Tresen weiß,
wovon du sprichst. Das ist der große Unterschied zu Konrad.
Und vor Jahren, das war total geil, da hatten die auf dem Tresen so ein Diskettenlaufwerk,
für 3,5 Zoll und dann hast du deine eigene Diskette mitgebracht,
hast sie da reingesteckt, auf den Knopf gedrückt, dann hat das Ding ein wenig
gerattert und dann hast du den aktuellen Katalog von denen mitnehmen können.
Aber ist schon ein paar Jahre mehr her, ne?
Das ist schon ein paar Jahre mehr her.
Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Das kann mir heute keiner mehr lesen, deswegen.
Jedenfalls bin ich da hingefahren, habe mir den richtigen Stromstecker gesucht,
damit ich dann halt meinen eigenen Strom da machen kann, um das Netzteil nicht
zu zerstören und habe mal probiert,
wie viel Volt das Ding denn so braucht und habe, ich habe zu Hause so einen
Akkupack, wo sechsmal so eine AA-Zelle reinpasst, also sechsmal 1,2 Volt,
nee, nee, sechsmal 1,2 sind ja.
Ja, 1,2, ich habe jetzt 1,5 gerechnet.
Naja, Akkus, Akkus.
Okay.
Du willst ja nicht Batterien nehmen, Akkus. Die haben ja nur 1,2.
Also eigentlich haben sie auch ein bisschen mehr, aber egal.
Jedenfalls ist das so 7,2 Volt. Hat das Ding gleich funktioniert.
Hab auch die Karte reingemacht. Hier Link LTE hat funktioniert.
Die 6820 läuft mit?
6 mal AA-Zelle. 7,2 Volt. So, jetzt warte.
Dann hab ich probiert, okay, 7,2 oder 7 Volt ist ja komisch so,
weil am Ende braucht das Ding ja wahrscheinlich sogar wirklich nur 5 und der
Wandler, der da 5 erstellt, der braucht halt 6, so wie man das kennt von so
einem 7805. Der braucht immer so ein Volt mehr.
Also habe ich gedacht, probier es nochmal mit fünf Zellen, was ja immer noch genau sechs Volt sind.
Hat nicht funktioniert. Also er braucht schon anscheinend so ein bisschen mehr als sechs Volt.
Das heißt aber, man kann sich halt so einen Akkupack holen, diese schwarzen
Dinger, die so, ja, wo man halt Batterien so mehrere reindrückt.
Dann gibt es auch bei Sega.
Genau. Dann packst du sechs so Batterien rein und dann hast du was für unterwegs,
wo das funktioniert. Ich habe auch durchgemessen, wie viel Strom das dabei so braucht.
4 Watt habe ich gemessen.
Ich habe Ampere gemessen, bei meinen 7 Volt ich angebe, und das waren halt immer
so zwischen 300 und 400 Ampere.
Nee, Milliampere.
Ja, Milliampere.
Und die Batterien haben ja so 3000, wenn man diese XX-Zellen nimmt oder wie
die heißen. Also kommst du damit locker so 8 bis 10 Stunden hin, würde ich mal sagen.
Sag nochmal, wie viel Milliampere bei wie viel Volt?
7,2 Volt, so 300 bis 400 Milliampere.
Also er bootet mit viel weniger, so zwischen 100 und 200, aber wenn das LTE
oben ist, dann ballert er schon ein bisschen mehr raus.
Darf ich meinen Schlauberger-Tweet dazu beisteuern?
Ja, klar.
Bei allen Devices, die du so betreibst, das sind keine konstanten Werte.
Nee, ich hab ja gesagt, zwischen, das hat schon geschwankt.
Nee, die richten sich aber auch nach der Umgebung draußen. Das heißt,
wenn du das schwankentesten willst, dann fährst du damit auch mal in die Brandenburger Puster.
Ja, wo dein scheiß LTE-Turm zwölf Kilometer weg steht und nicht auf deinem Nachbarhaus.
Ja.
Und dann misst du das nochmal. Also du solltest da ordentlich Reserve einplanen,
weil diese ganzen Wireless-Device, selbst Wireless, APs oder sowas,
die haben alle Powersteuerungen drin, die bratzen nur, die verbrauchen nur so
viel, wie sie brauchen und wenn du das natürlich in einer Klosterumgebung wie
bei dir zu Hause testest, dann hast du das alles schick.
Ja, mir zu Hause ist gar nichts schick.
Ja, aber ich kann das nicht sagen.
Aber ich will nur sagen, plant dort, plant dort.
Passt aber ins Bild, ich habe es mal ausgedacht, also ungefähr,
du kommst auf 2,88, also 3 Watt ungefähr, ich habe so 4 Watt ungefähr gemessen.
Ja, dann planst du bitte für 5 mindestens.
Dann planst du für 5 Watt und dann kannst du in etwa, wenn du dann halt die
Wattstunden von deinem Akku kennst, dann weißt du halt auch, wie lange der hält.
Ja, meine nächste Idee ist jetzt, dass ich das Ding nochmal aufmachen werde,
weil ich glaube wirklich, dass da drin halt nur so ein Voltage,
wie heißt es, so ein Down-Voltage-Regulierer.
Voltage-Regulierer, der aus den 7 sowieso 5 macht und wenn man sich gleich dahinter
anschließt mit seinem USB-Stein nämlich, dann muss man da gar nichts konvertieren
und dann kann man einen normalen USB-Akku nehmen, aber das muss ich erst noch
machen. Aber ich denke mal, das wird da der Fall sein.
Dann muss ich noch kurz an die Firma AVM, die hat uns ja das hier freiwillig
irgendwie zugeschoben, wir haben ja nicht mal nachgefragt, hätte ich noch zwei
Anmerkungen und zwar erstens wäre es schön, wenn ich so ein Ding auspacke,
Und dann aber meine SIM-Karte nicht reinstecken kann, weil ich so eine Mikro-
oder sonst wie-Karte habe.
Und die hätten diesen 1-Cent-Plaster-Adapter, wenn sie den dazulegen würden.
Das wäre wirklich cool, weil sonst fährst du in Urlaub oder kaufst das Ding
im Urlaub, bist im Wald und denkst dir, ja, ach nee, scheiße,
meine Karte ist ja zu klein.
Genau, das Ding hatte ich gerade in Polen.
Genau, genau. Und das kostet dir wirklich nichts, 1 Cent oder weißt schon.
Die haben diesen Anwendungsfall wirklich, die verkaufen das ja als kleine Box
eigentlich für zu Hause. Ja, sie funktioniert eben auch sehr gut mobil.
Ja, das ist das, was wir jetzt entdeckt haben, dass er dafür geil ist.
Alle entdecken das so.
Ja, natürlich, aber das war halt nicht deren anticipated usage.
Naja, aber das ist doch mal die interessantesten.
Aber man kann jetzt schon nochmal so ein Ding reinschmeißen, vor allem für den Preis.
Wenn man so im Feld ist, wir brauchen jetzt mal nicht so, wer hat mal eine Karte,
dann steckst du eine Karte rein und dann ist scheiße, wie war jetzt die PIN
von der? Das heißt, du musst die mal erst einloggen, machen, tun.
Das wäre schick, wenn sich das Gerät, sagen wir mal, für die letzten drei oder
fünf Karten einfach die PIN merkt, damit man einfach mal wechseln kann,
ohne sich immer wieder einloggen zu müssen, um da irgendwie was zu machen.
Nicht nur die PIN, sondern auch noch das zugeordnete Netz, weil du ja auch noch
Zugangsdaten auch noch einstellen kannst.
So kannst du Dinge auf automatisch stellen.
Nee, hab da nichts gefunden.
Glaube ich auch nicht.
Muss immer nicht die Karte wechseln, muss ich da in das Goehe.
Er hat gar keinen Kontext für die Karte. Er müsste im Prinzip die SIM-Karte
wiedererkennen und sagen, ah, die Karte. Er braucht es nicht.
Er kann nicht der Karte ansehen, zu welchem Netz sie gehört.
Warum kann man das dann noch einstellen?
Weil den APN? weil manche Netze mehrere APNs anbieten.
Aber in der Regel hast du das so, du kannst, heutzutage sind aus der Frühzeit
von GPS und da musste man das alles einstellen.
Heutzutage hast du einen Default-APN und der ist in der Regel auch das, was du haben willst.
Ja, okay. Aber auf jeden Fall, sie sollen sozusagen mehrere SIM-Karten...
Machen die Leute aber nicht. Guck, wenn ich mir jetzt von dir einen borge,
dann kann ich ja nicht sagen, mach mal vorher bitte deine PIN weg.
Ich verstehe das ja.
Man kann sie sich auch merken.
Da merkt sie sich ja eh und da muss sie sich einfach nur mehr als eine merken.
Ist egal. Sind alles Details.
Ich hab auch so lauter Kleinigkeiten.
Das sind so die feinen Dinger.
Die einen abhalten, schnell mal hin und her zu wechseln.
Genau. Und was mir halt auch noch fehlt, aber vielleicht hab ich auch nur was übersehen.
Ich hätte halt auch noch ganz gerne für das WLAN vielleicht halt auch noch einen
externen, also überhaupt externe Anschlüsse wären ganz geil.
Du hast ja unten noch einen Gigawatt Ethernet dran.
Das stimmt, da kann man halt dann einfach nochmal so einen anderen...
Weil übrigens auch der Vorteil ist gegenüber so einem Huawei-Mifi-Dongle-Ding.
Also ich muss noch mal sagen, wenn die Leute mich fragen, warum nimmst du das?
Das ist doch viel zu umständlich. Ein Mifi-Ding ist ja viel kleiner, lalalala.
Ich fange erst mal an mit, wo sie alle die Augen erst mal hochdrehen und sage,
die Fritzbox gibt mir IPv6.
Ja, macht es halt einfach mal so, weil es es kann. Ja, und dein Mifi-Dongle kann das nicht.
Und dann kommen diese Mifi-Dinger mit irgendwelchen obskuren Beschränkungen.
Nur fünf Clients oder nur zehn Clients und haben keinen Hardware-Ethernet dran
und kein La und kein Blob und keine vernünftige Ausleuchthilfe,
die nehmen nämlich zum Beispiel gerne einfach mal den Default APN.
Ja, du kannst dich dann auch auf dem Ding einloggen und so, aber die solche Geschichten.
Und für Leute, die sich jetzt fragen, warum sollte man denn mehr als 10 Leute
irgendwie an seinen WLAN ranlassen? Ich meine, wenn er auch mal auf so einem Festival ist.
G20? Genau.
Da gibt es WLAN. Da gibt es WLAN.
Nee, aber ich meine, jeder hat irgendwas zu bieten. Der eine kann irgendwie
Kaffee anbieten, der andere hat irgendwie andere Interessante Ressourcen,
aber wenn du auf so einen Acker kommst und sagst, ich hab hier ein Netz.
Du glaubst gar nicht, wie häufig ich das schon gemacht habe.
Neulich in einem Huckspace hier in Berlin und wir sitzen da zusammen und wir
wollen uns irgendwo einloggen, aber die ganze Zielinfrastruktur ist aus diesem
Jahrtausend, deswegen ist das größtenteils V6,
und wir sitzen da in diesem Huckspace und die so, ja, wir haben hier nur V4
und selbst das ist nur über drei Freifunkdinger getunnelt und kommt aus Krötenhausen
und la la la und ich so ein Moment.
Die 6820 auf den Tisch, klick an, LTE, 150 Megabit oder sonst so,
was hier so Spaß hat. Ich hab da mal was vorbereitet.
Das ist halt schon okay, dass man sich da mit dem Ding auch nicht so rumprügelt.
So, jetzt hab ich noch...
Jetzt habe ich natürlich darüber nachgedacht, was wäre denn jetzt sozusagen
eigentlich die Deluxe-Lösung, die ich eigentlich haben will,
wo ich es jetzt nicht unbedingt mit eilig habe, aber so dieses,
man kommt so mit so einem Wohnwagen an,
und ich weiß, manchen rollen sich jetzt bei dem Namen Wohnwagen so ein bisschen
die Fußnägel hoch, aber vielleicht nochmal, um das zu argumentieren,
Wohnmobile sind ja irgendwie immer Keiler.
Du kommst mit einem mobilen Device an.
Ich komm mit einem mobilen Device an. Was ich so geil finde,
also ein Wohnwagen ist, den schleppst du halt mit einer Karre irgendwo hin,
wirfst da ab und dann ist das so das Device für Wohnen, wo dann auch wirklich
jeder Quadratzentimeter,
dieses Ding irgendwie umspannt, ist dann auch bewohnbar.
Du stellst da nicht noch so einen Motor, Tanks, Benzin, was du einfach nicht
brauchst noch hin, sondern das ist halt einfach das und dann hast du so dein,
Movement-Device, das Auto ist halt dann frei.
Das ist einfach eine geile Kombination.
Davon mal ganz abgesehen, kann man da jetzt irgendwie natürlich auch noch so
Antennenmast einbauen und so ein Kram.
Und was ich jetzt eigentlich gerne hätte, ist halt erstens natürlich oben eine
LTE-Antenne, die man einfach so ausklappt und dann ist man raus aus dem eigenen
Faridation Käfig, der ja durchaus gegeben ist mit diesen ganzen beschichteten Trennen,
wie nennt man diese Dinger, diese Verdunklungsdinger an den Scheiben.
Lamellen.
Also ich will natürlich erstmal korrektes Netz einfangen, dann will ich aber
natürlich auch selber WLAN ausstrahlen, also ich will ja dann sozusagen das
gewonnene Netz möglichst per WLAN auch.
Das heißt innen noch eine Antenne?
Ja außen noch eine Antenne, also eine WLAN-Stabantenne quasi nochmal,
die dann einfach so einen Rundstrahler macht, damit ich dann halt im Zweifelsfall
auch mal so 100 Meter abdecken kann. Dann sitzt man nämlich dann auch noch hinten
irgendwie am See und hat immer noch korrektes Netz.
Und was ja zur Entspannung im Urlaub sehr wichtig ist, wie wir wissen.
Und dann die dritte Option wäre noch so, und das leistet leider auch diese Fritzbox
nicht, weil das ist ja ein Feature, was nur die anderen Fritzboxen haben.
Was ist, wenn du jetzt irgendwo hinkommst, wo deine einzige Netzquelle ein WLAN ist?
Sagen wir mal, es gibt jetzt die LTE-Option nicht, weil du keine SIM-Karte hast oder es kein Netz gibt.
Du willst sozusagen, dass der Wagen sich an dieses WLAN anknüpft und deine User
weiterhin deinen Wagen benutzen können.
Genau, dass ich quasi meinen WLAN habe und der das aber so rausbringt.
Das Xbox-Ding ins 6820 hat das Ethernet, oder?
Genau, da kannst du jetzt mal wieder einen Access-Point dran tackern.
Genau, also so eine Konstellation müssten wir irgendwie mal bauen.
Der gerade einen Link geschickt.
Bauen.
Für einen schönen Outdoor-AP, den ich dir anempfehlen kann, genau für diesen Zweck.
Also mir geschickt, hau den doch einfach mal in den...
Dazu müsste ich jetzt erstmal unsere Schlag-Channel hier wiederfinden.
Ja, okay, wo hast du mir denn das jetzt hingeschickt?
Für iMessage.
IMessage.
Ich hab zwar unsere Schlag-Channel, aber die, wo sind die jetzt hier? Ne, ist ja in Ordnung.
Ne, lass das, mach das schon.
Meintest du das hier? Die Bude?
Äh, ja. Oder? Ich habe das gerade...
Einbautsatz für 6810 und 6820.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich habe das eben auch schon im Slack reingeworfen.
Du kannst die Variante gerne... Ich weiß nicht, ob das dasselbe ist.
Nee, sieht nicht so aus. Die Antennen sind an einer anderen Stelle und größer.
Ja, dann gibt es mehr als eine Lösung. Ist auch gut.
Was du noch nicht in Slack gehauen hast, ist ein Link zu deinem Wohnwagen.
Wie sieht der eigentlich aus?
Gut.
Er sieht gut aus.
Ja, sieht sehr gut aus.
Okay. Na dann.
Sieht ja nämlich an so einen alten Knaller.
Muss ja noch ausreichend inkognito sein.
Bist du spätestens mit der Antenne auf dem Dach eh nicht mehr.
So eine Flachantenne auf dem Dach fällt überhaupt nicht auf.
Da siehst du wirklich aus wie der normale RTL Plus Konsument.
Naja, ich bin ja immer wieder entgeistert auf diesen Campingplätzen.
Also was da für Leute wohnen.
Das ist echt die andere Welt.
Ja, wir haben in dem Dorf, in dessen Nähe sich mein Landsitz befindet,
da gibt es auch einen Campingplatz.
Da gehe ich auch gelegentlich mal hin, weil da gibt es auch ein Café,
ein Restaurant, gute bürgerliche Küche und so, sehr lecker.
Ja, aber was da so für Leute so kreuchen.
Es gibt ja drei Klassen von Leuten auf solchen Campingplätzen.
Da gibt es halt so Leute wie man selbst, die so rumeiern und dann zufällig irgendwie
auf so einem Campingplatz hängen geblieben sind, aber irgendwie eigentlich auch
ein normales Leben führen.
Dann gibt es so die Leute, die so mobil sind, also nicht die Dauercamper,
sondern halt so, aber die dann eben auch schon so als erstes erstmal so die,
Satellitenschüssel ausfahren und so, damit irgendwie dann auch abends Fernsehen
geguckt werden kann und wenn du dann so in der Dämmerung rumläufst,
dann siehst du auch, dass sie alle Fernsehen gucken.
Einem ja irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, mir ist das komplett verloren gegangen.
Das ist aber genauso, wie an denen verloren geht, warum du im Urlaub Netz brauchst.
Ja klar, aber ich bin seit 35 Jahren unverstanden in dieser Thematik,
von daher ist das alles nichts Neues.
Und dann gibt es die Leute, die kommen im April und gehen im Oktober.
Ja, diese Garten-Sekstraktionen.
Und zwischendurch, ich glaube, da gibt es ja irgendwelche Regime,
alle wie viele Monate die Jogginghose gewechselt werden müssen.
Aber egal, also irgendwie.
Lassen wir jetzt mal. Gut, also das war jetzt eigentlich so mein Einwurf zu dem Thema.
Da kann man auf jeden Fall nochmal lustige Lösungen anstreben und wird mal im
Rahmen des Herbstes da mal versuchen.
Dazu einen kurzen Tipp von mir noch, weil das eine Falle ist,
in die man sehr gerne reintappt.
Erstens, es gibt ja noch von der 6820 noch den größeren Bruder, nämlich die 6840.
Gibt es die wirklich noch?
Die gibt es noch, ja.
Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass sie nicht mehr verkauft wird.
Es wird jetzt gerade auch wieder eine neue vorgestellt zur IFA.
Ich glaube 6890 oder weiß ich nicht, aber irgendwie sowas.
Aber jedenfalls diese größeren Dinger, die halt auch mehr als ein WLAN-Radio drin haben.
Fritzboxen können ja einen WLAN-Uplink. Das heißt, das, was du hier zum Beispiel
auch deine DSL-Box, die du hier hast, was ist das?
7390 oder 7490?
Aber die 6820 hat das nicht.
Aber die 6840 hattet. Aber ich sag's nur,
da gibt's eine ganz, ganz große Falle, die genau für deinen Einsatzzweck scheiße
ist, weil du klickst dir das zu Hause an, denkst, oh, ist ja geil,
funktioniert, teste ich sogar mal, oh, ich kann mich in mein eigenes WLAN von
meinem Nachbarn einbuchen und dann sieht das alles aus, als hinkriegt am DSL
und alle checken und alle toll.
Und dann nimmst du das Ding mit, deinen Campingplatz und dann sagst du das Ding,
such doch mal Netze und dann zeigst dir deine möglichen Netze an,
auch das von deinem Campingplatz, sagst du, oh geil, haben will. Select, apply.
Dann sagt die Fritzbox zu dir, nee, dieses Netzwerk ist nicht verschlüsselt,
mit dem verbinde ich mich nicht.
Das sagen die jetzt?
Ja, das sagen die. Ich hab mich schon mehrfach beschwert bei AVM,
was das für ein Affenzeck soll, weil das ist halt Internet, ist auch mein Netz,
das sollen sie bitte doch mir überlassen, aber das Ding verbindet sich,
wenn es Ablink über WLAN macht, verbindet es sich nicht mit unverschlüsselten Netzen.
Gibt es sowas noch?
Ja, natürlich.
Genau die Dinger, genau die Dinger, wo man sich einbuchen will,
in einem Hotel oder auf einem Campingplatz, die sind nämlich alle unverschlüsselt, diese Biester.
Ich habe jetzt noch keine Antwort von denen erhalten, einfach habe ich mich
schon mehrfach darüber beschwert, die sind bestimmt auch noch im Sommerurlaub.
Aber das ist eine echte Falle, weil du denkst, ich habe eine geile Lösung,
die habe ich getestet, alles ist cool, ich habe meinen geilen Router,
der kann alle, der macht sogar, wenn man will, so IPv6-Prefix-Delegation und all sowas.
Du denkst, ah, und dann so, oh fuck, kann ich mich nicht mit öffentlichen Netzen verbinden.
Na, wenn die im Urlaub waren, dann sind die ja vielleicht in das Problem gelaufen.
Besteht schon länger, also da waren schon diverse Urlauber dazwischen, aber es ist trotzdem so.
Freund von mir auch, wahrscheinlich teilweise gemeinsamer Bekannter von uns,
dessen Namen ich jetzt aber nicht erwähnen werde, hat mal sich irgendein Device genommen,
also so ein Router-Device genommen, so in so einer Fritzbox-artigen Größenordnung,
ohne dass es sich jetzt, glaube ich, wirklich Dollarplaster-Router und dann
einfach mal selber Code draufgeschmissen,
der sozusagen eigentlich so mehr so dieses Du-Water-Mienen-Prinzip unterstützt.
Das heißt, so ein Teil, das hängst du halt einfach so in die Luft und der fängt
dann selber an, einfach mal zu gucken, wo man denn so ein Netz herkriegen könnte.
Testet mal durch, ob die gehen, ob da scheiß Brutal drin ist.
Das ist ein offenes Netz, kommt da einfach so ein Netz raus.
wenn nicht, was macht man da? Ich hatte zum Beispiel auf dem Eincapingplatz,
hatte ich auch wieder so, ja, kostenloses WLAN.
So, und dann erst mal, ja, sie müssen sich aber jetzt irgendwie registrieren.
Dann erst mal so Facebook-Button, ja, wo ich mir dachte so, no way.
Und dann darunter, ja, oder mit E-Mail.
Ich mir denke so, ich will mir jetzt nicht eine Mail schicken,
die ich nicht abholen kann, weil ich noch kein Netz habe, weil ich ja damit
erst ins Netz reinkommen will und so.
Nee, dann kam dann so ein Feld, wo du dann E-Mail und Passwort eingeben kannst.
Oder dir zu erklären, wofür Passwort jetzt eigentlich gedacht ist.
Also du registrierst dich. Und ich glaube, dass schon mal eine ganze Menge Leute da wahrscheinlich,
ihre Mailadresse und ihr Mailpasswort eintragen, weil sie irgendwie glauben,
das müsste jetzt irgendwie sein.
Also sowas allein schon zu präsentieren ist natürlich hart.
Das Passwort ist dasselbe wie der PIN-Code zu ihrer EC-Karte.
Und die Leute so, ah, tipp ein.
Genau. Naja, da war ich dann auch schlau genug, das irgendwie nicht zu machen.
Und dann kam ich so zu diesem, also erstmal wird einem Registrierung angeboten.
Was sie meinen ist, du trägst einmal deine Mailadresse rein,
damit sie irgendwas von dir haben, um irgendwie Daten zu sammeln,
so auch immer sie das brauchen und du musst dir dann ein Passwort geben, damit du dann künftig,
in Kombination mit deiner Mailadresse da dann auch Netz machen darfst, warum auch immer.
Der übliche Hint ist, dass du dich zweimal nach dem Passwort fragen.
Ja, du weißt aber auch, was man einträgt, wenn man dann, also dann habe ich
so, ich habe schon ein Passwort geklickt und was nimmt man so,
wenn man irgendwo auf dem Campingplatz in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Cypherpunk, Cypherpunk.
Exactly, hat funktioniert. Cypherpunks at cypherpunks.org Passwort Cypherpunks.
Funktioniert seit 20 Jahren.
Geht immer noch. Leute, das ist Internet-Basiswissen. Habt ihr hier in der Freakshow
jetzt nochmal richtig schön eingetrichtert bekommen.
Cypher, also C-Y-P-H-E-R Punks at cypherpunks P-U-N-K-S .org,
also Cypherpunks als Cypherpunks.org, Passwort Cypherpunks.
Ihr glaubt nicht, in wie viele Systeme man einfach so reinkommt,
weil schon irgendjemand anderes das schon mal registriert hat.
Das ist sozusagen von den Cypherpunks seit Ewigkeiten sozusagen der Default
mit irgendwie, wenn ihr solche blöden Registrierungssysteme habt,
nehmt einfach das und damit macht ihr dann auch anderen Leuten die Tür auf.
Das Netz war dann trotzdem scheiße.
Bin dann doch wieder auf LTE umgestiegen. Das ist natürlich dann das andere Problem.
Ja, aber was du da auch haben willst, bei solchen Dingern ist,
du solltest immer einen guten VPN-Provider am Start haben, jetzt nicht für die
Aluhut-Fraktion, sondern weil teilweise, denn die anfangen arbiträr dort Ports
zu sperren oder sonst einen Scheiß zu machen.
Deswegen klickt man sich da was, ich schwöre immer noch darauf,
wenn wir jetzt eh schon gerade dabei sind, Markennamen rumzuschmeißen und Empfehlungen
auszusprechen, die keiner Rechtfertigung bedürfen.
ähm, ich benutze immer noch gerne unsere schwedischen Freunde von Müllwatt von
Maulwurf die haben halt eben, das ist so ein Ding da kannst du,
der anonym per Bitcoin oder wie auch immer, kostet 5 Euro im Monat, Müll M-U-L-L-V-A-D,
ja, Punkt net ähm,
nämlich deswegen weil die halt, weil die total super simpel sind,
du musst ja nicht großartig Accounts oder irgendwas anlegen,
sondern du kriegst so ein Account, das ist nur eine Nummer ohne Passwort eine
ziemlich lange Nummer ohne Passwort,
Dann überweist du da unten Geld hin oder schickst irgendwelche Bitcoins hin
oder sonst was, kostet 5 Euro im Monat, dafür hast du nämlich 3 oder 5 Zugänge oder sowas.
Die du auf Access Points, also sozusagen VPN-Konzentratoren,
die überall auf der Welt zu stehen haben.
Ich benutze das andauernd, wenn ich im Ausland will und mal was sehen will,
wo auf ARD oder irgendein Scheiß, dann connecte ich mich back home auf deren
Aufpunkt in Frankfurt oder sowas.
oder andersrum, wenn mir mal wieder irgendwelche Leute kommen mit,
das kann ich in Deutschland nicht anzeigen, dann mache ich das Ding halt eben auf.
Manchmal mache ich es auch automatisiert im Router, dass der Router selber sich das auswählt.
Und so ein bestimmtes Müllwarttunnel geht nach Holland oder in die Schweiz oder
sonst sowas und die sind total super simpel, kannst du auch ein iPhone-Client
und bla bla bla, aber das Schöne ist, das basiert auf OpenVPN,
das heißt, das kannst du ja genauso gut auf ein Raspberry Pi draufschmeißen
und auf so einen klären Edge Router oder Edge Router X, was so das Spielzeug
ist, wo A und X so spielen.
Kann man das mit Mac-Bordmitteln machen oder muss ich dann Viscosity dafür benutzen?
Ne, Viscosity ist nur eine Oberfläche. Hast du Viscosity?
Ich hab das zur Not, aber ich benutze das selten.
Ja, Viscosity ist nur eine Oberfläche. Viscosity ruft auch bloß OpenVPN auf.
Du kannst das jetzt auch gerne in ein Shell-Script einhacken oder wie auch immer
deinen OpenVPN von Hand aufrufen.
Also die Bordmittel sind jetzt im Mac OS schon dabei?
Nein, dein OpenVPN selber ist nicht dabei, aber den kannst du dir brunen oder
wie auch immer. Du brauchst einen OpenVPN. Den liefert Apple nicht mit aus.
Ja, den kannst du dir aber brunen oder selber kompilieren.
Ja, aber Viscosity ist schon mehr als nur oberflächte.
Ja, Viscosity ist, nee, der bringt auch einen OpenVPN-Client mit.
Ja, mein ich ja.
Ja, aber das ist derselbe, den du auch selber kompilieren kannst.
Ja, ist schon klar, aber es ist halt normalerweise im macOS noch kein,
du kannst jetzt nicht im Standard-User-Interface OpenVPN klingen.
Nee, das gibt es noch nicht. Aber das ist trotzdem, also deine Seite ist eigentlich alles Open Source.
Open Source oder Commercial, wie du willst. Es gibt halt Open VPN Clients, bis der Arzt kommt.
Und machst du es auch auf V6?
Ja.
Hätte mich jetzt ja auch schwer gewundert.
Also hallo, wie jetzt, es ist super simpel,
es gibt Röpft sich von diesen Leuten, ich mag die, weil sie halt technisch sehr
sauber sind und auch gut dokumentiert sind und sind auch nicht irgendwelche
Chinesen, die der irgendwie, was jetzt für 4,95 anbieten,
weil es halt 5 Cent billiger ist oder sonst nichts gegen Chinesen,
jetzt will der gar keine Diskussion, will die gar nicht anstoßen.
Aber es sind Schweden, die das basteln und die auch sehr gut darüber nachgedacht haben.
Also auch für die Aluhut-Fraktion ist das was, aber ich nutze das hauptsächlich
eben, um mal so aus Fasch und Netzen rauszukommen, ohne dass ich jetzt meine
eigene Infrastruktur benutze.
Ich habe zwar meine eigene Infrastruktur, aber nicht im Entferntesten in so
vielen Ländern wie die Müllwartleute zum Beispiel.
Jetzt haben wir noch mal kurz, um das vielleicht auch mal abzuschließen,
die 6820 ist derzeit die einzige Fritzbox, die AVM unter der Kategorie Macht
LTE listet auf der Homepage.
Das heißt, dieser 6840 scheint so ein bisschen on its way out zu sein.
Und es gibt was Neues.
Das hieß dann wie?
Ach, haben sie jetzt gerade dieser Tage angekündigt für die Liefer 6890, glaube ich, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wo sie über Heise gerade geredet haben.
Dass es halt kein Hybrid-Dings ist. Hab's schon.
Wichtiger Punkt dabei, gerade da wir jetzt hier schon mehrfach,
dass das rosa T-Wort, das magenta T-Wort gefallen ist und solche Sachen wie Dayflat und so was.
Ich hatte das ja schon mal in einer Sendung vor ein paar Wochen angesagt,
dass die Telekom jetzt angefangen hat und auch rapide am Ausbauen ist,
LTE auch im 900-Megahertz-Band zu betreiben.
Das ist wichtig für Städter, weil seitdem sie das tun, geht dein LTE auch in deinem scheiß Keller.
Und es geht zum Beispiel auch bei mir auf ein Dorf.
Wir hatten ja da so eine kleine Basisstation am Feuerwehrschuppen dran.
Die ganze HF-Infrastruktur, die Kabel und Antenne, alle 900 Megahertz und bla und pipopo.
und da hat jetzt, ist glücklicherweise vor ein paar Wochen mal ein Blitz eingeschlagen
und die Telekom hat gesagt, fuck it, die alte GSM, BTS, scheiß drauf.
Wir tun nochmal was Modernes hin und seitdem gibt's, obwohl sie jetzt,
die hatten natürlich keinen Bock die ganzen Antennen. Wie hast du das gemacht mit dem Blitz?
Ein paar Bittenfonds an die richtige Adresse überwiesen.
Und seitdem, zack, ich komme aus dem Urlaub wieder, hab ich LTE in meinem Scheißdorf da.
Aber wie gesagt, 900 Megahertz. Das heißt, du möchtest, das kann 6820 und da
müsst ihr aber eben auch aufpassen, wenn ihr so MIFI ist oder sonst irgendwelchen
anderen Quatsch jetzt für Europa kauft,
das werden andere Operator der Telekom auch nachtun und findet sich auch schon in anderen Ländern.
Nein, LTE auf 900 MHz zu machen.
Ja, wenn in deren Mastestationen die Blitze einschlagen.
Ja, aber deswegen der neue heiße
Scheiß ist halt wichtig, weil 900 MHz ist halt... Was ist das Ding hier.
Ja?
Ich hatte es gar nicht gesehen, ich habe es nur im Twitter gesehen,
die sieht ja scheiße aus.
Eben, also das ist halt schon wieder mehr so ein Gerät für zu Hause,
ein bisschen fancy, flach mit zwei Antennen hinten rausgucken.
Die 6820, die ist halt schon so richtig geil so für unterwegs.
Also die steht ein bisschen scheiße eigentlich, aber die ist schön klein.
Ja, aber mit dem Strom unten und so weiter ist nicht wirklich praktisch.
Das Ding will ich haben. Diese 68. Die sieht genau aus. Vor allem,
die hat ja auch noch andere Sachen. Die hat ja auch noch diesen ganzen Deckt-Kram.
Ich will natürlich am Bach sitzen mit dem Deck-Telefon und telefonieren.
Und wo buchst du das ein? Bei deinem Call? Nee, wie hättest du das?
Einfach über Zip dann halt. Es geht ja nur darum, dass ich das machen kann.
Außerdem, wer will schon telefonieren?
Also, der nächste Schritt ist ja.
Übrigens, hallo, nur so nebenbei, du bist beim falschen Provider,
dieses Problem interessiert mich nicht mehr, weil ich bin ja Telekom-Kunde mit WLAN-Call.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich WLAN habe, am Bach-Call, wo ich WLAN am Bach
habe, habe ich Telefon, mit meinem Device, was ich kenne.
Da muss ich jetzt nicht noch ein Deck, ich weiß, doch, ich verstehe dich.
Du willst es tun, weil du es kannst.
Ja.
Ja, das ist okay.
Genau, deswegen würde ich es machen.
Naja.
Ist okay, mach das.
Man muss ja auch noch im Hundealter auch noch Eindruck stellen.
Jetzt müsste man natürlich bei dem Ding mal nachschauen, welche Bänder die jetzt
da wieder unterstützen und bla bla bla.
Aber die machen halt auch 5 Gigahertz und so.
Ja, eine letzte Sache vielleicht noch, aber da habe ich noch nicht viel drüber
nachgedacht. Ich habe so eine obskure Lichtsteuerung in diesem Wohnwagen.
Das heißt, es gibt so verschiedene Lampen, die ich jetzt irgendwie erstmal strategisch
alle gegen LED ausgetauscht habe, weil man Strom verbraucht.
und diese Lichtsteuerung macht halt so magische Dinge, du hast ja so Fernbedienungspaneele
und kannst so Gruppen schalten und das ist alles irgendwie vollkommen weird.
Wäre natürlich geil, wenn man diesen Wohnwagen dann sozusagen irgendwie auch
noch auf HomeKit umsteigen lassen kann, jetzt soll ja demnächst HomeKit auch
mit so Arduino zusammenkommen, mit Softwareautorisierung und so,
dann ist das ja vielleicht durchaus eine Option.
Und so, dann kannst du halt dann auch irgendwie so richtig schön Remote-Disco machen.
Also Arduino wahrscheinlich nicht, ich glaube da brauchst du schon Raspberry Pi?
Ja, oder was auch immer, halt irgend so ein Gerät, so ein Embedded-Gerät,
was mir dann so wie diese Lichtsteuerung mal ein bisschen intelligenter macht.
Aber, Clemens.
Yes.
Da du ja bald weg möchtest, und wir unter Umständen eine kurze Sendung haben.
Nix ist.
Nix ist, könnt ihr ohne mich weiterspielen.
Ja, okay, aber dann musst du ja jetzt nochmal aus deinem Urlaub nochmal berichten,
weil das will ich natürlich jetzt hören. Und du musst ja...
Welchen der Urlaub?
Den, den du mit deinem neuen Auto gemacht hast.
Mehrere.
Ja.
Ein Freund von mir sagte und war mal zu mir, so wie du arbeitest,
möchte ich Urlaub machen.
Aber, ähm, ja, bei mir ist es ja, es gibt ja mal so Grauzonen.
Ich hab ja, mach ja auch so ein bisschen Event-Networking Irgendwie der Aal und so.
Reißt dafür in der Weltgeschichte rum.
Er setzt sich dafür eine Woche ins Stadion und lasst mich dafür denn irgendwo hinfliegen.
Und bezahlen.
Nee.
Aber hinfliegen. Und Hotel und Pool und alles.
Ja klar.
Das ist eigentlich all inclusive. Du musst nur arbeiten dort,
dann vor Ort ein bisschen.
Da musst du jetzt sehr vorsichtig sein, damit weder die deutsche Steuer noch
die Arbeitsaufsicht in die Zielländern da jetzt auf... Nee, nee, nee.
Diese Vorstellung, was kein Geld ist, ist keine Arbeit, ist sehr, sehr...
Verstehe.
Aber ich bin halt Volontier bei verschiedenen Veranstaltungen,
die jetzt auch durchaus wie ITF halt eben sehr...
Du brauchst sie nicht zu rechtfertigen.
Ich muss sie dir hinterher schicken.
Keine Ahnung, wie viele Steuerleute hier dieser Sendung zuhören. Also aber egal.
Oh, Steuern, haben wir schon mal darüber geredet?
Ja.
Der spannende Teil war eigentlich, denke ich mal, also jetzt weniger so,
wir fahren mal nach Prag oder so, sondern der spannende Teil war eher mal so,
wir fahren mal fast 3000 Kilometer in Schweden rum.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht wieder den jährlichen Salm anstellen,
warum Schweden irgendwie ein geile, tolles Land ist und so.
Wir können jetzt noch...
Ja, aber es fällt halt einfach eher auf, dass die ein bisschen unverkrampfteren
Zugang haben zu solchen neuen Themen.
Also wenn bei uns irgendwie ein kleines Dorf sich überlegt, Elektromobilität,
was ist denn das eigentlich und hin und her, dann kommen erstmal sich Bedenkenträger
und dann werden erstmal irgendwelche Ladekarten ausgegeben an irgendwelche Leute oder sonst sowas,
und in Schweden habe ich es halt erlebt, da komme ich in eins meiner Lieblingsdörfer,
wo ich immer wieder mal gerne durchfahre und in der Tat haben sie auf dem Marktplatz
einfach an zwei Laternen jetzt so Ladedinger angebracht.
Und dann guckst du hin und dann ist da so ein Zettel dran mit so einem QR-Code
und klickst auf den QR-Code mit deinem Handy und dann landest du halt auf so
einem Google-Formular, wo drauf steht, ja toll, dass du das jetzt hier benutzen,
ich würde einfach nur gerne wissen,
so ein paar Daten, so statistische Daten so und hin und her und ansonsten viel
Spaß beim Laden. Ich so, okay, cool.
Ich habe diese knapp 2900 Kilometer zugebracht von Berlin bis da hoch und wieder
runter über Sassnitz-Trelleborg-Fähre,
und habe bezahlt fürs Laden 0 Euro. 0 Kronen, 0 Euro. Das geht.
Überall, also wir reden jetzt von Tesla, wegen der Supercharger-Infrastruktur.
Ich habe nicht nur Supercharger.
Aber wie viel Prozent von dem Strom, die du so konsumiert hast,
kam daraus? Also aus Tesla-offiziellen Tesla-branded Stationen?
In Deutschland aus allen. In Schweden,
60, 70 Prozent vielleicht. Lag aber daran, weil es halt einfach bequem ist.
Die haben massenhaft von diesen Dingen, das war jetzt weniger eine Kostenfrage,
sondern war halt eher so dieses Oh, guck mal, da ist ein Supercharger gegenüber
vom Einkaufszentrum. Lass uns doch mal kurz und dann zack, ist der Drops wieder gelutscht.
Okay, aber du hast ungefähr 600 Kilometer kostenlos Strom aus Nicht-Tesla-Outlets geholt.
600 Kilometer, wie kommst du das?
20 Prozent von 3.000.
20 Prozent von deinen 3.000.
Ja, vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen mehr. Eher ein bisschen mehr.
Also zweimal vollgetankt wahrscheinlich irgendwo, was nicht Tesla Supercharger war.
Du machst ihn ja voll geladen, du machst ihn ja nie leer. Du musst einfach mal
von dieser Denke her wegkommen, den mach ich auch nie voll.
Außer wenn ich jetzt weiß, ich fahr jetzt in ne Gegend, da weiß ich jetzt noch
nicht, wie lange ich mich da rumtreibe, gibt's da irgendwelche Lader,
dann mach ich den halt voll.
Aber normalerweise mach ich den nur 80% voll. Ne, 90% voll.
90 Prozent. Der hat so ein einstellbares Ladelimit, das liegt standardmäßig
bei 90 Prozent und dann mehr macht er da aber nicht.
Und was halt interessant, diese ganze Geschichte ist aus mehrerlei Hinsicht
interessant, was schon, also Ladeinfrastruktur mäßig, die haben genau dasselbe
wie wir, sie haben auch ungefähr so viel wie wir davon rumzustehen.
Was ich interessant fand, ist, dass die weniger Heckmeck machen mit diesen Ladesystemen.
Das ist ja meine große Kritik an der deutschen Situation, dass es zwar diese
Ladesäulen gibt und auch diese ganzen technischen Themen, mit welchen Stecker
stecke ich denn jetzt wo rein, sind mehr oder weniger eigentlich alle durch.
Aber dieser unglaubliche Zoo von hier brauchst du aber diese Ladekarte.
Und nein, aber die romt ja denn mit dem anderen, wo du vielleicht auch schon
mal, und der hat ja dann, und da kannst du mit deiner App auf dem Telefon,
ach nein, hier brauchst du doch einen Airfit-Schlüssel und so ist es.
Das ist schlimm, oder?
Das ist wirklich echt krass. Da muss auch wirklich noch was passieren,
wenn Leute über Ladeinfrastruktur nachdenken.
Und das hatte ich dort fast nie. Was ich sehr interessant fand,
ist, sie haben sehr gut verstanden, dass man das zur allgemeinen Infrastruktur
macht, jetzt nicht exponiert, so wie hier.
Du hast jetzt hier eine Ladesäule, die in irgendeiner Straße rumsteht,
sondern sie machen die dahin, wo man sie eigentlich auch ganz gut gebrauchen kann.
Nun muss man da sagen, die Wohnsituation in Südschweden, wo wir da rumgefahren
sind, ist noch eine andere. Da gibt es zwar auch so Städte wie Malmö oder Jöteboi,
aber in der Regel wohnen die Leute halt mit irgendeiner Art von kleinen Häuschen in Bremer.
Das heißt, die spielen das Spiel, was angesagt ist, nämlich du lädst zu Hause
und wenn du unterwegs bist, brauchst du was.
Das führt aber dann eben auch dazu, dass du, wenn du irgendwo hinfährst,
was so ein öffentlicher Ort ist, wir haben irgendein Schlösschen besucht an
der Küste oder sonst so, das hat natürlich einen großen Parkplatz,
weil sie lauter Touris da kommen und da gibt es in diesem Parkplatz eine Ecke,
da gibt es Ladesäulen. Oder halt die Städte.
Welche Größenordnung?
Wie viele?
Das hängt von dem Parkplatz meistens zwei. Aber ein anderes Beispiel war in
Warberg, das ist so ein kleines Küstenstädtchen an der Westküste.
Die haben sich gedacht, wir holen mal so ein bisschen den Verkehr aus unserem
ganzen kleinen Dorf da raus, haben sich ein schönes Parkhaus irgendwo hingebaut,
städtisches, kostet auch nichts, tagsüber.
Und dann fährst du da rein und da stehen dann sechs so eine Dinger im Parkhaus.
Und wie kommst du von dem Parkhaus dann zu dem Parkhaus?
Nee, das ist in dem Ort. Am Anfang der Altstadt ist so ein von außen eher unauffälliges
Ding, ist aber innen drin so ein größeres Parkhaus, damit die Leute ihnen halt
nicht diese ganze Altstadt zuparken oder sowas.
Dann fährst du da rein. pack da mal und dann fährst du da rein und immer wo
du so ein Ding findest, findest du auf jeden Fall irgendwas zum Laden.
Manchmal findest du was von irgendwie, in Südschweden treibt sich so eine dänische
Firma rum, Clever heißen die, die machen so Zeugs, was ganz gut ist,
wenn du bei denen Dauerverträge hast.
Prepaid-Situation ist für einen Fuß.
Und du hast doch gesagt, du hast nichts bezahlt.
Nee, nee, nee, die machen, das siehst du häufiger dort, du siehst dort Ladesäulen
für Umme, für Umme und dann nochmal die von Clever für Geld.
Ja, ich habe es auch nicht verstanden.
Wenn die anderen voll sind, dann musst du bezahlen.
Vielleicht ist das Premium-Strom.
Oder RWE habe ich auch gesehen. Ich habe zum Beispiel...
Das kann sein, vielleicht eine Schnellladesäule.
Läht er schneller eventuell?
Mehr Leistung?
Waren dieselben Typ 2 Steckerdinger mit 16 Ampere, 32 Ampere oder so.
Also die 22 kW-Lade-Dinger.
Also ich habe keine Ausdruck. 22, okay.
Dann habe ich gesehen, so in der Nähe zum Beispiel auch, kannst dich darauf
verlassen, wenn du da so ein größeres.
Einkaufszentrumplatz hast. Haben wir sowas in Deutschland? Ja,
haben wir auch sowas vor den Städtchen oder sonst sowas liegt.
Da hast du dann, weißt du, so an einer Autobahn oder an einem...
Genau, ist so ein Ikea und dann ist da, weiß ich, ein großer Ica,
also so ein Supermarkt und alle möglichen anderen Zeugs und noch so ein paar
kleine Gewerbe, die üblichen Autoschrauber und so, dann hast du da so einen Platz.
wo mittendrin so eine Autobahn irgendwas durchgeht. An diesen Dingern hast du
regelmäßig immer irgendwas zu laden.
teilweise von drei, vier verschiedenen Anbietern. Ein paar davon umsonst,
ein paar davon kosten Geld und dann hast du noch, wenn der Tesla cool ist,
dann gerade an der Westküste haben die da die fetten Superchar dazu stehen.
Also da habe ich wirklich Situationen erlebt. Muss ich aber legen geografisch.
Tesla Country in Europa ist ja Norwegen. Und deren Landweg nach irgendwo anders
hin, führt sie über die Westküste von Schweden.
Entweder runter nach Malmö über die Brücke rüber oder dann eben weiter nach
Trelleborch und dann mit einer Fähre irgendwo hin.
Das heißt, an der gesamten Westküste gibt es wirklich eine Menge Supercharger
und da war immer was los und die waren teilweise so richtig voll.
Ich stand dann mal am einen, hab den geladen, an so einem Zwölfer,
wo sie auch zwölf Dinger gleichzeitig laden können, die waren dann noch alle
zwölf da und dann standen noch drei andere da, die noch drauf gewartet haben.
Was ja bei so einem Supercharger nicht so das Problem ist, weil die laden ja
eh bloß alle 10, 15, 20 Minuten, das heißt, irgendeiner von den zwölf fährt
eh in den nächsten paar Minuten weg.
Aber das war krass und dann bin ich da weggefahren aus meinem und hab noch was
aufgegessen, was ich mir inzwischen zu essen geholt habe und drin kamen nochmal
drei und dann aber auch richtig dann fette Model X und sowas,
also was hier kaum siehst, hier siehst du ja kaum Model X.
Also da war richtig, für Tesla-Fans kannst du dich da auf die Lauer legen,
kannst alles fotografieren von dem ersten Tesla-Modell bis hin zu aktuellem Scheiß.
Tesla-Spotting.
Das Tesla, kannst du da Schwedens Westküste kannst du das Tesla-Spotting machen.
Auch Model S in braun, das ist doch angeblich so selten.
Alles, alles, auch ne, was es ja auch gibt, ist ja diese Urfarbe,
diese Urrot oder diese braun-rote, das war die ersten Dinger,
diese Founder Edition, keine Ahnung, bin ja da nicht so, aber diese, da war echt was los.
Und auch da, wie gesagt, auf der anderen Seite der Straße dann so ein bisschen
verweist dann auch so ein Chardemont Charger, wo dann mal so gelegentlich mal
so ein i3 vorbeikommt und mal so ein bisschen dran schlabbert.
I3 hat Chardemont?
Nee, weiß ich jetzt, aber ich sag nur, diese Multi-Charger.
I3 hat CCS.
Ist so eine Kiste, meistens, das gibt es auch in Deutschland,
steht bei uns bei Tank und Rast, da hast du halt so einen Typ-2-Stecker für
Wechselspannungsladerei bis 22 kW, ein Charmo mit diesen 45 bis 50 kW und dann ein CCS noch.
Das sind drei von den Dinger. Von denen kannst du aber nur zwei gleichzeitig benutzen.
Ist auch nicht mehr Platz. Du hast diese Säule, steht in der Regel dann immer
am Ende von zwei Parkplätzen in der Mitte.
Da kannst du halt einen links und einen rechts und die Kabel reichen auch gerade
so hin, aber da ist eben nur Platz für zwei Parkplätze und dann kannst du zwei
von diesen drei Und den Tesla eigentlich links.
Und rechts tanken?
Nein, den kannst du nur links.
Nur Fahrerseite.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding, wo man sich auch denkt, das fällt in die Kategorie,
das ist halt ein kalifornisches Auto.
Viele Platz haben die da und deswegen.
Nee, das ist halt eben Driver-Convenience. Ernsthaft, ich hab mal ein bisschen
rumgegoogelt und die Idee ist halt, dass wenn das Ding innerlädt,
dann ist das der Driver und damit der nicht noch um das halbe Auto noch rumgehen
muss, machen sie das Ding halt links.
Was natürlich für Leute in Deutschland, die das Ding am rechten Fahrbahnrand
parken, eher so ein bisschen so ja,
Ist jetzt nicht dramatisch, das Ding ragt jetzt bei mir so 15, 20 Zentimeter raus.
Habe ich in der Torstraße schon öfter gesehen, wenn dann auf der Fahrerseite
der Stöpsel da drin, also auf der Fahrbahnseite der Stöpsel drin steckt,
wenn der da am Rand parkt.
Ist nicht so günstig, ist aber auch kein Drama, aber ist trotzdem so,
weiß ich nicht, die anderen Kröten, was hier so rumfährt, diese ganzen...
Zoe macht das vorne in der Mitte, haben es ganz viele, das finde ich aber auch doof.
Weil es sieht immer so ein bisschen aus.
Als ob der irgendwas aus der Nase draufkommt.
Mit diesen Citroen-Dingern oder E-Golf.
Der i3 hat es rechts.
Ich gucke gerade.
Ja, bei den anderen ist es meistens da, wo auch der normale Tank ist.
Ja, aber dann muss der Fahrer wieder ums halbe Auto rumgehen.
Ja, aber dann muss er eh, weil er zur Ladesäule muss.
Die kann ja auch links sein.
Ja, nicht in Deutschland.
Nicht an der Straße.
Stimmt. Musst du andersrum einpacken.
Aber ist nicht erlaubt.
Es ist wirklich...
Aber diese Tesla Supercharging Station, Das ist auch im Prinzip so die ideale
Dating-Plattform eigentlich für so Tesla-Fahrer, oder?
Das Problem ist, dass die...
Das sind Leute im ähnlichen Preissegment und nicht Interessen.
Ja, nee, Vorsicht. Elite-Partner.
Ja, ja, alle elf Minuten verliebt sich ein Tesla-Fahrer an einer Zuhörer.
Das ist durchaus...
Ich kann ja nicht mitlachen.
Ich habe mir zu viele von diesen Tesla-Fahrern angeguckt.
Also habt ihr eine Werbeverarsche Para-Frasch oder wie nennt man das?
Nee, aber ernsthaft, ich muss leider sagen, das ist,
sagen wir mal so, das Level der Goldkettchenträger ist doch relativ hoch.
Ernsthaft? Oh Gott, ich dachte, das sind alles nur so Akademiker-Typen.
Nee, die gibt's auch. Was es auch gibt, sind irgendwie, was irgendwie sehr,
in bestimmten Gegenden sehr sehr beliebt ist, ist Business-Frauen stehen drauf.
Sehr häufig gehabt, eben...
Model X natürlich auch, ne?
Nee, nee, nee. S. Model S.
Aber so die anderen, die du da so siehst, ist halt eben, was ich sehe, so Typ Bauunternehmer.
So Autofan und so und ne, so.
Dann aber auch mit Ludicrous Mode und so.
Na klar. Oder halt, die gibt's auch, die Akademiker sind eigentlich eher Technologiefans.
Das sind die, die mit dem absoluten Sparbrötchen-Modell, also mit dem S70,
was ja nur der kleinste ist oder damals irgendwie noch ein S60 oder sowas ohne
D ohne D, ohne L, ohne nix oder sowas.
Mikro-Tesla.
Ja, so der kleinste Tesla, den klicken. Links oben, nicht rechts unten, sondern links oben.
Ja, es ist, man kann da auch mit Leuten ins Gespräch kommen.
Ich fand es jetzt in Schweden immer ganz interessant, wenn man da ein bisschen
wegkommt aus dieser Westküste,
dann wird es ein bisschen internationaler, dann hast du auch mehr Schweden,
Finnen und auch andere Mitteleuropäer da und das war dann immer ganz lustig,
da während der Ladeweile mal, mit
denen mal zu schnacken, wo die jetzt herkommen, was die so machen und so.
Das kann ganz nett sein. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob man das jetzt zur Dauerbeschäftigung
machen muss, aber man kann. Das ist okay.
Sind die überdacht?
Nee. Es gibt Bilder von Superchargern, die sie jetzt in den USA bauen wollen,
so richtig welche mit 40 Stalls und sowas.
Die sehen so ein bisschen aus wie so eine alte Tankstelle und die haben oben
Solar noch drauf auf den Dingern.
Was was ganz Nettes ist, Tesla baut die Dinger nicht einfach irgendwo hin,
sondern die machen natürlich Vereinbarungen mit den Leuten, denen dieser Ground dort gehört.
Das heißt, da gibt es in der Regel immer irgendwie irgendwas zu essen oder sowas.
Oder das ist auf einem Parkplatz von einem Hotel, wo du dann die Lounge benutzen
kannst oder dann natürlich auch ein Klo und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist sozusagen einfach alles mit drin.
Und ja, manchmal stehen die Dinger auch einer meiner Lieblingscharger,
das kann man durchaus mal sagen, den ich hier in Deutschland benutze,
gerade so nach Süden raus, ist der in Bersteland.
Das ist so 100 Kilometer südlich von Berlin.
Den ich auch gerne mal mitnehme, weil der steht halt mitten in so einem Feld.
Das war in 200 Meter Entfernung so ein Hotel, wie gesagt, da kann man ja noch
hingehen und essen und so.
Aber der steht mitten in so einem Feld und am Rande dieses Feldes stehen überall
diese Windturbinen, die der überall ist in Brandenburg.
Und das ist halt einfach nett, wenn du das schöne Wetter hast,
sitzt du da drin, du siehst diese Dinger drehen und du weißt, ja.
Die pumpen da gerade in dein Auto rein.
Den Wind, den ich da gerade höre, der fließt gerade in mein Auto rein.
Das finde ich schon mal irgendwie, ja.
Das wird dann aber wahrscheinlich auch wie bei IP über sonst wo geroutet und
kommt dann über hunderte Kilometer hin.
Nee, das macht keinen Sinn. Bist du sicher?
Die sind doch nicht direkt dran. Die müssen da erstmal hier den Strom wandeln und machen.
Das geht schon bis zum nächsten Umspannwerk, aber das geht nicht durch die halbe
Republik, weil Stromtransport ist extremst teuer. IP-Paket-Transport ist leider viel zu billig.
Also Umspannwerk ist ja auch nicht um die Ecke.
Diese Windturbinen müssen ihr Zeugs ja auch loswerden. Die legen doch nicht
erstmal extra 100 Kabel nach, was ist das nächste Ding da, nach Zeuten oder
sonst irgendwas, um mir dann mal wieder 100 Kabel wieder runterzulegen.
Ich befürchte schon.
Nein, sicherlich nicht.
Das wird alle, diese Stromflüsse werden alle denn nur virtuell abgerechnet.
Das heißt, du hast sozusagen eine so eine Wolke, da speist jemand ein,
jemand anders speist aus und das wird irgendwie verrechnet.
Und das wird ein Niveau gehalten in dieser Wolke. aber du routest deinen Strom
nicht halb durch Deutschland oder halb durch Europa.
Das macht doch keinen Sinn vor Ort schon irgendwie da so ein Wandlerhäuschen
hinzubauen, wenn sie natürlich.
Natürlich, die müssen doch eh ihr Zeugs einspeisen.
So ein Supercharger, der macht ja 110 Kilowatt.
So, weil er eh schon so viel nimmt.
Einer.
Einer, genau.
Ein Stor. Und du hast immer, der kleinste den ich gesehen habe,
war einer mit vier Dingern.
Die meisten haben sechs, acht, zwölf solche Storps, also solche Ladedinger dran.
Wobei dann aber so ist, die teilen sich die auch. Also wenn du so ein Zwölfer
hast, das ist nicht zwölfmal 110 Kilowatt oder 115 oder sowas.
Wenn da zwei Teslas dran sind.
Dann lädt da einer ein bisschen lang. Aber ein bisschen, nee,
ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte.
Der Tesla lädt ja wahrscheinlich, wenn er bei 80 Prozent ist,
auch nicht mehr volle Pulle, sondern wird da ja auch langsamer.
Das ist nur am Anfang so.
Wenn er da losballert.
Also wie gesagt, so viel zur Ladeinfrastruktur und hin und her.
Was ich sehr spannend fand, deswegen wollte ich da nochmal drauf kommen,
wenn man so ein bisschen reist, guckt man auch anders drauf,
wie man so fährt. und ich fahre sehr viel, sehr gerne mit dem Autopiloten,
also das, was Tesla als Autopilot verkauft.
Wir nennen es jetzt mal Lenk- oder Fahrassistent.
Und,
das Ding fährt, jetzt knurbel ich gerade so ein bisschen rum,
weil Tesla mir jetzt gerade dieses Wochenende ein Update spendiert hat, der so richtig geil ist.
Aber bis dahin fuhr das Ding korrekt, aber nicht gut.
Das war noch dieses ruppelige Korrigieren.
Ja, das ruppelige Korrigieren, das meine ich gar nicht, aber ja,
also das ruppelige Korrigieren, das haben sie jetzt deutlich weg.
Das ist jetzt wirklich diese Smooth-Essert-Geschichte, das ist richtig geil.
Aber, ähm, dieses, ähm, was ich meine, ist, du fährst halt lange Landstraßen,
fährst halt hundert von Kilometern in irgendwelche Landstraßen und denkst.
Da kriegst du auch drüber nach.
Lässt das Ding denn fahren und dann macht das Auto was, wo du denkst so,
nee, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gemacht so einfach so, nicht so,
ah was tut der, wir werden alle sterben sondern eher so dieses,
nee, warum hast du jetzt hinter dem angehalten, anstatt um ihn rumzufahren oder,
warum hast du jetzt an dem Schild wo 70 dran steht auf 70 reduziert und nicht
vorher du hast es doch vorher gesehen,
Ähm, oder, äh, also solche Geschichten halt.
Und, ähm, dann hab ich halt jedes Mal darüber nachgedacht, wenn mir sowas aufgefallen
ist, auch mit meinen Mitfahrern dort, die ja natürlich wussten,
dass ich Autopilot fuhr, die sich mir auch manchmal angeguckt haben,
denn so, das war jetzt komisch, warum, ne?
Also jetzt, wie gesagt, der fährt nicht so, dass du jetzt Angst haben musst,
dass er dich umbringt, aber er fährt halt nicht so wie ein Mensch.
Und wenn du dann überlegst, was das für Situationen sind und du sagst,
ich hätte jetzt anders entschieden und dann drüber nachdenkst,
aber wieso eigentlich, aufgrund welcher Sensorinformationen oder wie auch immer,
das hätte der doch gar nicht erkennen können, diese Thema.
Oder manche Sachen kann er erkennen, aber macht er nicht. Wie zum Beispiel ein
Auto, was vor dir abbiegt, was blinkt, was links blinkt, da fährst du rechts vorbei als Mensch.
Darfst du das denn dann auch? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Aber du denkst halt darüber nach, so eine Dinger fahren halt anders.
Ich will damit nur sagen, man kann da mal rein zoomen, jetzt mit seinem Geist
oder das beobachten, gerade wenn man so ein Ding hat, dann mal gucken,
könnt ihr euch noch Dutzende von solchen Beispielen sagen,
wo man einfach denkt, naja, wenn die jetzt alle die viel gelobte Autonomie und
jetzt nur Tesla-Algorithmus oder Daimler oder wer immer, scheißegal,
wenn diese viel gelobte Autos fahren jetzt autonom durch die Gegend,
dann fahren die alle anders.
Die fahren nicht so wie wir heute. Aus verschiedensten Gründen.
Und das muss man halt eben berücksichtigen. Man muss sich auch,
denke ich, an der Straßeninfrastruktur mal ein bisschen ein paar Sachen machen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel etliche Stellen, wo das Auto komische Sachen macht und du denkst, äh?
Ja, wer hatte gar keine Chance, das anders zu bewerten, weil die Straßenmarkierung
war einfach weg oder falsch oder sonst irgendwas.
Also zum Beispiel so ein klassisches Ding, hatte ich vorhin schon mal vor der Sendung erzählt, ist.
Aus einer Fahrspur werden zwei. Du hast eine Landstraße, jetzt nicht so Stadtsituation,
sondern du hast eine Landstraße, du hast eine Fahrspur und das ist in Schweden
sehr, sehr häufig so, nicht immer, aber sehr, sehr häufig so,
dass die dann zum Beispiel auch,
physisch abgegrenzt ist. Das heißt, du hast zwar eine Fahrbahn und die hat einen
Mittelstreifen, dieser Mittelstreifen ist aber ein kleiner Zaun.
Dieser Mittelstreifen ist so einen halben Meter hoher, aus fetten Stahlseilen gebauter Zaun.
Und das heißt, du kannst nicht in den Gegenfall rüberfahren.
Physisch nicht. Also außer du mäßt diesen Zaun um, aber der sieht sehr stabil aus.
Und was sie jetzt natürlich machen ist,
damit es keinen dauernden Ärger gibt, machen die dauernd wechselnde Spuren,
Das heißt, eigentlich besteht diese Fahrbahn aus drei Spuren und entweder du
hast die zweispurige Seite und die andere Seite haben eine oder andersrum und
das wechselt so alle vier, fünf Kilometer.
Ja, ich sehe in Deutschland auch immer da, wo es hochgeht, sind zwei Spuren,
damit man die LKWs, die es nicht so schnell schafft.
Überholen kann. Die machen es auch, wenn es flach ist, regelmäßig gerne diese
dreispurigen Dinger mit dem Zaun wohlgemehr, also physisches Hindernis in der Mitte.
Und dann, wenn du jetzt die, ich bin auf einer Spurseite hast,
die jetzt irgendwann mal endet, dann weitet die sich aus. Und wenn du dir das
mal anguckst, wie das aussieht, verschiedene Länder machen das anders und selbst
innerhalb der Länder wird das anders gebaut, wie das wirklich gemacht wird.
Die Schweden machen das so, deine Spur wird einfach erstmal breiter.
Das heißt, das Auto sieht, seine Straße läuft auseinander.
Es gibt noch keinen Mittelstreifen wieder, den gibt es erst 50 Meter weiter hinten.
Das heißt, deine Straße wird erstmal breiter und jetzt das Auto so,
bleibe ich jetzt am linken Rand oder am rechten Rand, wo es mein,
ich habe keinen Mittelstreifen, oh, einen Mittelstreifen.
Ja, das heißt, der eiert so ein bisschen hin und her und mit der alten Software
war das richtig so, du bist einmal so richtig so durchgeruckelt und dann hat
das wieder seine Spur gefunden.
Mit der neuen Software macht er einmal so, na gut, fahre ich da weiter.
Aber trotzdem, ein Mensch würde das nicht machen und wenn du jetzt überlegst,
wo dran das liegt, ja klar, mit Fahrspuren, man könnte das auch anders markieren und so.
die Deutschen bauen das nochmal ganz anders die Deutschen bauen das ohne Zaun
in der Mitte das gibt es zum Beispiel auf dieser neuen Strecke von Rügen runter
nach Stralsund rein, haben sie das gemacht so mehrere Kilometer,
mehrere Dutzend Kilometer sogar, auch so zwei, drei,
und die machen es nur mit Fahrbahnmarkierung und wenn da deine zum Beispiel
deine zwei Spuren sich verenden, verengern,
verengen ja, dann wird die linke Spur einfach radikal abgeschnitten.
In Schweden machen sie das, wenn sie die Doppeldinger zusammenführen,
dann wird das ein bisschen enger, dein Mittelstreifen hört wieder auf und die
Straße wird einfach wieder schmaler.
In Deutschland machen sie das so, dass deine rechte Spur weiter gerade aus ist,
du hast sozusagen diese Strichchen und die andere läuft innerhalb von wenigen
Metern. Zwei, drei Metern läuft die halt einfach aus.
Das ist aber auch ordentlich vorher angesagt.
Mit Schildern, mit Schildern, und dann gibt es da auch eine Sperrfläche,
die machen da auch noch schön grün.
Und so geschräge Streifen, also in Schweden oder so.
Nee, nee, nee, hier jetzt da auf Rügen. die machen sie einfach einen fetten
grünen Klotz hin, aber deine linke Fahrspur hört einfach abrupt auf,
Ja, und jetzt kann man halt sagen, ja, muss man ja ein bisschen programmieren.
Aber wenn du darüber mal nachdenkst, kommst du einfach drauf,
wie viel die noch lernen müssen.
Und wie viel auch gerade solche Buden wie Tesla oder egal, das geht auch andersrum.
Die Tesla-Leute müssten jetzt langsamer anfangen, Entwickler nach Europa zu entsenden.
Ja, vielleicht nach Deutschland, nach Schweden, nach Holland oder Frankreich.
I don't care. Die müssen jetzt mal hier.
Aber die sammeln doch auch die Videodaten ein von den ganzen Fahrten.
Das weiß ich eben nicht. Was ich gerne gehabt hätte, kann ja mal an Tesla mal
twittern oder so, ob die da mal Bock drauf haben oder so.
Ich hätte gerne einen Knopf auf meinem Lenkrad, wo ich sagen kann,
die letzten 30 Sekunden hochladen mit den ganzen Sensordaten,
die sie ja eh in der Schleife haben, die sie sich noch merken und all so Zeugs.
Also einfach so, guck mal, was das Auto jetzt hier gemacht hat.
Du siehst das schon an dem Kamerabild.
Aber ich glaube, das machen die schon automatisch. Die wissen ja,
wenn das Auto da rumeiert, das können die ja auch erkennen.
I don't know. Aber es passiert halt einfach, sehr, oder passiert halt immer wieder.
Und es ist fast so, als wenn ihr vorstellt, wie habt ihr in Kalifornien noch
nie eine Straße gesehen, die sich ausweitet auf zwei Spuren oder andersrum?
Die können einfach noch nicht alle Situationen dieser Welt gesehen haben.
Deswegen alle Tesla-Fahrer, die jetzt rumfahren, danke, dass du das machst.
Ja, ist ja so. Du lernst gerade deren System an.
Clemens starb für unsere Sünden.
Clemens lädt für unsere Sünden.
Ja, mit dem Sterben würde ich gerne darauf verzichten, auf den Anteil.
Aber ich will nur sagen jetzt mal allgemein, weil alle Leute, auch Politik,
ja, wird jetzt gerade wieder das große, Elektroautos sind ja der große Hype
und natürlich auch, selbst in die Netzneutralitätsdiskussion kommt mit rein,
autonom fahrende Autos und bla und
blub und alle haben da so Wolken-Kuckucksheim-Vorstellungen davon und so.
Wir sind da noch weit von entfernt.
Und nochmal, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass wir jetzt so richtig in den Kinderschuhen
stehen, wo wir jetzt dauernd irgendwelche Leute umfahren oder irgendwelche in
die Bäume fahren oder sonst sowas, aber es ist nochmal ein großer Unterschied von
wir lassen meine Insassen überleben zu wir fahren jetzt mal richtig cool,
wie ein Mensch das auch tun würde, der nicht besoffen ist.
Keine Frage. Ich glaube auch, dass das Ziel, das ist weit entfernt,
aber die Geschwindigkeit nimmt auch enorm zu.
Also das Ziel rauscht auch ganz gut heran.
Also ich merke das, weil ich kriege so alle fünf bis sechs Wochen ein Update,
die verbessern wirklich Sachen.
Das ist der Punkt, der mir wichtig ist, weil mich auch Leute fragen,
wie Tesla und teuer und bist du denn nicht sauer, dass das nicht alles und sie
haben doch versprochen.
Ich sage, nee, das Einzige, was ich mir als Versprechen habe geben lassen,
ist, dass sie sagen, hier hast du ein coole Stück Technik und wir machen dir das besser.
Wir wissen, wir basteln, ich wusste genau, dass sozusagen eine nagelneue Software
ist, weil das Hardware Model 2, die Tesla selber entwickeln musste,
neu entwickeln musste, nachdem sie sich von Mobileye getrennt haben.
Und nur sauer drüber wäre es, wenn sie aufhören würden, Updates zu liefern. Was sie jetzt sagen.
Ach. Silky Smooth, war da Chris Lettner noch zuständig? Der ist doch dahin.
Und wieder weg, aber auch, ne?
Weiß keiner genau, worauf der jetzt einen Schluss hatte.
Zum Thema Silky Smooth.
Man muss sich so ein bisschen trennen von diesem, aha, es werden hier große
neue Features propagiert per Elon Musk-Tweet oder sonst irgendwas mit Versionen
und hin und her, weil ich glaube, da steckt ganz viel Regulierung drin.
Silky Smooth haben sie schon vor Monaten advertised und ich habe es jetzt letztes
Wochenende erst bekommen, aber zwischendrin schon mal drei Software-Updates gehabt.
Das liegt glaube ich daran, ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel auch erst seit letztem
Wochenende diesen Fernlicht-Automatischen Fernlicht-Ablend-Assistenten oder sonst irgendwas.
der war an derselben Version, die eine Freundin von mir in den USA hat,
die genau das selbe Modell hat wie ich, schon seit Monaten war das Ding an.
Und ich immer so, Fabi, was ist jetzt, guck mal, bei mir sieht das Display so
aus und sie schickt mir ein Screenshot von ihrem Display, da ist einfach drei Knöpfe mehr drauf.
Ich so, was hast du für eine Version? Exakt, auf die Version,
exakt das selbe Ding, selbe Auto und so weiter und so fort und das liegt halt
an der Region. Und meine Vermutung ist, und das finde ich halt...
Oder die machen einen AB-Test.
Und ich dachte, das wäre mit den DVDs ausgestorben.
Nee, nee, nee. Nee, ich denke, da muss halt Tesla besser kommunizieren halt einfach.
Dass sie sagen, ja, wir haben das Feature drin, aber wie das immer so ist mit Zulassung.
Ich habe auch gehört, dass zum Beispiel, wenn normale Autohersteller,
da ist ja auch sehr viel Software drin in ihrer Motorelektronik und so hin und her.
Dass wenn die da bestimmte Dinge anfassen, dann müssen die erstmal wieder durch
irgendwelche Kraftfahrt-Bundesamt-Zulassungsprozeduren und sowas durchreiten.
Und deswegen kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass eben jede Popelfeature,
was da Tesla anmacht, sie erstmal den Hollandern zeigen müssen.
Die machen es halt auf die EU-Schiene, die plagen sich gar nicht erst rum mit
den Deutschen, sondern die zeigen es den Hollandern.
Wenn die das toll finden, dann hast du eine holländische Zulassung,
die in ganz Europa gilt und dann ist es gut. Aber...
Einfach testen, nehmen wir einen Tesla, ab nach Amerika, gucken, ob er da das Update hat.
Da kannst du nicht laden.
Ich glaube, der geht nicht in der Region, wo du gerade bist,
sondern wo es angemeldet wurde.
Da kannst du auch nicht laden, die haben andere Stecker.
Die haben ganz andere Stecker. Vielen Dank.
Aber es gibt aber Leute, es gibt Leute, es gibt Leute,
die mussten natürlich mal ein Around the World machen und hatten natürlich auch
das Problem und haben sich denn von mehreren Nerds auf dem ganzen Globus immer
die Adapter zusammen löten lassen, je nachdem, wo sie jetzt gerade damit waren.
Aber es gibt Leute, die sind schon einmal rum auf der Kugel.
So ein Adapter würde ich nicht löten, aber das nur am Rande.
Ja, egal. Die haben sich einen basteln lassen und ja, das kann man machen,
aber das das ist wie gesagt interessant und das bleibt auch spannend,
weil es dort eben Updates gibt für das Zeugs und die auch neue Features bringen
und eben auch was machen.
Und wie gesagt, die aktuelle Software fährt richtig smooth, das ist jetzt einfach
schön, ich mach die eigentlich kaum noch aus, außer hier in der Stadt.
Sobald ich hier in die Stadt rausfahre, oben auf die Aufwand,
mach das Ding an, dann fährt der fertig.
Und das ist schon auch convenient.
So.
Okay. Das war doch mal ein schöner Einblick. Jetzt hast du mich so ein bisschen
auf den linken Fuß erwischt.
Nee, sorry.
In dieser Sekunde wollte ich nämlich gerade schauen, was wir eigentlich sonst noch so haben.
Das ist eigentlich noch eine Menge. Wir könnten jetzt hier noch fünf Sendungen
voll kriegen, glaube ich.
Aber sag mal, jetzt darfst du sozusagen auch schon gehen. Wann musst du los?
Eigentlich 23.10 Uhr, aber ich hab noch keine Message gekriegt.
Wahrscheinlich ja wieder Verspätung.
Ja, vielleicht bevor ich das vergesse zu erwähnen, es steht hier aus diesem
Hause, trifft es nicht so ganz, aber sozusagen Subscribe?
Die Subscribe steht an, genau.
Aus der Familie.
Wer das noch nicht weiß, wir machen,
Ja, eigentlich halbjährlich immer so ein Konferenz-Workshop-Treffen rund um
Podcasting und so das Senden und Empfangen im Netz.
Es ist uns in diesem Jahr nicht gelungen, ein Event in Berlin hinzubekommen,
was ein bisschen ärgerlich ist. das hatte zwei Gründe im Wesentlichen.
Nachwuchsgründe, ne?
Es hatte Nachwuchsgründe, jetzt nicht bei mir, aber bei den anderen und es hatte
aber auch einfach schlicht den Grund, dass wir keine Location hatten.
Also wir hatten auch nicht die Zeit und nicht die Energie, uns eine zu suchen.
Die eine Location war jetzt expired?
Die eine, die ist einfach geschrumpft. Also wir waren ja vorher bei Wikimedia
und die haben dann halt einfach diese ganzen zusätzlichen Räume sukzessive in
Büros wieder zurückverwandelt und dieser eine Raum reicht halt einfach für unser Konzept nicht.
Und deswegen machen wir es jetzt halt noch ein weiteres Mal in München,
im Bayerischen Rundfunk, wo die Situation halt hervorragend ist,
weil wir da halt den großen Konferenzsaal und dann nochmal so eine ganze Etage
mit vielen Räumen und alles top ausgestattet nutzen können.
Die waren ja auch selbst ganz begeistert letztes Jahr, ne? Hatte ich so den Eindruck?
Ja, also die haben uns einfach sofort wieder eingeladen. Es war ein bisschen unglücklich,
weil der Termin letztes Mal, der einzig mögliche Termin so war,
dass deren netzpolitischer angehauchter Event, nämlich dieser Zündfunk-Kongress,
ausgerechnet an dem es am Wochenende stattfand.
deswegen ist uns da sehr viel potenzielle Zielgruppe aus diesem ÖR Umfeld so
ein bisschen abhandengekommen, das soll sich dieses Jahr hoffentlich etwas anders ergeben,
ansonsten ja ist wieder geladen klickt doch einfach mal auf subscribe.de dann
kommt ihr auf die ganze Infoseite zum Event oder tickets.subscribe.de wenn ihr
also auch kommen möchtet,
worüber ich mich natürlich sehr freuen würde wer sollte sich da angesprochen
fühlen erstmal natürlich so alle,
Podcaster oder die, die es werden wollen, die Projekte schon ins Auge gefasst
haben oder die sich irgendwie in irgendeiner anderen Form mit dem Senden und
Empfang auseinandersetzen.
Das trifft natürlich so einerseits vielleicht Radiojournalisten oder auch Entwickler natürlich,
also insbesondere Leute, die jetzt vielleicht auch Bock haben,
so bei Podlove oder Ultraschall oder einem der anderen Projekte sich da noch
mit einzubringen, weil da sind dann halt auch alle. Podlove zuckt noch, ja.
Podlove zuckt wieder, nachdem wir eine etwas längere Durststrecke hatten,
wo nicht so ganz klar war, wie viel Werbe wir da jetzt wieder hinter alles bekommen,
aber wir haben ja jetzt den tollen neuen Webplayer,
jetzt wirklich auf dem Weg und ich hoffe dann zu Subscribe gibt es dann halt auch das erste Release,
und dann schneller, höher, weiter.
Man hat es doch mal versucht, bei dem Start von diesem Paddler irgendwie auch
mal Leute zu finden, die dir vielleicht mal einen Entwickler finanzieren oder
Co-Finanzieren oder sonst irgendwas.
Nun gibt es ja inzwischen solche Buden, solche Prototype Fund oder sowas.
Ja, der Prototype Fund ist natürlich sehr,
politisch, gesellschaftlich ausgerichtet. Da könnte man es natürlich probieren,
wurde auch teilweise schon probiert.
Podcast ist ja ein wichtiges Mittel zum demokratischen Ausdruck.
Ja, so kann man natürlich argumentieren, aber da haben natürlich dann so Projekte,
die dann so ganz konkrete Kampagnen, Geschichten, wahlbezogene Sachen und so
weiter haben natürlich einen ganz anderen Reiz.
Ja, jetzt vor der Wahl, aber vielleicht so, wenn du jetzt dann mittendrin in
der Legislaturperiode bist und auch gerade mal keine Atomkraftwerke jetzt nachgewässern
werden müssen, ob sie auch wirklich ordentlich strahlen, dann gibt es ja bestimmt
auch nochmal da was zu krabbeln.
Also ich bin da auf jeden Fall auch für alles empfänglich, was uns halt nicht
in irgendeine kapitalistische Turboscheiße reinwälzt.
Das wollen wir halt nicht.
Aber ja, muss man mal sehen. Aber jetzt geht es ja auch erstmal ums Treffen und mal wieder ums Neue.
Just hier, nachdem wir jetzt mal ein Jahr Pause gehabt haben,
ist auch mal ganz interessant, weil dieser Halbjahreszyklus war eigentlich sehr
geil, weil man da irgendwie auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise miteinander in
Verbindung bleibt und so ein Jahrestonus, den man ja irgendwie so gewohnt ist von Events,
tickt irgendwie anders.
Also das ist immer so, ich finde so ein Jahr, das ist so,
gibt nicht viele Veranstaltungen, die so ein Zwei-Jahres- oder ein Vier-Jahres-Rhythmus überhaupt aushalten,
aber so Jahr ist schon so ein bisschen das Minimum, wenn man auch irgendwas
am Laufen halten will, aber ich finde so ein halbes Jahr ist für so eine lebendige
Community eigentlich optimal.
Nun ja, so viel dazu, wer da noch mehr drüber wissen möchte,
soll sich einfach mal ein bisschen erklicken oder kann uns dann auch auf Twitter
fragen, das Sendezentrum gibt.
Also ich habe mir ein Ticket schon geklickt, aber ich weiß etwas schockiert,
wie lang der Fragebogen ist.
Ich habe das erstmal so in der S-Bahn und dann hörte das nicht mehr auf und
dann habe ich es irgendwann abgebrochen, weil so aus dem Twitter-Client raus
war das dann doch ein bisschen viel.
Ja.
Und habe es dann irgendwann nochmal gemacht.
Der Hintergrund ist, dass wir halt vor Ort,
Also der Hauptwert von so einem Event ist ja die Vernetzung und wir wollen dann halt mal,
also haben wir ja letztes Mal auch schon gemacht, so übersichtliche Tafeln,
dass man sozusagen auf einen Blick an der Wand sieht,
wer ist noch da und wer will mit wem irgendwie in Verbindung kommen und da wir
irgendwie jetzt nicht die geile App haben, wo wir irgendwie so das Konferenz
Social Network reinpipen können.
Da gibt es ja mittlerweile schon so Apps, aber die wollen dann irgendwie mal
so ein Tausender pro Event, das werden wir natürlich nicht investieren, um sowas zu machen.
Sowas fände ich ja auch mal für den Kongress übrigens ganz geil,
aber das ist ein schwieriges Thema.
Also sozusagen so ein, man will sich vernetzen, man hat die Daten ja eh schon,
warum nicht auch gleich da die Kommunikation ermöglichen.
Aber das ist sozusagen der Hintergrund hinter diesen Fragen.
Ja, das war mir schon klar, nur es kam etwas unerwartet.
Ja, es kam vielleicht etwas unerwartet.
Steht einfach Seite drauf. Längere Fragebogen.
Naja, aber wenn du es dann erstmal hast, dann ist es halt...
Aber du kommst gleich trotzdem. Ich hatte keine Ahnung, was Längere Fragebogen
bei Herrn Pritnauf bedeutet.
Ich bin gar nicht mal schuld.
Aber das ist schon nur so eine Konferenz für das Umfeld Podcast.
Naja, wir haben es halt ein bisschen offen gehalten. Alles, was wir mit Sinn
und Empfangen zu tun hat.
Also wir werden auch unter anderem versuchen, die Erfahrung,
über die wir heute hier schon so ausführlich gesprochen haben,
von dem Medienzentrum da noch mit einzubringen.
Okay, seid ihr schon dran.
Also bin ich genau, also es ist jetzt noch nichts in trockenen Tüchern,
aber das ist ganz klar mein Ziel, weil das finde ich halt eigentlich sehr spannend,
auch inhaltlich und auch alle Projekte, die sagen wir mal überhaupt so auch mit diesem,
Status Quo des öffentlich-rechtlichen und sonstigen News Flows,
spielen und das Podcasting hat ja jetzt schon vieles in Frage gestellt oder
hat halt gezeigt, dass man eben auch andere Kanäle und andere Wege wählen kann,
um zu informieren oder auch zu organisieren oder auch zu,
bewegen. Und ja, das soll alles da stattfinden, ist in München.
kann aber trotzdem revolutionäre Anteile haben.
Hoffe ich ganz schön weit weg ja.
Hotels sind dann wieder ein bisschen teurer und so, wir müssen das Ding auf
jeden Fall auch wieder nach Berlin holen Hamburg ist.
Auch eine schöne Stadt.
Ja, aber wir müssen es einfach mal nach Berlin holen, weil du kennst das ja
weil halt wegen ist so genau,
Ich meine, wir organisieren das so im Kern zu dritt, wohnen alle hier,
wir wollen das Ding halt auch irgendwie bei uns haben und in Berlin gehen halt
einfach noch mal ein paar Sachen, die sonst nicht so einfach sind.
Apropos Hotels, ne?
Ah, Hotelgate. Oder was?
Ja, ich bin da sehr verwirrt, weil ich eigentlich in Justen Hotel...
Erstmal erklären, worum es geht.
Okay, gute Frage. Ich habe es nur so am Rande mitbekommen.
Diese Hotelkette, wie heißen die? NH Hotels, die haben das mit der Lebenläufigkeit
und der Datenbank und so weiter wohl nicht im Griff gehabt und haben deswegen
irgendwie massiv überbucht.
bekommen als irgendwie 180.
180 Doppelbuchungen.
Von wie viel?
Weiß man genau, was der eigentliche Grund war? Also was die Schwäche war?
Das betrifft wohl alles ohne Gewehr.
Also kurz erklärt. Leute haben bei einem Hotel gebucht für den Kongress. Darum geht es jetzt.
Das war nicht bei irgendeinem Hotel.
Genau das ist der Punkt. Wir haben nicht bei einem Hotel gebucht,
sondern über Booking.com.
Über Booking.com bei einem bestimmten Hotel gebucht, was halt in der Nähe...
Und am Ende sind 180 Zimmer mehr vergeben worden, als halt tatsächlich da sind.
Timeline ist auch wichtig. Die Leute haben schon vor Monaten gebucht.
Vor Monaten rausgefunden, dass du kackst und sagen jetzt kurz vor der Angst
nochmal an, das passt übrigens alles gar nicht, wir buchen euch mal irgendwo hin.
Das ist glaube ich eher der Knaller. dass da mal was schief geht,
ist ja alles okay, aber dass sie das jetzt ewig rausgezögert haben, ist so ein bisschen.
Genau, das war so ein bisschen ungeil, das war wohl so ein bisschen,
sie hatten sich eigentlich bemüht, sie wollten sozusagen erstmal gleich Antworten
haben und hier und wir haben auch was für euch und dann hat sich das in die
Länge gezogen und das war dann natürlich ein bisschen unklug.
Tja, weiß nicht, hast du noch irgendwas mitbekommen, Al, was sich da noch so entfaltet hat?
Ich bin nur so, ich bin nur so, so ein bisschen verunsichert. Bist du betroffen?
Bis jetzt nicht. Ich habe es noch nicht gehört. Also ich habe in diesem Hotel gebucht.
Über Booking.com?
Entweder über Booking oder über Trivago. Das weiß ich eben auch nicht mehr so genau.
Ich glaube, sie hätten sich inzwischen bei allen gemeldet.
Aber ich habe von denen nichts gehört. Ich weiß aber auch nicht,
ob ich die Mail nicht vielleicht einfach gelöscht habe, weil die mir sowieso
so viel Werbung geschickt haben. Ja, das sollte ich mal machen.
Das wäre vielleicht ganz hilfreich.
Du sollst sie bitte nicht beschimpfen.
Das ist auch nicht meine Art.
Ich sage, es wird darum gebeten.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, es ist nicht meine Art, Leute zu beschimpfen.
Andreas Burg hat sich ja auch nochmal ein bisschen eingeklemmt,
nachdem er die Dinger da hochkochten und hat dann da nochmal mit denen auch
gesprochen und hin und her und hat ihnen das immer erklärt, wie so ein Kongress
ist, weil die dachten immer so, naja, ihr habt da halt ein anderes Hotel, so what?
und ja, aber das ist jetzt nicht die Leipziger Buchmesse, wo die Leute brav
um 17 Uhr nach Hause gehen, sondern,
deswegen ein Ding, wo man erst mit einer Bahn hinfahren muss,
die nachts nicht fährt, ist halt eben blödet Umbuchungsstil und dann hat er
denen auch erklärt, dass Kongressbesucher auch mal so ihre Familie dabei haben
und all solche Geschichten und hin und her.
Hat sich da so ein bisschen verdient gemacht, aber im Gegens hat eben auch man
da mit Leuten mal gesprochen, die mal so ein bisschen die Hosen runtergelassen
haben, was da das Problem ist.
Und eine der Messages, die da zurückkamen, waren so, ja, wir schämen uns alle
ganz fürchterlich, aber hört doch bitte auf, unsere Leute am Telefon zu beschimpfen.
Die können dafür auch nichts. Deswegen sagte ich eben.
Wenn du da anrufst, dann warst du das mitbekommen. Ja.
Also, wie gesagt, ich weiß es immer noch nicht, ob ich betroffen bin.
Ja, aber ich fand es schon interessant, dass so Hotelbuchungen des Kongresses,
mittlerweile dem MDR, eine Pressemitteilung wert sind.
Also spannend finde ich jetzt auch so Side-Fact, das Motto, die wissen nicht
wegen Bahn nachts und so, also es ging jetzt ja auch schon über Twitter,
wer es nicht gesehen hat, gibt
jemanden vom Club, der gerade mit den Verkehrsbetrieben in Leipzig redet.
Den kennen wir ja auch.
Ja, so ne, der hat einfach mal
schön den WLAN-Grafen, der Concurrent User genommen vom letzten Kongress.
Er ist da hingegangen und hat gesagt, so, das sind die Zeiten,
da sind die wach und da gehen sie nach Hause.
Da hatten sie denn verstanden, über was man da eigentlich redet.
Ja, sowohl in Zahlen als auch in Ausprägung.
Vor allem spannend, für die ist ja auch nicht bloß, wie viele Leute sind da,
sondern wenn so eine Kurve abfällt, wie steil fällt die ab. Das heißt,
wie viele Leute hauen da gleichzeitig ab aus dem Land.
Das ist aber echt geil, direkt aus der WLAN.
Hätte ich genau so gemacht. Ihr zählt ja sonst, ihr habt ja sonst keine Leute
am Eingang, die zählen, wie viele
Leute drin sind. Obwohl, wie wird das eigentlich gemacht beim Kongress?
Was denn?
Es wird ja immer wieder kolportiert, dass so bei öffentlichen Veranstaltungsräumen
für so Massenveranstaltungen muss eigentlich der Veranstalter Pi mal Daumen
eine coole Idee haben, wie viele Leute sich gerade auf seinem Gelände rumtreiben,
damit er beim Feuerchen hinterher nachzählen kann, ob er alle rausgebürstet hat.
Klappt auch ähnlich. Aber gut, erzähl weiter.
Ich weiß ja nur, deswegen werden zum Beispiel bei anderen Veranstaltungen,
wenn jetzt so Zählkameras oder sowas, gibt es schon seit ein paar Jahren,
haben selbst diese Veranstaltungslocation, die wir da kennen,
die haben auch Zählkameras da, damit sie genau wissen, nicht genau wissen,
aber schon ein paar Dutzend Leute wissen, wie viele Leute sich auf dem Gelände
rumtreiben. Macht der Kongress nicht, oder was?
Oder die Leute, die da Tickets kontrollieren, zählen die auch?
Nö.
Das heißt, du weißt nicht, wie viel...
Der Rechner weiß schon, wie viel Ticket er verkauft hat oder wie viel abgeholt wurde.
Du weißt aber eh nicht, wie viele gerade aus der Tür rausgegangen sind. Genau, du weißt nicht.
Wie viele davon wieder rausgehen oder wieder reingekommen sind am nächsten Tag und so.
Wir trecken die Leute nicht. Wir trecken halt die Leute nicht.
Du musst ja die Leute nicht trecken.
Du könntest aber zählen.
Ja, können wir, aber soweit ich das weiß, geschieht das derzeit nicht.
Ja, ich meine, das ist immer so diese Verlockung von Statistiken,
die ist natürlich gegeben.
Nee, das hat mit Statistik nichts anderes. Wie gesagt, das wird gerne kolportiert
mit. Wir müssen aus evakuierungstechnischen Gründen wissen, wie viele Leute,
oder zum Beispiel diese andere Location, die ich eben erwähnte, die haben ein Limit.
Das ist ein hohes Limit, aber die haben ein Limit, wie viele Leute sie überhaupt
aufs Gelände lassen dürfen.
Ja, gleichzeitig anwesend sein dürfen.
Das haben wir auch.
Da halten wir uns auch dran.
Wie machst du das, wenn du die Leute nicht zählst?
Indem du nur so viele Tickets verkaufst.
Achso, okay, ja, alles klar.
Und weil, wenn wir das nicht machen würden und wir würden bescheißen,
habe ich schon gehört, dann wäre die Auflage, dass wir an allen Türen,
also an allen, dass wir da Leute mit Zähler hinstellen müssen,
um mitzuzählen. Das macht man zwar dann auch selber, aber ja,
das wollen wir auf jeden Fall vermeiden. Deswegen halten wir uns an die Auflagen.
Deswegen gibt es einfach nur so viele Tickets, dass nur so und so viele Leute
auf dem Gelände sein können.
Das muss ja sowieso alles stimmen, auch wegen Finanzamt und so weiter.
Die wollen die Bändchen haben und den ganzen Spaß und so. Da muss man sich eh sehr genau halten.
Also so einfach ist das nicht mehr wie früher mit Stempel und durch,
sondern das hat schon alles handelt gut.
Aber dem Finanzamt ist bloß egal, wie viel Geld, wie viele Leute sich davon
auf dem Gelände rumtreiben, aus dem Finanzamt, sowas vom Rüchte.
Ja, das schon, aber du kannst nicht einfach Leute ohne Bändchen reinlassen,
weil das wäre wieder Betrug, weil das Finanzamt, die haben die Bändchen im Griff.
Du musst da zeigen, also du bestellst Bändchen, ich hoffe, ich erzähle jetzt
nicht aus dem Nähkästchen, aber das ist ja bei allen Veranstaltungen so,
du bestellst halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20.000 Bändchen, auf die Veranstaltung
dürfen von mir aus nur 15.000 drauf,
und dann, oder du sagst, dem Finanzamt, dem ist dem Engel egal,
aber du sagst dem Finanzamt, wir hatten 15.000 Leute, dann wollen die danach
5.000 nicht benutze Bändchen haben.
Und zwar auch 8 Jahre später.
10.
Ja, aber die wollen halt in den 10 Jahren halt jederzeit ankommen können.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt von jedem Kongress eine große Kiste mit Restbändchen.
Würde ich einfach hingehen, bei der Firma noch welche nachordern, wenn du Finanzamt hast.
Nee, die arbeiten ja alle zusammen, das ist ja so ein Ding.
Wenn du da nachorderst.
Dann weißt du das Finanzamt, das ist ja auch mehr oder weniger.
Wenn du so sprichst, die Rechnung dafür einzureichen, ja.
Ja, die arbeiten alle so ein bisschen zusammen bei diesen großen Dingen,
damit man halt eben nicht bescheißen kann, weil man sonst ja immer schnell mal
so ohne Bändchen durchmogelt und so eine Menge Geld verdienen könnte.
Deswegen ist das alles schon sehr geregelt.
Verstehe.
Krass, wa? CCC, voll egal.
Ja.
Ihr müsstet euch jetzt alle das Bild dazu angucken, wie Tim da in seinem Sessel hängt.
Die Augenbraue hoch und dann so, krass, CCC, voll egal.
Also wir lachen jetzt alle, weil natürlich auch eine Menge passiert,
wo man halt ein bisschen tricksen muss. Ich glaube, das ist aber vorbei.
Aber ich könnte glatt behaupten, wir tricksen noch viel weniger als die ganzen anderen Bescheißer.
Die es da gibt.
Weil die rennen mit Krawatte rum und bescheißen aber noch viel mehr. Könnte ich wetten.
Das liegt daran, dass ihr alle nichts davon hättet, wenn ihr bescheißen würdet.
Ihr persönlich nicht. Weil der Klub auch sehr viele Bürokraten-Fanatiker hat
und die alles ganz ordentlich haben wollen.
Wie, ihr habt Leute mit Stock im Arsch im Club?
Aber hallo.
Was denkst du denn, Alter?
Ich wollte nur sein Aber hallo hören.
Oh weia. Ich glaube, du musst langsam los.
Oder? Ich habe meine Message noch nicht gekriegt, aber ich packe jetzt trotzdem langsam mal zusammen.
Aber mal noch eine Frage jetzt an diese Club-Geschichte und Hotelgeld.
Also wir reden jetzt über 180 Zimmer.
Lass mal so sein, dass die sich die jetzt alle teilen oder so,
dass da jetzt vielleicht dann 360, 400, 500 Leute betrifft.
Aber ihr habt doch viel mehr als die am Start.
Gibt es da noch mehr Hotels?
Das ist ja nur ein Hotel. Betrifft jetzt nur das NH da?
Also ich habe nicht so einen richtigen Überblick über die Situation gerade,
aber ich habe so gerade schon den Eindruck, dass dieser ganze Kongress in der
Hotelszene in Leipzig schwer eingeschlagen hat.
Also die haben da auf einmal so eine Schockwelle gespürt, die sie nicht kannten.
Erstmal ist Weihnachten einfach in Leipzig nichts los.
Die Messe hat ja normalerweise auch zu.
Das ist aber für die Hotels, das ist nicht so wie Hamburg, wo die Leute hinfahren um da Silvester.
Klar gibt es ein bisschen was, aber das schlägt nicht groß aus.
Viele Hotels haben einfach zu über Weihnachten. Gerade die halt direkt an der Messe.
War das nicht, dass das NH auch eigentlich zu gehabt hätte?
Nee, das NH nicht, aber das ist ein anderes. Dann gibt es da wohl auch noch
ein paar andere, die auch so ein bisschen zurückfahren oder weniger Personal oder was weiß ich.
Und dann kam halt einfach dieser Buchungs, diese Schockwelle dieser Buchung
und das hat irgendwie alle vollkommen...
Für wie viele Leute plant ihr jetzt? 15, 20? Oder war das jetzt die offizielle
Planung? Oder ist das geheim?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da überhaupt schon so eine klar fixierte Zahl gibt,
aber du kannst halt mal davon ausgehen, dass wir jetzt nicht weniger haben werden
als zuletzt. so, aber dass wir das Ventil,
Das waren, es war die 12,5 war die Zahl und.
Ich glaube, das fällt schon auf in Leipzig.
Naja, es ist halt Druck.
Das ist krasser als Wave-Graphic-Spanzen.
Oder? Auf diesem Kessel, das wissen wir ja, dass mehr Leute hätten kommen wollen
und es ist auch klar, dass man dieses Ablassventil ein bisschen öffnen muss,
aber wir wollen uns natürlich jetzt auch gerade,
das muss man auch verstehen, wir müssen nicht, das ist jetzt die fünfte Version
des Kongresses, die da jetzt eigentlich entsteht.
Das ist jetzt die fünfte neue Erfindung des Kongresses.
Und du arbeitest natürlich mit dem, was du zuletzt im Kopf hast und mit den
Mengen und Massen und den Gruppen, die da waren und versuchst das jetzt in irgendeiner
Form auf die neue Location zu machen.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, ah, hier Messegelände, open the floodgates,
hier passen ja irgendwie auch 50.000 rein, weil Platz ist ja da.
Haben wir aber nicht bezahlt für 50.000.
Ja, erstens das nicht, aber jetzt nur so von der Grundidee her,
man hätte ja auch sagen können, jetzt haben wir so viel Platz,
jetzt dürfen alle wieder kommen, die ja auch jemals auch nur im Entferntesten
darüber nachgedacht haben, mal auf dem Kongress zu sein.
Dann sprengst du natürlich den Event sowieso, weil er sich einfach nicht mehr,
weil er kein organisches Wachstum mehr hinlegen kann.
Und deswegen müssen wir uns quasi an den alten Zahlen orientieren, plus halt ein X.
Und wie groß dieses X ist, ergibt sich glaube ich im Laufe der jetzt anstehenden
Verkaufsrunden und dann sieht man ja, wie groß die Panik ist und dann kann man
immer noch damit umgehen, also es ist wichtig Und muss man erstmal gucken.
Ob die Leute ja auch alle kommen weil es ist ja schon auch eine andere Stadt,
das ist ja ein bisschen was Anderer Ort.
Genau, also es werden sich sehr viele Parameter mischen und deswegen ist es
vielleicht auch ganz gut, wenn man nicht alle anderen Parameter,
die irgendwie auch erstmal halbwegs konstant sein können auch gleich noch ändert
und am Ende überhaupt nicht mehr der weiß, was jetzt eigentlich,
worauf eine Auswirkung hat.
Naja, du hast ja noch das Problem, du kannst ja nicht nur sagen,
okay, wir haben jetzt Platz für 25.000 Leute, doppelte Menge.
Du musst ja auch die Infrastruktur und die ganze Logistik dann entsprechend anpassen und,
Ich kann nur für die Bereiche sprechen, wo ich ein bisschen Einblick habe.
So viel Mate kann Loscher gar nicht herstellen auf einen Bums oder was.
Naja, also ich sag mal so, realistisch betrachtet hättest du letzten Monat die
Bestellung mal ankippen müssen, damit das produziert wird.
Oder, dass man irgendwie mal sagt, okay, jetzt für den Bereich,
wo ich ein bisschen Einblick habe, wo willst du denn diese ganzen Access Points herbekommen?
Wo willst du die ganzen Switche herbekommen?
Also man muss sich halt vorstellen, so in dem Bereich, dass du dich da wirklich
auch bei so einem Sponsor natürlich schon ziemlich am Limit bewegst,
wenn der einfach mal drei Paletten,
Hardware in dem Gegenwert von mehreren siebenstelligen Zahlen dahin schifft.
Das ist super nett, dass der das macht.
Und das funktioniert mit dem auch super. Aber der hat halt das Lager,
wo er das rausnimmt, ist halt auch irgendwann leer.
Und das kriegen wir langsam hin. Das heißt, wir stoßen halt an ganz andere Kapazitäten
oder wie viel Engel willst du an?
Ich könnte euch einen Sponsor sagen, dessen Lager groß genug ist dafür,
aber den wollt ihr nicht.
Ich gehe über diese Brücke nicht.
Ich weiß, weil ich nämlich auch weiß, was der für andere Veranstaltungen macht
und was da an Hardware auffahren.
Ich möchte diese Schallplatte nicht kaufen, sie ist sehr krass.
Und das hast du halt in allen Bereichen. Du musst halt dann irgendwie die Engelanfall
irgendwie nochmal deutlich höher irgendwie motiviert bekommen und und und und und.
Kannst du auch den Engeln alleine einen neuen Kongress bauen.
Ja genau, du machst einen Engelkongress zwei Tage vorher.
Also das ist halt nicht nur die Location, sondern halt auch das alles,
was dahinter steckt. Du musst das erstmal gewuppt bekommen.
Das ist ja immer das Spannende bei diesen Skalierungsthemen.
Es ist ja so kleine Effekte hier und da, aber dann eben mal,
eine Verdoppelung oder auch nur mal wegen nur 50% mehr irgendwie anzulegen bei
dem Ding, was eh schon groß ist, erzeugt ganz lustige Effekte immer wieder.
Das kenne ich auch. Dann hast du halt tatsächlich die Stadt.
Man merkt schon, dass die an allen Ecken und Enden jetzt so langsam verstehen,
was da eigentlich Weihnachten bei denen da reinschneit.
Wie groß ist die Stadt?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Halbe Million Leute oder sowas.
Oder Einwohner. Einwohnerzahl Leipzig. Lass mich nachschlagen.
Offiziell 560.000.
War ich doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Hamburg war wo? 2 Millionen?
1,8 Millionen.
1,8.
Also ein Viertel. Ist schon kleiner. Ist halt so eine normale deutsche Großstadt.
Naja und die Lage halt der Messe ist noch mal das andere. Das ist wirklich dieses
An- und Ab-Transport-Problem.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist halt vor der Stadt.
Wir sind halt nicht mittendrin. Das ist auch, glaube ich, auch eins der Fragezeichen.
Wir brauchen da mobile Dönerbuden vor der Tür.
Ja, ganz ernsthaft. Und die wirst du nicht in Sachsen zusammengekratzt kriegen
oder in der näheren Umgebung. Da musst du halt immer auch Leute motivieren.
Ich glaube, die kriegt man locker zusammengekratzt, aber wir müssen halt Bescheid wissen.
Wir brauchen einfach korrektes Kälterigen.
Punkt.
Es gibt nichts über einen ordentlichen Döner. Keine Ahnung.
Kannst du Döner-Catering machen.
Weißt du, was viele als ordentliches Catering sich ausdenken,
das ist für andere so, nee, will ich nicht essen.
Also manche brauchen halt ihren Döner, manche brauchen halt ihre,
keine Baguettes oder weißt schon. Also Fastfood ist auch einfach mal schick, weil es fast.
Gibt es Franzbrötchen in Leipzig?
Keine Ahnung.
Es wird uns irgendwas fehlen und wir werden wahrscheinlich auch auf eine ganze
Menge Dinge stoßen, von denen wir nie wussten, dass wir sie unbedingt haben wollen.
Also ich bin nach wie vor sehr gespannt, was sich aus diesem ganzen Experiment
ergibt. Das wird bestimmt ganz geil.
Das wird großartig. Also ich denke schon, dass es großartig wird.
Keiner weiß, wie es wird, aber es wird großartig.
Ja, auf jeden Fall ist es neu. Also ich meine, man war ja auch jetzt so ein bisschen...
Der letzte Kongress war schon zu eingespielt, oder?
Das war schon irre irgendwie. Alle liefen nur noch rum und haben sich gefragt,
was man jetzt überhaupt noch verbessern könnte und so. Und das ist natürlich
auch eine absurde Situation.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ich habe hier noch ein paar Engel. Hast du was zu tun?
Ja, genau.
Den ersten in Hamburg 29 bin ich, glaube ich, noch am 24. angekommen oder 25.
Und dann noch mit aufbauen und so weiter. Und jetzt beim letzten war ich,
glaube ich, schon an Tag 0 da, so kurz bevor wir die Kasse aufmachen,
weil ich weiß, alles ist schon fertig und man muss ja gar nichts mehr machen.
Dann kommt man schon so knapp an und auch alles funktioniert dann auch.
Sozusagen schon zu einfach. Und das haben alle gesagt.
War ja auch so.
Ja, und die Arbeitslosenzahlen sind gestiegen.
Und die ganzen Engel, die halt Alarm machen, weil sie keine Schichten kriegen,
aber weil sie doch ihr Ticket oder ihr T-Shirt haben wollen.
Und machen dann da voll Stress, weil ihre Schicht abgesagt wurde und machen
da richtig Alarm deswegen.
Kommt gerade die Frage.
Wie ist mit Airbnb? Also ich kenne zwei Betroffene, denen wurde die Buchung gecancelt.
Ich glaube annähernd zeitnah mit der Bekanntgabe der Veranstaltung, so einen Tag später.
So nach dem Motto, oh Mann, wir sind ja alle Nerds, wenn wir hier selber wohnen.
Nee, nee.
Da kommen jetzt Hacker. Ich will keine Hacker.
Mehr Geld?
Weil mehr Geld tatsächlich. Also aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen.
Also die haben sich ja irgendwas ausgedacht, weil du darfst bei Airbnb wohl
nicht wegen wirtschaftlichen Gründen das canceln.
Offiziell. Da wurden dann irgendwelche Gründe vorgeschoben, nach dem Motto Renovierungsarbeiten,
bla bla bla, Wasserschaden, wissen nicht, ob das rechtzeitig fertig wird. Im Juli, naja.
Ja, aber dann haben sie trotzdem ja wieder eingestellt zur Vermietung.
Ja.
Also ich zum Beispiel, ich denke mal, ich werde im November mal gucken, was noch übrig ist.
Wie, du hast da noch nichts gebucht?
Nö.
Also mein Problem ist hier, mein Problem ist ja.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch Wohnmobile.
Du wohnst eben noch oder was? Mit einer Matratze oder wie?
Ne, mein Problem ist einfach, ich verbringe halt nicht eine Woche da,
sondern ich bin tendenziell drei Wochen da.
Und drei Wochen so ein Airbnb oder ein Hotel zu bezahlen, liegt halt gerade
noch nicht so in meinen Möglichkeiten.
Ich versuche gerade noch irgendwie andere Optionen. Er hat einen Wohnwagen.
Habe ich gehört.
Ja, Wohnwagen ist noch so.
Warte mal, ist in Leipzig nicht auch die Caravan-Messe? Na, egal.
Ja, mal gucken. Die haben ja auch viele Hallen da frei. Also ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass wir uns da irgendwie noch ein Dorf bauen.
Ein Dorf bauen?
Naja.
Da wird schon noch was passieren. Ein kleines Temp-Camp, ja.
Ja, so ein Caravan-Zentrum.
Man weiß das nicht. Na, ich meine, die Caravan-Messe ist in Leipzig.
Also die Infrastruktur.
Die kennen das, ja.
Es wäre halt theoretisch da, aber.
Ja, wobei, die stellen ja die Wohnwagen dann nur aus und sie pissen und kacken da ja nicht.
Ja, aber sie machen trotzdem Strom dran und solche Dinge und so.
Ja gut, Strom ist ja das nächste Problem.
Naja, ich will da jetzt nicht zu viel versprechen, aber man kann mal drüber nachdenken.
Also ich würde drüber nachdenken.
Ich sag mal Camper Maut.
Aber so ist das ja. Camper Maut und Tesla.
Ich hab schon von Leuten gehört, die mit dem Zug hin und her fahren wollen.
Berlin-Leipzig ist jetzt auch nicht so lange.
Also ich hab Bekannte, der arbeitet in Leipzig und wohnt in Berlin.
Der wird dicht genug an den Bahnhöfen dran. Es gibt ja da diese,
also jetzt nicht nur eine Bahn, es gibt ein schnelles Ding von einer Bahn und
dann nochmal von einer anderen Bahngesellschaft, der braucht keine Stunde,
knapp unter einer Stunde.
Da kenne ich Leute, die haben in Berlin längeren Commute.
Kannst du machen. Aber es ist natürlich dennoch schon blöder,
wenn Kongress gerade dann da nachts irgendwie, dann wird es den nicht nochmal
eine Stunde nach Berlin eiern.
Ja, aber wenn du galistisch betrachtest, stolperst du jetzt morgens um vier
oder um fünf aus der Lounge, bis du am Bahnhof bist, kannst du den ersten Zug
nehmen und nimmst dann halt irgendwann nachmittags wieder den Zug nach Leipzig.
Ist eventuell sogar günstiger als das Hotelzimmer.
Mit Sicherheit sogar.
Da kannst du endlich im Zug in Ruhe so einen Vortrag gucken.
Du hast noch nie WLAN im ICE benutzt.
Du musst natürlich vorher raufladen.
Ja, wir können natürlich so Ladespots machen, so kurz vom Ausgang. Dann gibt es ein Kabel.
Können ja mit der Bahn drehen. Sagen so, wir machen jetzt mal für die Zeit des
Kongressus fixen wir mal euren WLAN von den auf den Strecken von und nach Leipzig.
Oh Gott. So Clemens, wenn du jetzt noch hier bist, Kongress haben wir durch, oder?
Aber egal, erzähl mal.
Du bist jetzt doch abgezogen.
Du bist noch nicht abgerufen worden.
Ich dachte mir so, ist ja Wahl. Und jetzt reden ja gerade alle so über,
was machen wir denn jetzt hier mit der Zukunft von unserem Internet und alle
haben so ihre Wahlbroschüren ausgefaltet, wo sie davon träumen,
dass wir jetzt in der Gigabit Internet Gesellschaft irgendwie.
Dark Fiberland. ankommen wollen und ich dachte mir so,
wir haben ja nun sehr oft darüber gesprochen so über den einen oder anderen
Aspekt und schwedische Modelle und so weiter und ich frage mich so vielleicht
kann man ja auch mal zusammentragen was wir eigentlich gerne hätten Das.
Ist übrigens einer meiner wichtigen Argumente warum wir in Deutschland dieser
Diskussion nicht besonders weit sind und zwar nicht deswegen,
weil jetzt nicht Hannes und sein Bruder,
Gigabit-Internet für 14,95 was sie immer noch für zu teuer halten zu Hause haben
sondern weil eigentlich gar nicht klar ist was jetzt einfach was wir wirklich
davon wollen man hört immer dieses Geschrei ja wir brauchen Glas,
ja okay kann man mal so stehen lassen was machst du jetzt damit genau,
Und ist das auch, ja schön, dass das jetzt Spaß macht, jetzt auf der Telekom
rumzukloppen oder auf irgendwelchen anderen Leuten, aber ist ja eigentlich klar,
dass selbst wenn die Telekom dir das jetzt vor die Haustüre legen würde,
dir dein scheiß Vermieter gar nicht erlaubt,
das von besagter Straße überhaupt in einen fünften Stock hochzuziehen,
weil er hat nämlich gerade erst das Treppenhaus renoviert.
und das heißt, der fragt dich auch nochmal, warum willst du das eigentlich haben?
Ich hab doch hier gerade hier Kabel Deutschland großartig Coax verlegen lassen
vor 20 Jahren, die bieten dir doch auch schon 200 Megabit an und so was,
warum brauchst du jetzt Glas?
Diese Diskussion wird einfach nicht geführt, wird halt einfach mal gesagt,
wir brauchen jetzt alle Glas, sonst werden wir alle sterben.
Aber was du gerade sagtest, was wollen wir jetzt eigentlich?
Wenn du mich jetzt fragst, was ich möchte, ich möchte, dass der Staat anerkennt,
dass das Infrastruktur ist und kein Luxusgut.
Das ist für mich der wichtigste Aspekt an dem allen. Und das ist auch das,
was den Unterschied macht zu vielen anderen Ländern.
Es wird in Deutschland immer noch von der Politik, ja, es wird jetzt nicht mehr
von jedem Scheißhinterbänkler im Bundestag, als, ja, die Leute gucken eh bloß Porn oder so.
Das haben sie schon verstanden, dass wir aus dieser Welle jetzt raus sind.
Aber es wird immer noch als, ja, das ist halt irgendein Luxusgut.
Ja, vielleicht auch ein wichtiges Luxusgut, wie das Schöne ist,
dass Leute sich seltener im Laden kaufen können und sozusagen Wasser trinken
können oder sowas, aber es gibt da keine, es ist nicht als Infrastruktur gesehen.
Mein Beispiel ist immer die Straße.
Und was in Deutschland diskutiert wird von der Politik ist,
wie geben wir, also jetzt Meta-Ebene, wie geben wir jetzt, sagen wir mal,
DHL Geld, damit sie sich jetzt als Zuschüsse, damit sie Straßen bauen können
in deinem Dorf, um dir Pakete ausliefern zu können.
das ist das Diskussionsmodell, was im übertragenen Sinne hier stattfindet.
Und nicht, wir bauen eine Straße.
Und ja, da darf auch DHL drauf fahren, aber auch der UPS und auch der kleine Hermes-Transporter.
Aber die anderen müssen dann bei DHL die Straßenbenutzungsgebühr bezahlen.
Genau, nach der deutschen Denkmodell. Im Gegensatz dazu, wie gesagt,
andere Denkmodell, also öffentliche Infrastruktur.
Hier springen sie nicht drauf an, weil sie Leute diese Separation of Layers
nicht kapiert haben. Weil sie immer glauben, wer das Kabel hat,
muss auch IP darauf machen.
Und das ist halt, das ist ein großes Denkproblem.
Und immer denn, wenn du sowas siehst, wenn hier sowas mal gemacht wird,
wenn hier mal ein Dorf Glasfaser kriegt, weil sich jetzt mal irgendwie ein Bürgermeister
mal ordentlich aus dem Fenster lehnt oder sonst irgendwas, ist das fast immer dieses Modell,
fast immer, dass sie halt irgendeinen kleinen Mini-ISP gefunden haben von dem
lokalen IT-Dienstleister, ein Spin-Off oder sonst irgendwas,
der jetzt da mit staatlicher Förderung Glas legt, aber der ist dann auch der
exklusive Anbieter von dem Schmuddel in dem Dorf.
Was natürlich massiv Probleme erzeugt.
Allen voran das Problem, was ich dann immer ankreide, ist, wenn so was passiert,
ist das verbrannte Erde.
Das heißt, wenn da schon mal jemand hingeht in so ein Dorf, der den Bürgersteig
aufmacht und Zeugs reinlegt und die Vorgärten der Leute aufbuddelt und deren
Haus anbohrt, dann wartet für die nächsten 30, 40 Jahre.
Da kommt niemand niemand jemand anders noch auf die Idee, da nochmal was anderes hinzulegen.
Ich hab ja die Situation bei meinem Stiefbruder in so einem Vorort von Donauwörth,
da ist genau das passiert und er ärmert mich voll, weil dieser eine Exklusiv-Provider
sind voll die Arschgeigen.
Also so Preis und Service und kannst alles voll in die Tonne treten,
sind weit unter dem, was wir alle als Telekom früher gehasst haben.
Und teurer und bla und blub. Und da passiert aber nichts mehr.
Diese Erde ist verbrannt. Den Bürgersteig macht in den nächsten,
Zwei, drei Generationen, keiner mehr auf. Dann habe ich gesagt,
wenn du Glück hast, dann erbarmt sich mal irgendwie ein Telekom oder Vodafone,
stellt dir nochmal einen ordentlichen
LTE oder vielleicht irgendwann einen 5G-Turm in deine Sichtweite.
Wenn nicht, war es das jetzt für dich.
Oder ein Laden macht Konkurs.
Ja, okay. Aber dann wird Kreti nur durch Plety ersetzt.
Da kommt keiner auf die Idee zu sagen, oh, wir haben ja Glas,
das ist ja Infrastruktur, lass uns das mal nicht.
Es gibt zwar ein paar Leute, die das ausprobiert haben, Die sind aber,
die in Deutschland, die sind sehr, sehr, wie ich sagen,
schlau rangegangen, haben allerdings dadurch, dass das keine Politik ist in
diesem Land und auch keine nationale Initiative, sind sie natürlich in die andere
Falle getreten. Die haben als Gemeinde gesagt, wir buddeln jetzt hier mal Glas ein.
Und so, liebe Provider, hier ist der Glasfaserverteiler, da sind alle unsere Haushalte dran.
Jetzt, liebe Telekom, lieber Vodafone, bringt doch mal bitte eure Access-Kisten
her und steppselt unsere Kunden da per Glas an. Und die, die kommen,
sagen, nee, sorry, das machen wir nicht.
Wir machen das auf eigener Infrastruktur und so und hin und her.
Und die haben alle abgewunken.
Das heißt, bis auf ihren Dorfprovider, der das sozusagen mit dir erholfen hat,
das zu bauen, obwohl das Open Access Infrastruktur ist, haben sie sozusagen
bisher keinen anderen gefunden, der da Konkurrenzangebote zu macht.
Das ist zum Beispiel gerade diese Geschichte ist in Schweden,
aber auch in anderen Ländern ist halt ganz anders gedacht und gerätselt.
Klar baut irgendeine Firma das, da kommt jetzt keine Beamten,
die das Glasfaserkabel durch die Straße baut irgendeine Firma,
die wird auch bezuschusst, die darf auch mitspielen, aber die darf halt nicht exklusiv spielen.
ich hab jetzt gerade wieder auf meinem Schwedenurlaub die Bilder bestimmt auf
Twitter gesehen, mitten auf Öland, das ist so eine kleine Insel,
das ist eine kleine Insel, schon über 100 Kilometer, die klemmt so an der Ostküste dran,
da ist aber eigentlich nüsch, im Sommer ist da Tourismus und gerade in der Mitte
dieser Insel ist genau nüsch, nüsch, Felder,
Windmühlen haben sie dort und dann kommst du da an so einem Haus vorbei,
das steht draußen und schnitt vorbei, hier ist ein Glasfaseranschluss drin,
Opennet, Tralala oder IP-only heißen die dort, die das dort machen und dann
klickst du mal auf deren Webseite rum,
wie das so funktioniert und diese IP-only Leute, die sorgen dafür,
dass du überhaupt erstmal Glasfaser ins Haus kriegst und wenn du das aber hast,
dann sagen die so, das war es jetzt und da ist deine Webseite und da suchst
du dir jetzt aus zwei Dutzend Providern, suchst du jetzt einen aus und zwar
für deinen Internetdienst, für deinen Telefoniedienst und für deinen Fernsehen.
Das war ziemlich genau in der Mitte, da ungefähr sogar, wo dieser Ölandstecker steckt, da.
Da, wo jetzt genau da, da ist so ein altes.
Wenn ich Karten auf dem Bildschirm habe, dann darf man das nicht erwähnen.
Warum machst du die Karte dann überhaupt auf den Bildschirm?
Damit er weiß, wo Öland ist. Aber ich will nur sagen, es muss jetzt keine Insel
sein, es ist aber middle of nowhere und das können andere Länder auch.
Aber das hängt alles damit zusammen, dass sie verstanden haben,
um zurück zu zoomen auf meinen ersten Satz.
Das ist Infrastruktur. Das ist genauso, wie wenn die Gemeinde eine Straße baut
oder wenn die Gemeinde dafür sorgt, dass es Wasser und Abwasser gibt,
unter diesem selben Ding wird das gehandelt.
Ja, das darf auch was kosten. Niemand von denen sagt, also Schweden,
da kommt das nicht kostenlos aus der Wand.
Das ist aber erschwinglich für jedermann, natürlich gibt es da auch Sozialtarif
und bla und blub und alles, aber das ist Infrastruktur, die eben allermaßen
allen Leuten, die dort spielen wollen, allen Usern, aber auch allen Providern
offen zur Verfügung steht, wie in Deutschland eine Straße.
Hier darf der DHL genauso wie die Post, wie die FedEx oder sonst was hier durch
die Straßen fahren und ihre Dienste anbieten und der Zeugs machen.
Na gut, jetzt haben wir natürlich das spezifische Problem, dass es derzeit anders ist.
Und wenn du schon die Geschichte erzählst, dass selbst wenn die Situation im
Prinzip so geschaffen ist in irgendeiner Gemeinde, Telekom und Vodafone dann
trotzdem Stinkefinger zeigen und sagen, hier spielen wir nicht mit.
Das wäre was anderes. Ja, weil die einzelnen Gemeinden, da können sie immer sagen.
Wenn es nationale Infrastruktur wäre.
Könnten sich dem nicht entschließen.
Ja gut, aber du kannst ja jetzt nicht alle enteignen. Ja okay,
das wäre vielleicht auch eine Forderung.
Wir könnten ja alle Glasfasern werden jetzt irgendwie Nö. Also was müsste man
sozusagen, also was denkst du würde dazu führen, dass sich das ändert?
Kann man die Dienste nicht entbündeln? Du könntest ja sagen,
dass eine Firma, die das Glas gehört, auch nicht IP machen darf und andersrum.
Ja, nee, nee, nee, das finde ich auch nicht. Wir haben gar nicht so viel Infrastruktur derzeit.
Wir reden ja gerade dafür, dass wir welche bauen wollen. Aber wenn es Infrastruktur
ist, kann ich zum Beispiel machen, dieses Land hier, unseres strotzt vor Verordnung.
Wenn du in der Straße irgendwas machen willst, auch nur einen Bordstein zwei
Millimeter anheben, musst du bestimmt 30 Zettel ausfüllen und so und so viel
Bestimmungen einhalten und da noch ein Messprotokoll und tralala.
Kann man bitte nicht einfach dazu schreiben, wenn du eine scheiß Straße anfasst,
legst du ein Leerrohr mit rein.
Ganz simpel. Und diese Leerrohr, dieses Stück Plastik, das kostet dich jetzt 10 Cent.
10 Cent für einen Meter. Wem gehört das?
Das gehört demjenigen, dem die Straße gehört. Nämlich der, die die Straße anfasst.
Der Gemeinde in der Regel. Wenn es eine Bundesstraße ist, gehört es dem Bund oder wer auch immer.
So, ich möchte jetzt erstmal unter der Straße, möchte ich jetzt erstmal Rohre drin haben.
So, das ist eine ganz simple Regelung, die man aufstellen könnte.
Und die kostet echt nichts, die geht derartig unter in den ganzen Dingern,
das glaubst du gar nicht.
So, jetzt kann man selbst hingehen, wenn man mal weiß, wenn man sich Glasfasertechnik
anguckt, wie die so aussieht. Es gibt da den teuren Faktor und es gibt den billigen Faktor.
Der billige Faktor ist das Material selbst.
Das heißt, eine Glasfaser ist viel billiger als Kupfer und kannst du dir spulenweise
irgendwo herkaufen. Ja, das kostet alle hier einen Cent und da einen Cent.
Aber nicht dem Spotpreis von Kupfer unterlegen.
Erstens das und zweitens ist das echt kein Kostenfaktor, wenn du jetzt drängst,
wir buddeln an der Straße.
Das heißt, man könnte das jetzt weitertreiben. Man könnte jetzt sagen,
jedes Mal, wenn du eine Straße anfasst, machen wir nicht nur einen Leerrauch
rein, sondern schmeißt du erstmal Glasfasern rein.
Was teuer ist, ist an diese Dinger Stecker hinten dran zu machen und das zu
messen und zu machen und zu tun.
Das kann man ja machen in dem Moment, wo man so ein Ding aktiviert.
Aber wenn du jetzt sozusagen für ein Haus irgendwo was machen willst und dann
fängst du extra an, irgendwie die Straße wieder aufzureißen,
das ist natürlich ein riesen Kostenfaktor.
Übrigens nur so nebenbei, da muss ich die Telekom mal loben.
Die Telekom hat bei meinem Landsitz in dem Dorf ja die Basisstation ausgewechselt,
weil die immer gezappt wurde von jemandem da oben aus den Wolken.
Moin?
Hast du das schon erzählt?
Hast du das vorhin schon erzählt?
Ja, meine ich.
Die Blitzende da reingejagt.
Genau.
Für die neuen Zuhörer.
Für alle, die reingeschaltet haben.
Bei der Geschichte haben sie halt eben auch das gemacht, was sie eh machen, nämlich,
weil sie selber Kupfer nicht mögen, ihr Kupfergerassel eingesammelt,
weil das Ding hing nämlich vorher an ihrem alten DSL Opal Tradala Verteiler,
weil die Die alte GSM-Basisstation brauchte nur zwei Megabit.
Das kannst du alles locker mit Kopf verlegen und so.
Und haben also jetzt von ihrem Verteiler am Dorf Anger zu diesem Ding hin Glas verbuddelt.
Allerdings haben sie es so gemacht, wie man es auch macht.
Heutzutage wird Glas nicht mehr direkt verbuddelt, weil das Zeug ist zu fragil.
Was du immer machst, ist, du verlegst Schläuche.
Schlauch kannst du jedem Trop in die Hand drücken. Kannst du auch jedem Hausbesitzer
in die Hand drücken. und sagst, ja, du hast Angst um deinen Vorgarten,
buddelst dir doch selber ein. Das ist einfach 20 Meter Schlauch, mach mal.
Da kann nichts mit passieren. So macht man das.
Diese Dinger siehst du manchmal auf Bildern. Die sind immer lauter bunten Farben oder so.
Dann hast du die Bündels, die die so zusammen so entpacken, so,
was weiß ich, 24, 48, 96 oder so.
Von lauter dünnen Schläuchen, die irgendwo aus irgendwelchen Häusern kommen.
Die werden dann in immer dickere Schläuche eingepackt, also so Schlauch-in-Schlauch-System und so.
Die werden auch ganz simpel zusammengesteckt. Da brauchst du nicht splicen,
wie mit einem Splice-Gerät an der Glasfasern.
Das steckst du einfach zusammen mit so Gummistopfen und so. Wie ein Schlauch halt.
Der muss doch nicht mal wasserdicht sein. Wäre schön, wenn das ist, aber muss er nicht.
Aber ja, okay, wasserdicht. Er soll schon luftdruckdicht sein.
So, und wenn du diese Schlauchinfrastruktur hast, die wirklich jeder Trop mit
normalen Baugeräten legen kann, dann bläst du dort die Fasern ein.
Dann hast du eine Maschinka, die stellst du dann hin an das dicke Ding,
wo dann diese 96 Biester ankommen.
Und die pustet wirklich mit Luftdruck da die Glasfasern durch.
von diesem Zentralpunkt bis an das Haus.
So, und die Telekom hat genau witzigerweise das gemacht und zwar nicht nur ihren
Mast versorgt, sondern alle.
Gelände, alle Grundstücke auf dem Weg vom Dorfanger bis zu diesem Ding,
haben auch einen Schlauch gekriegt.
Da ist zwar jetzt nichts drin, da hat noch keiner in der Glasfaser eingeblasen,
aber kann eingeblasen werden.
Das ist das, was ich meine mit Infrastruktur. Da hat sich die Telekom selber
gebaut. Weil sie das jetzt sagen, okay, wenn wir jetzt unseren Mast da hinten
versorgen wollen und dafür den Bürgersteig aufmachen, sind wir jetzt nicht so
blöde, dass wir für jeden Grundstück nochmal einzeln machen,
sondern wir legen einfach da so einen Schlauch mit rein.
Die haben nicht mal ein Produkt oder einen Auftrag oder sonst irgendwas,
aber selbst die Telekom als kommerzielles Unternehmen investiert in die paar
Cent Schlauch für jeden Grundstück dort,
weil sie einfach sagen, das ist alles viel billiger, wenn wir das jetzt in den
Boden reinschmeißen, für den Fall, dass wir irgendwann nochmal für mal ein Produkt
anbieten wollen oder sowas, als dass wir dann später nochmal den Bürgersteig aufmachen.
Ja, da macht dann irgendwie noch eine Firma auf, die auf einmal ganz groß und
ganz wichtig ist und dann kann man ja eben mal so Highspeed-Internet verkaufen für genau null Extra.
Ne, sie haben noch immer kein Produkt.
Naja.
Wir könnten aber.
Aber ich sage nur, sie schaffen passive Infrastruktur, das ist auch ein wichtiges
Thema übrigens bei der ganzen, es fiel mich gerade gestern auf,
bei dieser ganzen Diskussion mit, warum ist das alles so teuer bei uns und Telekom,
warum ist Fiber to the Curb auch teuer?
Fiber to the Curb braucht aktive Infrastruktur auf der Straße.
Was ist nochmal to the Curb?
Das ist das, was wir jetzt hier als VDSL haben, diese großen brummenden VDSL-Gästen,
die auf der Straße stehen.
Die haben jetzt auch wieder den Effekt, da ist aktive Elektronik drin,
das heißt, du musst da Strom reinlegen und wenn der lokale Stromversorger wieder
ETP-Tete ist, dann muss da wieder ein Zählerkasten dran gebaut werden mit einem Zähler drin,
der auch wieder eine Zählergebühr verursacht und lalala pipapo,
das Ding hat wieder Lüfter drin, hat drehende Teile, Elektronik, das ist alles teuer.
Teuer, schwer, steht mitten im Straßenland rum.
Mit dieser passiven Infrastruktur, mit den Schläufen, kannst du das über mehrere Kilometer machen.
Wenn du willst, also Klassik, was ich gesehen habe in Schweden,
der längst seit ich gesehen habe, war 60 Kilometer. Passive Infrastruktur.
Also jetzt war nicht ein Schlauch, der 60 Kilometer war, aber war eine Glasfaser
drin, wo das nächste aktive Element 60 Kilometer weg ist.
Also eine 60 Kilometer lange Glasfaser?
Die ist schon mal zusammengesteppt. Die kommt ja dann schon mal an von dem Haus,
die wird dann so ein paar Kilometer.
Aber ohne irgendwelche Repeater dazwischen, sondern.
Ohne aktive Elektronik. Das kannst du übrigens, das ist auch keine High-End-Technik.
Du kannst jetzt hingehen, nur mal als Beispiel, hier in der Stadt in Berlin
reichen für alles, was ich hier mal so mache, für Veranstaltungen oder so,
basierend auf Dark Fiber reicht mir fast immer ein normaler 10 Kilometer SFP.
Ne, LX-SFP. Und diese Dinger kosten nix. Nix.
Weißt ja nicht, was du für Gelände hast in Hamburg, aber hier reicht mir eigentlich
alles in Berlin mit den Kilometern.
Die besagte Fuchs, die wir vorhin erwähnt haben, die haben wir auch mit einer
Darkfiber angeklemmt und da sind es dann schon 14,7 Kilometer zum Beispiel.
Ja, wo jetzt, vielleicht ist einfach die Datacenter dicht, die hier in Berlin höher.
Das mag sein.
Aber auch das ist kein Problem, weil die nächste Phase sind 40 Kilometer für
diese Dinger und die kosten nichts mehr.
Der Jahr, der kostet irgendwie 30 Euro mehr als der 10 Kilometer.
Ja, bei Gigabit zu vernachlässigen.
Ja, machst du das auch mit 10G? Habe ich übrigens sogar ein Auto,
ich könnte jetzt gerade so ein 10G-SFP zeigen.
Ein Bidi.
Ein Bidi, das heißt, der sozusagen auf einer Phase...
Also SFP ist das, was man in die Glasfaser reinklemmt, damit man da Daten rüber schickt.
Ja, man hat das vor ein paar Jahren, schlauerweise hat man das entkoppelt.
Was heißt denn das?
Ich will es ja gerade erklären, dass die Optik in deinem Gerät nicht mehr fest eingebaut ist.
So wie die G-Bix früher oder wie die hießen. Jetzt sind die ja kleiner und schmaler.
Kleiner, schmaler und wofür die jetzt reden, ist jetzt SFP Plus.
Das sind diese Dinger, diese Small Factor.
Diese kleinen, quadratischen, langen Dinger. Genau.
Sehen so aus wie so ein kleiner Finger halt. Nicht besonders groß.
Kannst du als SFP Plus, wie gesagt, mit 10G und teilweise auch ein bisschen
mehr fahren, 12G oder sonst sowas.
Und diese, genau. Und das heißt, die Geräte haben nur noch dieses Loch drin.
Ja, und das, was da rausguckt, da wurde jetzt schon.
Ich wollte ja nur gucken, wie es heißt. Small Formfaktor Plugable Transceiver.
Und deine Geräte haben jetzt alle nur noch dieses Loch. Und du besorgst halt SFPs.
Und diese SFPs gibt es für alles mögliche, was du an Medium hast.
Auch für Kupfer. Es gibt zum Beispiel SFPs, wo ein normaler Rj45 Stecker hinten
wieder dran ist, wo dann wieder ein Gigabit Kupfergigabit drauf ist.
Das heißt, dein Gerät ist egal, welche Strecke du überwinden willst.
Dafür suchst du das richtige SFP aus.
Das heißt, der, der Kurzstrecker hat, der kann die billigen SFPs nehmen und
der, der 100 Kilometer machen will, der muss das teure SRP kaufen.
Kann ich das so verstehen?
Alles klar.
Du kannst nicht jeden SFP überall reinstecken, weil die haben natürlich unterschiedliche
Power-Sachen und nicht jedes Gerät
kann SFP Plus und so. Also die erste Generation war halt so eingehen.
Aber so vom Prinzip ist das ungefähr.
Und diese Dinger haben einen wahnsinnigen Preisverfall. Und wie gesagt,
ich habe jetzt im Auto welche für 10 Kilometer 10G,
Bidis, das heißt, die machen auf einer Faser, senden sie in beiden Richtungen
mit unterschiedlichen, mit zwei Frequenzen.
Also bidirektional.
Das heißt, du brauchst nur eine Faser. üblich, was auch schön ist,
weil gelegt wurde traditionell immer Paare.
Und das heißt, man kann jetzt einfach mal hingehen und das bestehende Glas,
was im Garten, im Boden drin ist, national, ohne dass man auch nur eine halbe Schippe anfassen muss.
Hat sich alles mal verdoppelt.
Kannst du verdoppeln, wenn du willst, indem du einfach nur die SFPs austauschst
oder neue SFPs reinmachst mit Bidi zum Beispiel.
Achso, nur so, um da mal einen Preisfaktor zu nennen, ein paar von diesen 10G,
10 Kilometer Bidi-SFPs, Single-Mode kostet so irgendwie 120 Euro.
Das ist ja nüscht.
Du brauchst dir immer ein Pärchen, weil die ja unterscheidet,
der eine sendet auf, sagen wir mal, auf blau und der andere auf rot und so,
aber das ist so verfallen inzwischen im Preis, dass du darüber nicht mal nachdenken musst.
Übrigens auch das ist ein Punkt, wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht über Gigabitze
oder sowas zu reden, weil mit deinem Glas habe ich eine Infrastruktur,
da kann ich dir auch irgendwann mal in fünf Jahren, wenn ich mir Lust habe,
das zu leisten, mache ich mir auch mal dann sozusagen die 100G-Variante da drauf.
Dem Glas.
Oder 400.
Also wir machen das jetzt zum Beispiel, wir sind jetzt an dem Punkt,
da wir immer sagen, es ist so billig geworden, dass wir jetzt die Gigabit-Strecke
einfach mal austauschen durch eine 10 Gig Strecke, indem wir einfach sagen,
wir tauschen die beiden Optiken und fertig. Und das war's dann so.
Und dann fällt halt anstatt ein Gigabit-Netz in dem Gebäude halt 10 Gig-Netz raus.
Das geht nicht so leicht mit deinem Fiber to the Curb. Das geht zwar auch,
weil die sind auch nicht doof, aber da musst du Geräte rausschrauben und andere
Geräte reinschrauben. Und deine Geräte konnten das schon? Das ist keine SFP.
Wir haben jetzt Geräte bekommen, die 40 Gig können.
Okay, dann musst du das also schon auftauschen. Das reicht dann nicht nur,
SFP zu tauschen, wenn deine Geräte dahinter auch schon 5 Jahre alt sind.
Dein Gerät muss natürlich SFP Plus dann können. Aber wenn du jetzt sag ich,
du fängst mal an, du hast ein SFP Plus fähiges Gerät und dann sagst du dir erstmal,
ja, ich habe jetzt auch in dem Rechenzentrum nur ein Gigabit irgendwie Uplink
mir geschnorrt oder eingekauft,
dann steckst du erstmal deine 20-Euro-Optiken da rein, die irgendwie noch rumliegen,
die noch irgendjemand übrig hatte und,
so wie wir, dann jetzt haben wir jetzt ein Jahr im Betrieb und jetzt,
oh, jetzt haben wir Geräte gesponsert, geschenkt, geliehen, Dauerleihgabe bekommen,
die SFP Plus abkönnen bis 40 Gig und jetzt sagen wir, ja, die 10 Gig Optiken
kosten jetzt auch nicht mehr so viel, die 40 Kilometer Variante,
dann stecken wir die da jetzt rein und dann fallen da halt irgendwie.
Das geht jetzt ohne, dass du dir den Arm und den Bein dafür abschneiden musst,
geht das bis ungefähr 100 Kilometer, also 90, 100 Kilometer.
Ich fasse jetzt einfach mal zusammen, das Problem, viele Daten über lange Strecken
ist gelöst, es ist billig, man hat es bloß nicht.
Wenn man den Stock aus dem Arsch nimmt.
Wenn man den Stock aus dem Arsch nimmt und man muss ja auch irgendwie jetzt
eine politische, man muss ja jetzt sozusagen eine konkrete oder mehrere konkrete
politische Forderungen aufstellen.
Was muss eigentlich jetzt genau geändert oder anders gemacht werden,
um so einen Weg einzuschlagen?
Es muss erstmal die Grundidee eines Open Access Netzes hinkommen.
Die Leute müssen verstehen, was das bedeutet.
Autobahnen.
Ja, kann man nehmen.
Früher wurde immer Datenautobahn gesagt und wir haben alle gelacht.
Und sagt Maut, Maut, Maut, Maut, Maut, Maut, Maut, Maut, Maut.
Kann man ja auch alles machen, aber es muss erstmal verstanden werden,
das Internet ist nicht Infrastruktur.
Internet ist einer der Nutzer, der Hauptnutzer der Infrastruktur.
Ich habe das vorhin mal so am Rand erwähnt, das ist natürlich auch IP-Basis
alles inzwischen, aber das merkt Autonomal-User nicht.
Bei diesem schwedischen Open Access-System, da kannst du drei Sachen klicken auf der Webseite.
Wo kriege ich mein Internet her? Wo kriege ich mein Fernsehen her?
Und wo kriege ich mein Telefon her?
Deswegen verkaufen sie es auch an die Oma draußen auf dem Dorf.
Die hat sowieso ihr iPad inzwischen, weil sie das sozusagen von ihren Enkeln
gekriegt hat zu Weihnachten, damit die sich da facetimen können und sowas.
Aber die ist jetzt nicht der Internet-User, die jetzt das Gig symmetrisch braucht.
Aber was sie braucht, ist ein Telefon, was funktioniert, damit sie ihre scheiß
Nachbarin jeden Tag zwei Stunden anrufen kann.
Und ein Telefon, was nicht dauernd immer kaputt geht, weil der Mast umgefallen
ist vom letzten Sturm oder weil ein Blitz irgendwo eingeschlagen hat.
ist kein Scheiß, damit verkaufen sie das den Leuten damit verkaufen sie auch den,
und natürlich dann die anderen Leute HD Fernsehen und Tralala und Pipapo und
ja, die klickt sich dann auch 10 oder da gibt es auch asymmetrische Modelle
da gibt es dann auch Leute, da klickst du halt eben 100 Megabit weil das so
das kleinste ist, was du überhaupt irgendwie klicken kannst mit 10 Megabit Uplink oder sowas das ist immer.
Noch besser als das, was ich hier habe ja.
So Zeugs aber das sind alles verschiedene Dienste die auf dieser Open Access,
Infrastruktur dazukommen.
Und diese kannst du dir von verschiedenen Leuten klicken. Kannst du dein Internet
von Teleja klicken, aber das Fernsehen findest du besser von Tele2.
Es geht alles über dasselbe Kabel, es geht alles über dasselbe Basisnetz.
Ja.
Ja genau, aber was brauchen wir jetzt? Was könnte man machen?
Mehr Konkurrenz zulassen.
Naja, ich rede jetzt auch konkrete Maßnahmen. Wir haben ja eine Bundesnetzagentur,
die sich so ein bisschen irgendwie um alles so ein bisschen kümmert.
Aber eigentlich brauchen wir ja da sozusagen so ein Äquivalent zu dem ganzen Autobahnbau.
Ich will jetzt diesen Vergleich nicht zu sehr bemühen, aber im Prinzip bräuchte
es eine Behörde, es bräuchte eine Behörde, die sozusagen mindestens Leerrohre,
wenn nicht sogar mit Glasfaser beschickte Rohre irgendwie in Deutschland langsam
ausrollt und die sozusagen Schritt für Schritt das auch erzwingt.
Das heißt, jedes Loch, was geöffnet wird in Deutschland, hat gefälligst mit
öffentlicher Infrastruktur vorgerüstet zu werden.
Es müsste zweierlei passieren. Es muss auf technischer Ebene was stattfinden,
es muss eine Standardisierung stattfinden, damit man das auch bauen kann und
national ausrollen kann, ohne dass wieder jeder seinen Scheiß macht.
Das müssen wir nicht neu erfinden, liebe Deutsche.
Da könnt ihr einfach mal zu unseren EU-Nachbarn gehen, egal in welche Richtung.
Und die fragen, wie man sowas baut, falls ihr da nicht selber Ideen für habt.
Aber das kann man sich einfach mal abgucken, wie die anderen das machen.
Machen das jetzt alle?
Und das geht jetzt um Frankreich?
In Frankreich weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie das mit Open Access aussieht.
Die haben eine andere Struktur. Da ist halt France Telecom noch sehr stark,
die aber auch gute Vorgaben haben, was sie so zu bauen haben.
Also da ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, inwiefern die öffentlich und trennen. und da.
Egal, aber in Holland machen sie zum Beispiel auch viel Open Access und so weiter.
Du kannst auch hinfahren oder nach Schweden, nach Dänemark, nach Norwegen. Egal.
Überall.
So, und das heißt, das ist aber dieser eine technische Teil.
Der andere wichtige Teil ist, dass einfach eine umfassende Bildung,
und zwar jetzt nicht, wie funktioniert dieses Protokoll, sondern was bedeutet
das? Wem gehört hier was?
Auf Deutsch übersetzt wer haftet für was? Und das muss klar sein,
das muss pamphletisiert sein, das muss jeder Drecksdorfbürger Bürgermeister
in Deutschland musstet verstanden haben,
ja, dass nicht sein Schwager hier Glasfaserkabel legt und er der Internet-King
von Dollar Dorf wird, ja, wie derzeit der Fall ist, sondern das,
was Open Access bedeutet, genauso wie ihnen klar ist, dass eine öffentliche
Straße öffentlich ist, dass da jeder drauf fahren darf.
Ja, so. Dann muss es geben, dann muss es nationale Infrastrukturträger geben,
die man auch mit rannehmen kann.
Was viele dieser Dörfer auch haben als Problem ist, die bauen sich jetzt ihr
tolles Dorf-Internet und nehmen noch, was sich den Vorort-Tralala mit dazu,
indem alle nochmal anfassen und zusammen mit einer Hacke nochmal zwei Kilometer
übers Feld buddeln, damit auch das Vorörtchen mit den fünf Häusern da hinten noch dran hängt.
Aber die haben ja das Know-how nicht, um sowas zu betreiben.
Nee, brauchen sie nicht. Die sollen Schläuche einbuddeln. Das können sie, das kann jeder.
Und nee, was die auch brauchen, die brauchen irgendwann auch mal Zugang an Backbone.
Was andere Länder auch gemacht haben, zum Beispiel in Schweden haben sie schon
vor vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren, haben sie mal einen nationalen Backbone gelegt.
Das heißt, da ist mal jemand hingegangen, da müsste ich jetzt mal nachforschen,
werdet wahr, ob da jemand Thiel ja beauftragt hat oder wie auch immer,
sie haben einfach mal eine fette Glasfaserschleife durch ihr scheiß langes Land gelegt.
Von unten, von keine Ahnung, Trelleborg oder Uestert bis hoch nach an die norwegische Grenze.
Oben sozusagen im Nordkap hinten. Und wieder zurück.
Und diese Dings erstmal da, so als allgemeiner Backbone, da machen sie zum Beispiel
auch öffentliche, rechtliche Fernsehen, verbreiten sie da drüber und all solche
Sachen, wo man halt alles, was man so transportieren will als Informationen
in welcher Form auch immer.
Und es steht aber auch zu Open Access Konditionen Netzprovidern zur Verfügung,
weil um so einen Netzprovider aus Stockholm dazu zu kriegen,
dass er irgendwie fünf Lappen oben in Lapland mit Internet zu versorgen,
kannst du dich nicht hinstellen und sagen, ja das ist ja alles private hier,
dann fährst du da einfach mal 3000 Kilometer hoch und buddelst dir mal ein Kabel
ein. dann zeigt dir der natürlich einen Vogel.
Aber wenn du sagst, pass mal auf, wir bringen dich auf unserem nationalen Backbone,
kannst du dir zu vernünftigen Konditionen, kannst du dir Bandbreite anmieten,
die dich bis 5 Kilometer vor das Dorf bringen, dann buddelt der auch noch die
5 Kilometer von da bis in das Dorf ein.
Das macht er dann auch noch. Das muss man sich jetzt mal angucken.
Das sind andere Situationen in diesen Ländern. Andere geografische Situationen
und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, aber da ist halt, wie jedes Rentier ist da ein WLAN-Accesspoint und hier hat kein Hund jetzt.
Wir haben hier nationale Infrastrukturträger. Das sind zum Beispiel die Bahnen.
Das ist der Bund mit seinen Bundesautobahnen. Die haben Wegerechte.
Das sind die Leute, die Wasserschifffahrt und Kanäle und sowas haben.
Ja, aber auch Wasserwerke.
Ja, das ist ja schon wieder in den Städten. Ich rede jetzt mal so von nationalen
Backbohnen. Wie Chris setzt den Schmuddel überhaupt erstmal hin in dein Dorf?
Selbst wenn dein Dorfbürgermeister willig ist, der muss ja auch erstmal seine
Connection zum DZX kriegen mit seinem Mininetz oder wie auch immer.
Auch da kann man durchaus hingehen, man kann sagen, wir verpflichten nationale
Infrastrukturträger wie die Bahn oder wie bla bla bla.
Die Bahn hatte das ja schon mal und hat es ja dann irgendwie Vodafone verkauft.
Ja, sie haben noch mehr gefunden. Aber die, wir wollen das jetzt ja nicht auch
im Detail ausmalen, dafür reicht die Sendezeit jetzt auch wieder nicht.
Aber ich will nur sagen, auch die muss man mal mit rannehmen und sagen,
pass mal auf Leute, wir haben jetzt hier mal eine nationale Anstrengung.
Und das ist jetzt nicht, was Dollar Firma macht, der wir jetzt irgendein Geld
geben, sondern wir bauen jetzt Infrastruktur. Ja, sozusagen.
Wie hieß das? Was haben sie nach der Wende gesagt? Da gab es doch diesen Plan,
der immer noch irgendwie gilt.
Deutsche Einheit.
Ja, Aufbau, Infrastrukturplan.
Nein, nein, Aufbau Ost.
Deutsche Einheit, la la la pipapo, wo sozusagen mal national festgelegt wird,
ja, wir möchten gerne tolle Straßen haben, auch im Osten. Mal simpel gesagt oder so, ja.
und diesen Schritt müssen wir erstmal finden, solange diese Aufbruchsstimmung,
das heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich Politiker mit einer Schippe in der Hand sehen
will, sondern einfach mal nur
dieses Grundverständnis von diesem ach Internet, geh mir doch weg damit,
lass das die Telekom machen oder wen auch immer sondern einfach,
dass die verstehen dass das wichtig ist für uns alle ja Verkehrsprojekte Deutsche
Einheit, kannst du nochmal spielen das Ding,
kannst jetzt sagen, wir machen jetzt das.
Datensprojekt Deutsche Einheit,
Und da hängt so viel dran und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, dass deine Bit-Torren schneller laufen.
Das ist immer das, was so Leute dann manchmal hinten für sich da rausziehen,
sondern wie wir sehen, da kommt Telefon drüber und da kann man auch dazu sagen
für die Politiker, ja, auch deinen Fax kann man da drüber machen,
da kannst du dann über Glasfaser faxen.
oder halt für die Fernsehfuzzis, ja da kommt euer Fernsehen drüber und so weiter und so fort,
das ist nationale Infrastruktur auch für Notversorgung und you name it,
da kann man alles mögliche, Kommunikationsinfrastruktur ist wichtig,
und die Leute sehen das nicht, die Leute sehen das als Privatspiel Platz für irgendwelche Konzerne,
und ja, man kann auch mal mit ein bisschen bayerischer Förderung oder sowas
auch mal dem Huber Andreas mit seinem kleinen IT-Laden noch mal erlauben,
Auxysheim da auszustatten mit Glasfaser. Aber das ist es nicht. Das kann es nicht sein.
Sondern die müssen halt einfach mal so aus dem Griff kommen.
Vielleicht muss man denen erklären, dass da drüber ihre Vorratsdatenspeicherung
kommt. Dann sind sie schnell dabei. Das kriegen sie sowieso.
Ja, kannst du auch probieren. Also da kann man jetzt polemisch rangehen, bis der Arzt kommt.
Und der kommt spät. Aber was ist denn.
Wenn ich jetzt, jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, irgendwie es gab die geile Wahl
und wir haben irgendwie jetzt nur noch Leute am Start, die jetzt innerhalb von
zwei, drei Jahren die Voraussetzungen schaffen, dass alles gut wird.
Das geht nicht aufgrund unserer föderalen Strukturen. Wir brauchen nicht eine geile Wahl.
Das reicht nicht. Nehmen wir mal hypothetisch an, dass dem so sei.
Wir haben das jetzt mal gemacht und alles wird gut und jetzt wohne ich irgendwo
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in so einem,
Dorf mit irgendwie 20 Seelen und es gibt irgendwie so sterbendes GSM und das
ist sozusagen meine Verbindung zur Außenwelt.
Wie sähe es dann aus? Also wo würde man sozusagen losgehen, um überhaupt diesen
Ort erstmal überhaupt mit der Welt zu verbinden? Nehmen wir mal an,
da gibt es jetzt so ein bisschen Du.
Legst einen Schlauch Schlauch,
von deinem Ort diesem Schlauch befinden sich lauter kleine Schläucher nämlich
für alle deine 20 Nasen, die wahrscheinlich nur in 10 Häusern wohnen,
also machst du da mal so 12 so eine Mini-Schläuche rein nur den Schlauch,
in deinen großen Schlauch und den legst du jetzt mal in deine nächste Kreisstadt.
Die darf auch gerne mal 40 Kilometer weg sein.
Wenn du das bist Wegerechte sind jetzt sozusagen dann Straße also würde ich
dann irgendwie Straße benutzen Schiene.
Übrigens nur New Strom. Total neue Entdeckung.
Man kann Kabel auch an Masten hängen, auch Schläuche. Hat natürlich das Problem,
die fallen gerne immer wieder um, aber bei uns fallen die gar nicht so häufig
um wie in anderen Ländern.
Strom kommt ja da sowieso an und das kommt auch nicht selten über sowas.
Da kommt auch nicht selten Glasfaser über diese Strommasten.
Ja.
Ja, aber bloß eh ne, da ist schon eine Faser drin. Und oder zwei oder jedenfalls nicht genug.
Da, ja, also das schmeißt du erstmal rein und dann ist es gut.
Damit kannst du auch dein Popeldorf versorgen.
Weil egal, egal, was hindert einen Ort heute daran, das zu tun?
Das Verständnis, dass man das braucht.
Wir wollen ja sozusagen eine Wahl beeinflussen, jetzt durch eine Argumentation
und nicht irgendwie das Verständnis eines Dorfes ändern, das ist ja nochmal ein anderes Problem.
Das Problem, was da auch noch anderweitig besteht, ist diese Sicht darauf,
dass das Luxusgut und keine Infrastruktur ist, ist nicht nur bei Politikern verbreitet.
Sondern auch in diesem Dorf.
Ja.
Die Dörper sind schuld, das ist es nämlich.
Nee, die musst du überzeugen.
Vielleicht muss man einfach mal Fernsehen abschalten, das gibt es nur noch über
Netz und dann geht es ganz schnell.
Wenn so, ja, aber wenn so eine Infrastrukturmaßnahme wie zum Beispiel in Schweden
passiert, dann machen die doch so, die buddeln nicht für jedes Haus einzelne
Schlauch ein, sondern da gehen Leute vorher durchs Dorf mit so Broschüren in der Hand,
die erklären den Leuten das mit diesem Open Access und lalala pipapo und wir
kommen in drei Monaten in dein Dorf.
Wenn du jetzt mitspielen willst, dann darfst du mitspielen für billig.
Ich habe mal so Preise gehört, so 2.000, 2.500 Kronen sind so 2.250 Euro für einen Hausanschluss.
Da ist noch kein Dienst drauf, nur der Hausanschluss, dass du deinen Schlauch
da kriegst, durch den dir irgendjemand mal eine Faser einbläst.
und in einem Projekt fand ich es sehr nett, sollen die Leute auch noch zwei Tage mithelfen.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass die selber metertief den Boden aufhacken,
aber dass ich dem Baggerfahrer einen Kaffee bringen oder da mal einen Stein
wegräumen oder da mal einen Zaun abschrauben oder weißt du, so Supplementary Services und so,
und die Oma, die nicht mitschrauben kann, die macht halt Kuchen für die Truppe,
die das draußen macht und so.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen Community mäßig. Also die Community beteiligt sich,
Die wird auch zum Beispiel in dem Sinne mit einbezogen, dass der gesagt wird, pass mal auf,
da wo die Schläuche alle enden, brauchen wir eine Hütte und diese Hütte muss
halt eine Grundfläche von 8, 9 Quadratmetern haben und so und so sein,
sucht euch eine Hütte aus und sagt uns, wo sie hin soll.
Alle 11 Minuten verliebt sich eine Oma in einen Glasfaserbläser.
So, die gehen mit diesen Broschüren durch die Gegend und sagen,
wenn du da jetzt mitspielst, kannst du das Ding für billig kriegen,
und dann fasst das ganze Dorf mit an und dann haben die erstmal alle Schlauch
im Keller und vielleicht auch sogar schon eine Glasfaser dran,
die dann in dieser Hütte irgendwo endet und diese Hütte kann durchaus 10,
15, 20, 26 Kilometer wegstehen Wem.
Gehört die Glasfaser, wenn sie denn dann mal da drin ist?
Ist ja egal, die kostet ja eh nichts Das ist eine interessante Frage,
wer sie jetzt rein liegele hinterher und du bezahlst diesen Anschluss,
das heißt das Recht, eine solche Glasfaser in deinem Haus zu haben, mit deinem Beitrag.
Du kannst es auch später noch mitspielen, wird es aber teurer,
weil sie für dich extra die Straße aufmachen müssen.
Wem gehört der Wasseranschluss deines Hauses? Wem gehört der Stromanschluss deines Hauses?
Nicht der Anschluss, die Leitung.
Ja, die Leitung. Wem gehört die Wasserleitung, die zu deinem Haus geht?
Wem gehört die Stromleitung?
Verrückt dich dem Wasserwerk.
Die Stromleitung, die zu deinem Haus gehört, ist die gleiche Frage.
Ich kann sie nicht beantworten, aber das ist irgendwie...
Ja gut, aber es ist ja sozusagen die Frage, die beantwortet werden muss.
Gehört das an der Gemeinde? Gehört das einer Bundesbehörde für Netzausbau? Es kann dir egal sein.
Weil du hast ein...
Es ist mir auch egal, ich frage nur, was ist es?
Kann ich dir nicht beantworten, müsste ich mir jetzt mal nachfragen, müsste mal nachgucken.
Ist es so aber, dass du aufgrund deiner vertraglichen Vereinbarung hast,
hast du das, was die Provider gerne ein IRU nennen, ein Irrefutable Right of Use.
Das heißt, du hast sozusagen das Recht, das unwiderrufliche Recht,
dieses Ding zu benutzen.
Ein eingetragenes Wegerecht nennt man das glaube ich.
Oder könnte man vielleicht ein eingetragenes Wegerecht nennen.
Ich habe eine Glasfaser nicht, weil ich sie benutze.
Genau.
Das kann sein, dass die jetzt nicht dir gehört. Das könnte sein,
dass jemand stinkig wird, wenn du an dieser Glasfaser ziehst und irgendwo 10
Kilometer weiter so eine Hundehütte umfällt.
Aber du hast sozusagen durch deinen Hausanschlussgebühr hast du sozusagen das
bezahlt, dass du dieses Ding benutzen darfst. Peng.
So.
Ja.
Das kann man jetzt nochmal, das schaffen wir nicht. Das muss auf kommunaler
Ebene, auf nationaler Ebene und so weiter.
Das müssen die Leute verstehen und diese Zusammenwirken, diese Frage zum Beispiel, wem gehört das Ding?
Und natürlich auch gerne die Frage für den Dorfbürgermeister beantwortet, wer haftet denn da?
Da können wir gerne mal 50 Anwälte draufsetzen oder Jurastudenten,
die sich mal eine schöne Dissertation dazu ausknuspern, wer jetzt da haftet,
wo auch immer jetzt das sein mag, aber egal, diese Ressourcen hat dieses Land.
Ja, da kann man sich einmal beschäftigen, das kann man machen,
das muss nicht jedes Dorf sich neu ausknubbeln.
Da kann man einfach sagen, so sind die schwierigen, genauso wie zum Beispiel Straßenrecht gibt.
Straßenrecht gibt es ja auch als Bundesrecht und als Landesrecht,
das genau festlegt, was technische Standards festlegt, was sagt,
wer ist dafür zuständig, das Ding zu bauen, wem gehört das hinterher und so weiter und so fort.
Kannst du eins zu eins nicht übernehmen, aber kannst du gucken,
welche Fragen gibt es dort und welche Fragen gibt es auf der Glasfaser-Seite, wie beantworte ich die?
Im Prinzip kannst du es machen wie beim Strom.
Also ich bin der Meinung, man sollte es einfach wie Strom behandeln,
weil dann, ich meine, da gibt es Eigentümer der ganzen Kabelwege,
der Hochspannungsleitung etc.
pp., aber die haben halt feste Vorgaben, die sagen,
du musst den Strom durchleiten, auch wenn du nicht die Rechnung beim Endkunden stellst,
sondern ich kann ja irgendwie einen Stromprovider gründen und ich muss keine
einzige Leitung bauen, aber ich kann Strom verkaufen. Ich muss halt dann Rechnung bezahlen.
Du kannst Strom mit Hamsterrädern erzeugen und die einspeisen.
Dann hast du Hamsterstrom und den kannst du auch irgendwie verkaufen.
Das gleiche kannst du halt mit Internet im Prinzip auch machen.
Wenn du sagst, okay, du baust eine Leitung, alles klar, kannst du machen, die kann dir gehören.
Dann mach dein Stadtwerk.
Was auch immer. Aber jeder, der an diesem Markt teilnimmt, darf diese Leitung
nach gewissen Regularien benutzen. Und du darfst dich dagegen nicht versperren,
sonst darfst du dieses Netz nicht betreiben.
Aber das Problem ist ja, dass die Leitungen noch nicht da sind, oder?
Ja, aber übrigens, das ist ein guter Hinweis, dass man das auch nachträglich
machen kann, weil vorhin wurde ja hier schon angeregt, dass man sagt,
wir enteignen einfach alle. Aber so, das hätte ja auch nicht passiert.
Im Strom kamen diese Regelungen mit den mehreren Anbietern ja schon Jahrzehnte,
nachdem unsere Stromnetze alle schon lagen.
Und auch dort, natürlich haben die alle geknirscht mit den Zähnen.
Wollen das alle nicht?
Es ist übrigens beim Gas genau dasselbe und ich kenne jemanden sehr nah an eine
Firma, auch einer von meinen Kunden, die in diesem Markt dort tätig sind,
da ist auch Kostenexplosion gewesen, weil die Firmen, so Gasfirmen,
denen früher alles gehörte,
jetzt plötzlich aufgespalten wurden in Transporteure, in Verkäufer und in Lagerer und Tralala und Pipa.
Also das wirbelt so einen Markt schon durcheinander, aber die haben es alle überlebt.
Das sind Energiemarkte, das heißt die haben es geschafft diesen Energiemarkt
aufzubrechen und vom Prinzip haben wir, da hat Al vollkommen recht,
wir haben im Strom- und Gasmarkt eine Open Access Infrastruktur und das haben
sie geschafft mit welchen hier und welchen dort,
aber das heißt man hat die bestehenden Netze übernehmen können.
Nichtsdestotrotz brauchen wir natürlich auch noch Infrastruktur.
Wir haben zwar sehr viel die Telekom, der Telekom ex-Bundespost gehört,
wahnsinnig viel Infrastruktur.
Die reicht aber nicht aus, um eine Glasfaser an jedes Haus zu legen,
weil sie dafür auch nicht gebaut wurde.
Die ist halt maximal für FTTC bisher gebaut worden.
Was sie jetzt halt machen müssen, ist sie müssen sich jetzt überlegen,
wie wir vielleicht mal aus FTTC vielleicht FTTH machen.
Oder dazu ist auch eine spannende Geschichte.
Ich hatte neulich eine Diskussion mit jemandem, der auch sagt,
ja, Glas, ich brauche Glas im Haus und hin und her und tralala und ich so,
ja schön, jetzt hast du jetzt Glas im Haus, was machst du denn damit?
Ja wie, nee, nee, also wie meinst du das jetzt, ja wo steckst du das jetzt rein?
Ja, das stecke ich jetzt in meinen Router rein. Okay, und wie kommst du jetzt
von deinem Router denn zu deinem Gerät?
Oder deinen Geräten? Ja, ja, ja, WLAN.
Okay, und die anderen? Ja, dein Kupfer. Ich so, warum beschwerst du dich,
wenn die Telekom genau dasselbe machen will halt nur, weil sie dir jetzt dein Glas hat?
Ja, weil er mehr Geräte per Kupfer anschließt.
Weil er, nee, es gibt ja noch diese andere, es gibt ja noch FTTB.
Und darüber müssen wir in der Stadt wirklich diskutieren.
FTTB.
To the Basement oder Basement Building. Das heißt, dein Provider legt dir Glas,
aber nur bis in den Keller und dann kommt aus dem Keller nach oben.
Das ist dir nicht egal. Das sind Schreiern, die sagen, ich möchte unbedingt
FTTH bis an meinen Router haben, damit ich von da aus mit WLAN weiterspielen kann.
Von mir aus können die auch Kupfer bis in meine Bude legen.
Bei mir zum Beispiel liegt im Keller Glas und im Haus geht es dann mit Kupfer weiter.
Können sie in 20 Jahren dann immer noch Glasfaser zu dir hochlegen,
wenn man da mehr braucht.
Wird aber von manchen dieser Schreier, wir brauchen FTTH, nicht akzeptiert.
Da wird wieder gesagt, oh die Telekom macht die G-Fast, das ist ja zum Beispiel
so, G-Fast wird sowas gerne benutzt, jetzt benutzt die Telekom wieder das Kupfer,
anstatt jetzt endlich Glasfasern in die Wohnung zu legen.
Und das ist aber, da muss man halt eben differenzieren und sagen, das ist aber Quatsch.
Aber die Faser liegt ja immer noch nicht im Building, oder?
Naja gut, es kommt doch vorhin. Also in der letzten Wohnung,
wo ich gewohnt habe, da waren halt im ganzen Haus in allen Wohnungen Fasern.
Aber das Haus wurde halt neu gebaut und sie haben es halt beim neuen Bauen halt
Fasern reingelegt. Fertig.
Und unten kommt Kupfer an.
Und bei den anderen Leuten, nochmal, unterschätze das bitte nicht,
ich habe mehrere Fälle, ich musste nur mal eine Twitter-Time-Mann da durchgucken,
wo ich das hatte, wo Leute gesagt haben,
ach ja, ich klicke mir mal hier so eine Glasfaser, in Berlin gibt es ja durchaus
Glasfaser-Provider, wo du sagen kannst, ich bin halt mittelständischer oder
bin selbst ein Freiberufler, ich mache aber so viel Videoproduktion,
ich brauche jetzt mal hier Glas, ach klicke mal, ich kriege hier eine Dark Fiber
für 600 Euro irgendwo, gibt es, nicht überall, aber gibt es.
Und dann geht der hin zu seinem Vermieter und sagt, ja, hier und tralala.
Und der sagt, was, sie bohren mir meine Außenhaut von meinem Haus, bauen sie mir nicht an.
Aber man hat ein Recht, die Antenne aufs Dach zu stellen, damit man alle Sender empfangen kann.
Ich habe hier gerade meinen Keller abgedichtet, weil wir in Berlin haben,
holt Grundwasser und so weiter und so fort. Der sagt, sie fassen mir meine Kellerwände nicht an.
Ja gut, das ist aber.
Oder eben die anderen, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, dann hast du vielleicht
Glas im Haus, weil die dann einfach die Telekom oder wer auch immer legt es
denn rein, überrumpelt einfach, bohrt was, tralala.
und dann sagst du, jetzt will ich aber von dem Kasten, von dem schönen FTTB-Kasten,
der da unten ist, hätte ich jetzt gerne mal eine Leitung in meiner Wohnung,
sagte der Hausverwalter.
Nee, Alter, also ich hab das Treppenhaus
gerade renoviert. Da gehst du mir nicht dran. Da ist die Frage.
Ob es da einen Anspruch ist.
Ja, da sind wir aber nicht.
Ich rede aber nicht.
Das verstehen die Leute noch nicht.
Ja, aber ich will ja nicht darüber reden, wo wir sind, sondern ich will darüber
reden, wo wir hinwollen.
Naja, also ich denke mal, das muss einen ähnlichen Weg nehmen,
um ein krasses Beispiel zu bringen, wenn man sich überlegt, was darf gefändet werden.
Der einzige Farbfernseher im Haushalt darf nicht gefändet werden.
Da sind wir inzwischen angekommen, was Fernsehen angeht. Früher war es das Radio,
dann war es ein Schwarz-Weiß-Fernseher, heute ist es ein Farbfernseher.
Wahrscheinlich wird es irgendwann ein LED-Fernseher oder Flachbild- Fernseher
sein und wir müssen halt dahin, dass der einzige Rechner mit Internetanschluss
auch nicht gefändet werden darf.
Und dann haben die Leute das verstanden. Aber das dauert halt ewig lange.
Das ist auch ein gesellschaftlicher Prozess, der sich zunächst natürlich erstmal
bei der Politik auch durchsetzen muss, weil das nochmal als Grasrutsbewegung
nochmal so komplett von unten aufzuziehen, geht glaube ich in Deutschland nicht,
weil hier das Betreten des Rasens verboten ist.
Aber die Leute müssen es auch selber verstehen. Sie müssen das eben annehmen
als Infrastruktur wie ihren Wasseranschluss, wie ihren Stromanschluss,
wie ihr scheiß Fernsehen.
Und zwar auf allen Ebenen. Und das heißt, da muss Bildungsarbeit gemacht werden.
Wenn du mich fragst.
Was müssen wir konkret tun?
Wir müssen das den Leuten erklären.
Ohne dass sie einschlafen wie unsere Hörer.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es mehr Bildung, ach, das kommt von alleine.
Wichtiger ist, dass die politischen Entscheidungen gefällt werden,
um so eine Infrastruktur umzusetzen.
Und ich denke, es bedarf halt irgendwie irgendetwas in der Kategorie,
also ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt so ein Internetministerium braucht.
Ich denke, dass man da gegebenenfalls als auch mit den existierenden Ministerien
hinkommt, allerdings nicht mit den bisherigen Ministern.
Ich halte halt für ein Problem, dass die Politik und die Deutsche Telekom halt
immer noch sehr stark verwoben ist und dass die Politik immer noch für die Deutsche
Telekom halt auch Protektionismus betreibt.
Wirft ja auch Dividende ab.
Und da hast du natürlich das Problem, dass so ein Open Access etwas,
was tendenziell dem hauseigenen Provider, nenne ich es mal,
schadet, will natürlich so eine Politik, die sich selber sieht,
als das ist immer noch die deutsche Telekom und unsere Bundespost,
die dem schadet, das wollen die natürlich nicht durchdrücken.
Ja, verstehe ich, ist auch okay, aber man kann es auch nachgucken,
das ist der berühmte, im Englischen gibt es diesen netten Ausdruck dafür,
Für den Incumbent, das ist sozusagen der in dem jeweiligen Land sozusagen der
Platzhalter, ehemals Staats-Telekom-Dingsen auch immer.
Und du kannst dir in allen diesen Ländern angucken, dass die alle noch leben
und denen geht es gut. Die spielen sogar mit. In Schweden spielt Thiel ja auch mit.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass es denen schlecht gehen würde.
Ich sage nur, dass es in den Köpfen der Politiker, die das hohe Lied der Telekom
mitsingen, halt so geht.
AT&T gibt es ja auch noch, wurde aber aufgesplittet.
Nee, gibt es aber auch noch.
Ja, ja, sage ich ja. Deswegen ist es nicht so schlimm gewesen.
Naja, das ist gerade nicht so das Paradebeispiel, wie man es richtig macht.
Ja, kann sein.
Aber ich sehe schon auch.
Dass dieses Pseudo-Telekom-Monopol, das ist schädlich.
Ich sehe das momentan gar nicht als Problem. Ich sage nochmal,
das Problem ist unser gesellschaftliches Verständnis davon, was ist das,
wofür ist das gut, wollen wir das?
Diese berühmte Mao-Am-Werbesport, was wollen wir?
und da hörst du eben, wenn du das in Deutschland in einem Stadion machst,
hörst du nicht Gigabit Internet die sagen Sky für Umme oder weißt du.
Das ist ein Problem aber haben sie auch in Schweden bestimmt auch nicht gesagt weiß ich nicht.
Die haben dort ja, das ist jetzt nicht in schwedische Gesellschaft die waren einfach mehr Offline.
Mehr Firmen und das hat sich meiner Meinung nach über den Preis erledigt und
hier hat die Telekom ihren Finger drauf und hier geht das einfach.
Die Telekom ist hier nicht das Problem, Leute. Echt nicht. Jedenfalls nicht an dieser Stelle.
Sie ist schon Teil des Problems, weil sie natürlich auch ein Lobbypunkt ist,
der den Leuten immer wieder einreden möchte, ja, das ist Luxus und nicht essentielle Infrastruktur.
Ja, weil sie von der Regulierung runter wollen. Sie wollen halt nicht reguliert werden.
Deswegen ziehen sie halt alle Register, die sie ziehen können und damit bleibt es halt,
in den Köpfen es ist Luxus und keine essentielle Also weil ich gerade Regulierung sage.
Bei uns in Deutschland gibt es ja diese Regulierungsbehörde Bundesnetzagentur,
ja vorher Regulierungsbehörde die reguliert ja alle möglichen,
Telefoniebereich und so und auch die EU fuscht damit rein, Telefonie,
Telefonie Internet ist in Deutschland nicht reguliert,
Ja, die Regulierungsbehörde hat, oder die Bundesnetzagentur hat jetzt irgendwelche Abteilungen,
haben irgendwelche Abteilungen, die jetzt so plötzlich so sagen,
wie, das ist aber blöde, dass der Provider 30 Megabit verkauft, aber bloß drei liefert,
ja, und bieten jetzt irgendwelche lustigen Messtools an und sowas,
da haben sie sozusagen aus Sicht des Verbraucherschutzes haben sie jetzt ein Problem entdeckt.
Also sie regulieren de facto nicht. Sie sind schon zuständig.
Man hält es gerade Stream-On, versuchen sie seit drei Monaten da irgendwie mal
zu einer Antwort zu kommen und irgendwie schieben das schön.
Sie tun so als ob und verschieben das so nach der Wahl, damit das Thema nicht nochmal aufkommt.
Ich sag's nochmal, ich hab's schon mal getweetet, das ist eine solche Petitesse,
ihr müsst nicht glauben, dass die Verschwörungen alle so tief gehen,
dass die Bundesregierung jetzt meint, irgendein scheiß Thema bis nach der Wahl.
Das ist doch vollkommen egal.
Ist jetzt wirklich egal.
Ich glaube, wir müssen mal ein bisschen runterkommen.
Genau, wir müssen mal ein bisschen runterkommen. Ich wollte eigentlich nur drei
knackige Wahlforderungen für die lustige Diskussion am Wahlkampfstand in den
nächsten Wochen liefern.
Das war jetzt dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen komplexer, was wir jetzt hier
ausgegraben haben. Ist ja auch okay. You ask for it. Ja, nee, eigentlich nicht.
Doch, you ask Clemens. So you ask for it.
Erstens habe ich euch alle gefragt und zweitens,
man muss sowas auch reduzieren. War es die Diskussion?
Wir werden nie gutes Internet haben, wenn wir diese Debatte nicht auf drei Forderungen
grundlegender Natur runterbringen kann. Guten Einstieg haben wir schon mal.
Internet, also Datenversorgung als Infrastruktur ansehen.
Essenzielle Infrastruktur.
Ja, mit einem Grundrecht auf Zugang und irgendwie dem Aufbau einer Open Access,
Verwaltung und Betriebsgeschichte, die in irgendeiner Form durch öffentlich-rechtliche,
Organisationen durchgeführt wird und nie wieder Internetminister,
die nie wissen, wovon sie reden.
Okay, das war jetzt Science Fiction, Entschuldigung, aber man muss ja auch mal
ein bisschen was einwerfen.
Nachdem ich jetzt mehrfach angekündigt habe, dass diese Sendung kürzer ist,
alle anderen, ist es nicht mehr?
Ist es nicht, ne.
Tja, mal den Mund so vollnehmen.
Wie ist denn so eure Sende-Fitness?
Voll fit.
Du willst noch?
Haben wir denn noch was?
Ja, ohne Ende, aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt noch fünf Stunden weiter podcasten
sollten, weil wir haben ja dann auch noch andere Ich habe immer nur so kurze Turbo-Themen.
Das dauert ja immer nicht lange. Also zum Beispiel Mac Pro.
Du willst doch über Macs reden?
Ja, ganz kurz ein bisschen.
Wenn du jetzt ganz kurz über Macs redest.
Nee, das ist ohne Pimpen aber.
Ja, nee, klar.
Achso, dann willst du auch, meinst du?
Ja, dann können wir natürlich jetzt noch einen Fass aufmachen,
aber ich bin auch schon ganz schön müde. Clemens möchte dann wiederum auschecken.
Nee, möchte erst mal gemutet werden, damit ich mal aufs Klo gehen kann.
Wenn ihr jetzt schon so konkret fragt.
Wir sitzen jetzt hier nämlich schon im Weinen.
Ja, aber... Wie lange machen wir das? Wie lange kennst du mein Zeichen dafür?
Ich kenne deine Pinkelzeichen nicht, um ehrlich zu sein. Ich will da nichts von wissen.
Zurück zu den Max.
Sonst reden wir zu viel Meta hier. Also ich hab...
High Sierra gibt's ja mit APFS Boot Support, das man nativ booten kann.
gab es aber für den Mac Pro nicht und auch bei unserer letzten Sendung ging
das noch nicht inzwischen gibt es aber ein Beta ist jetzt auch schon wieder zwei, drei Wochen her,
wo tatsächlich ein Firmware-Update für den Mac Pro rauskam, der jetzt tatsächlich
wirklich, ich habe es ja auch erstmal nicht geglaubt, Native von diesem APFS
booten kann, das heißt der Mac Pro Classic,
Der Cheese Grater, den Tim hier auch unterm Tisch hat.
Mac Pro Classic.
Wo wir alle gerade unsere Hände drinnen.
Aber den nennen die wirklich Classic. Den nennen die CMP immer in den Foren.
Classic Mac Pro. Oder MPC.
Vielleicht heißt es auch Cash.
Weil der immer noch Cash wert ist. Für so eine Mülltonne kriegst du nichts mehr.
Und auch, obwohl das Update ist ja eigentlich nur für den 5.1er,
weil der 4.1er ist ja eigentlich nicht supported. Aber wenn man aus einem 4.1er,
so wie du ja auch, ein 5.1er raufgeflasht hat, was man ja machen kann,
dann geht dieses neue Update auch einfach da drüber.
Also auch der alte 2900 Mac Pro nimmt dann dieses Update an,
wenn er vorher zu einem 5.1er umgeflasht wurde.
Und dann kann man einfach weiterflasht. Also der Installer merkt da nichts.
Und inzwischen, die aktuellen Installer fragen auch nicht mehr,
ob sie nach APFS konvertieren dürfen sollen oder sowieso.
Sie machen es einfach und sie fragen auch nicht. Das ist jetzt wohl Default.
Also man kann die Konvertierung auf APFS nicht abwählen, auch nicht beim MacBook
Pro oder sonst wie. Die haben gesagt, es ist jetzt Default-Munde, geht nicht.
Das könnte erklären, warum ich es nicht installiert bekommen habe.
Ja, bei Fusion Drive, da sagen sie, das geht noch nicht, aber alle anderen werden
automatisch konvertiert ohne Opt-out, also keine Chance.
Ich habe ja gleich mal die Latte ganz hoch gelegt und mir gedacht,
okay, jetzt machst du mal einen APFS Fusion Drive, habe mich so ein bisschen
durch die Dokumentation gewühlt und Tatsache, das geht.
Ja, ich habe auch schon Leute gesehen, man muss ein bisschen fummeln, aber es soll wohl gehen.
Ähm...
Witzigerweise, du kannst entweder, kannst du halt ein Core Storage Logical Volume
Group anlegen, wo du dann ein Logical Volume reinmachst und das HFS Plus installierst,
formatierst und kannst es dann zu einem APFS umwandeln.
dann mach den ganzen Raffel wieder weg und mach nur ein Logical irgendwas mit
APFS oder du machst es halt direkt damit, aber mir ist es nicht gelungen,
da ein laufendes System drauf zu installieren.
Das hat einfach mal so gar nicht funktioniert.
Oder sie lassen das mit dem Fusion Drive auch wieder fallen, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Na, laut Doku gibt es aber Systeme, die du mit Fusion Drive tatsächlich auf
High Sierra und APFS und so weiter fahren kannst.
Ich habe ja dann irgendwann gedacht, naja gut, dann installierst du es jetzt
erstmal mit HFS Plus, weil ich wollte halt jetzt mal wieder einen lauffähigen
Rechner haben, aber das hat dann halt auch nicht funktioniert.
Die Erklärung wäre natürlich, dass er versucht, es dann gleich umzuwandeln und
dann merkt er, oh, ich habe gar nicht den richtigen Bootblock und Bootpartition
und hast du nicht gesehen und bleib dann hängen.
Also das war alles irgendwie so, naja.
Ich bin zufrieden, man merkt Pro ist jetzt wieder erstmal, zumindest für das
nächste Jahr up to date und...
Also hier der Developer von Carbon Copy Cloner.
Der zieht natürlich rum.
Der hat geupdatet.
Wie der hat geupdatet? Hat was geupdatet?
Man kann jetzt sauber Backups machen, die booten auch mit APFS drunter.
Der hat ja vor kurzem noch irgendwie groß rumgetönt, dass er irgendwie null
Doku vorfindet von APFS.
Er soll das File-System benutzen, dann hätte er es gar nicht bemerkt.
Also er soll doch eh keine...
Ja gut, aber wenn du dann so Snapshots hast, dann weißt du nicht,
wie groß sind die jetzt und so weiter.
Also es gab sozusagen null Doku, wie benutzt man diese Snapshots eigentlich,
gerade so Größeneinschätzungen, du willst ja mal wissen, so okay, wie groß ist denn jetzt,
wie viel Daten muss ich denn jetzt transferieren, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie
so einen Snapshot nehme, so, und er meinte halt, ich weiß nicht,
ob sich das jetzt in der Zwischenzeit irgendwie geändert hat,
dass, der Blogpost ist ein paar Wochen alt, ich hab jetzt grad die URL auch
nicht vor mir, ja, dass das so wie ein Problem sein.
Also, der Carbon Copy Cloner benutzt ja auch das File-System,
aber sein Marketing Spruch war ja immer, dass er sagt, ich garantiere dir,
dass das eine 1 zu 1 Copy ist und zwar mit allem Scheiß.
Das war ja schon zu den alten EFS-Zeiten, nicht EFS, HFS-Zeiten,
war das ja schon so, da gab es ja noch so Schweinkram immer mal so wie ein Resource-Fork
oder irgendwelche anderen Dinger,
diese Properties, die du da noch dran hast, dass du die zum Beispiel in dein
Spotlight oder sowas hinterlässt und diese ganzen anderen Snippets,
die jetzt vielleicht nicht zu deinem File-Namen und zu dem Content deines Files
gehören, sondern diesen ganzen anderen Scheiß drumrum.
Und was du auch nicht machen willst, ist zum Beispiel ein Snapshot-Ding mit,
zu backuppen, weil da siehst du noch mal den Spiegel von all dem,
was du gerade eben schon mal gebackuppt hast und so weiter.
Das heißt, an seiner Stelle muss er diesmal schon das File-System so ein bisschen verstehen.
Er muss zumindest wissen, welche Dinger er abfragt. Also er poigt jetzt nicht
per Blocker-IO auf der rohen Platte rum, sondern er benutzt schon das File-System,
wie du forderst. Aber er fragt halt die richtigen Fragen.
Dann muss er ja wieder gucken, dass es die Calls halt gibt und wenn es die halt
nicht gibt, dann hat er da nichts zu suchen.
Deswegen sage ich aber gerade, er muss gucken, dass es die Calls gibt. der muss wissen, welche,
Wie verrät mir jetzt das File-System, was ist da jetzt mit einem Resource-Fort oder so?
Ich habe jetzt gerade nachgeguckt, die Version 5, die ist gerade in Beta.
Ich habe mal den Link in Slack reingeworfen, da gibt es einen Abschnitt APFS.
CCC5 currently offers bootable system backups from APFS to APFS,
HFS to APFS, and APFS to HFS, and of course HFS to HFS.
Übrigens, CCC5, die fünfte Version von CCC.
Ja. Und additionally, die neue Beta supports APFS Encryption for both Source
and Destination APFS Volumes as well as for Remote Mac Source and Destination Volumes.
Also die Version 5, die jetzt gerade in Beta ist, die hat das komplett jetzt alles eingebaut.
Mit Soße und Sharp.
Mit alles, was glaube ich irgendwie gebraucht wird.
Alles, was geht.
Ist ein ziemlich cooles Tool eigentlich, der Karl.
Mochte ich schon immer.
Der hat mir schon oft den Arsch gerade.
So, jetzt checkst du aber richtig aus, wahr?
Jetzt check ich richtig aus.
Okay, Klärens, dann.
Mein Gast hat sich zwar inzwischen jetzt selber irgendwo dahin verpisst,
vorhin gehört, aber mit dem fahre ich morgen ganz, ganz früh irgendwo hin, deswegen.
Verstehe. Na, dann bist du jetzt entlassen.
Dankeschön.
Dann, äh.
Wir sehen uns, wenn mal hier wieder Freakshow stattfindet und ich auch da bin.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das dann.
Machst du jetzt den 14-Tage-Tornus wieder?
Ja, ich habe jetzt auch schon wieder massig Termine eingetragen.
Ja, ähm.
Just look into your calendar.
I look in my Kalender. Ah, Kalender, wir sollten mal über Kalender spielen.
Ja, ja, machen wir später nochmal.
Alright. Ciao, ciao.
Tschau.
So, also hier, Carbon Kopie-Kloner. Immer diese CCCs.
Das ist ja geil. Also ich meine, dann ist er ja dann doch irgendwie,
dann hat das wohl doch nochmal irgendwie hinbekommen oder was?
Naja, hat er halt wahrscheinlich die richtige Doku bekommen,
nachdem er mal rumgeheult hat.
Das hilft manchmal, ne? Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, habe ich das gekauft?
Ich glaube, das ist so eins dieser Tools.
Ich habe mal irgendwann eine Version gekauft, aber das ist schon eine Weile her.
Ich habe ihn einmal benutzt, aber so richtig, ich weiß nicht,
ich mache meine Backups mit Time Machine oder von Hand, irgendwie wichtige Sachen.
Aber so dieses Carbon Copy Cloner.
Geht mir auch so.
Naja, Carbon Copy Cloner hat einfach einen wunderbaren Vorteil.
Und das ist der, du kannst halt damit einfach, also es gibt auch noch andere Tools, die das können.
Mag sein.
Aber, wie heißt das andere? Dem...
Habe ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr in Erinnerung. Aber wenn es jetzt darum geht,
du machst jetzt irgendeine Maßnahme mit deinem Rechner, baust irgendwas um,
instillierst was Neues, pipapo, ist nie los, Twitter-Tar. Ja, Clemens, kommt gleich.
Aber ich stehe doch gar nicht im Parkverbot. Ich sehe vor allem kein Blaulicht, doch jetzt.
Ist es Polizei oder ist es...
Und? Halten direkt vor der Tür.
Halten direkt vor der Tür.
Live in der Freakshow, und wenden aber, oder?
Der Raid.
Das sieht nach Wänden aus.
Ist es Polify oder ist es...
Ja, das ist doch im Ton.
Ich glaube, sie sind im Nachbarhaus.
Das ist der Polizeiton. Also es ist ja nicht dieses lang gezogen von der Feuerwehr.
Ja, aber ein Rettungswagen?
Nee, das ist Polizei.
Das ist Polizei. Nee, es ist vor allen Dingen ein Elektrohorn und kein Druckhorn.
Was machen die jetzt? Werden wir jetzt gestürmt?
Nee, das sah nach dem Nachbarhaus aus, wo die hingerannt sind.
Ist doch egal, lass die doch da GSG 9 stürmen.
Nee, Feuerwehr hat ja diese Drucklufthörner, die sind ja nochmal eine ganze Runde lauter.
Dann wäre hier richtig Alarm so, Feuerwehr ist richtig laut.
Wollt ihr nur ein bisschen Drama?
So, ich will jetzt noch mein Dings durchgucken. Ihr macht das auch immer.
Nur Last One.
Ah, guck mal. Yeah, siehst du, da sind wir doch.
Carbon Copy Cloner.
Okay, dann lohnt es sich ja wenigstens.
Ja, ist durch.
Nein, es gibt ja einen guten Grund.
Ja, man macht eine Kopie von einer Platte.
Mit kaum etwas so schnell wieder einen bootfähigen Zustand herstellen und von
daher ist jetzt sozusagen auch angeraten,
dass man neben diesen ganzen inkrementellen Backups, die man so macht,
sich auch ab und zu mal einfach mal so eine Note-Boot- Kopie macht,
einfach nochmal auf eine separate Platte und dafür ist das Ding echt gut.
So, was macht ihr jetzt hier gerade?
Also, seid ihr fertig mit eurem Thema?
Du hast damit angefangen.
Nee, mit Kabel und Copykloner, meine ich.
Ja, PFS war das Thema.
Okay, also fertig.
Beta 5 ist drin.
Was kommt jetzt?
Jetzt, wir wollen ja mal Gadgets vorstellen, die wir uns so holen.
Und ich musste, nachdem jetzt die Berliner Polizei mit ihren Radfahrerpolizisten
jetzt doch ganz schön doll kontrollieren in Mitte und so.
Und mich auch schon mal angehalten haben mit Telefon in der Hand. Nur zum Glück am Tag.
Und der war auch ganz nett, hat nur gesagt, ist ja nicht so doll,
hast die Hand nicht frei, kannst nicht so gut bremsen. Und wenn da ein Telefon
runterfällt, der hat ja auch so eins.
wäre nicht so schön und so, ich soll jetzt mal in die Tasche packen und ja und
dann dachte ich mir, da ich ja schon seit knapp 20 Jahren ohne Licht rumfahre.
Jetzt ist mal Zeit.
Und dann habe ich so einen Tipp bekommen von so einem Typen,
der meinte, es gibt so richtig geilen Scheiß,
die Firma heißt, ich denke mal spricht man ohne K, NOG, also K-N-O-G,
NOG und die Reihe heißt Blinder,
wie Blenden und das tun sie auch, ich mache das jetzt mal nur für euch,
die Hörer sehen das natürlich nicht, ach so, hier ein bisschen doller und dann
kann ich das auch noch eine und noch eine Stufe heller machen. Das sind 400 Lumen.
Das gab es vor ein paar Jahren noch nicht mal als Taschenlampe.
Inzwischen hast du das vorne als Fahrradlicht. Und das ist schon ziemlich geil.
Bist du sicher, dass du damit nicht irgendwie angehalten wirst?
Nee, ich glaube, die sind schon ganz happy, wenn jemand Licht hat.
Ja, aber die sind eventuell nicht zugelassen.
Doch.
Sind sie sogar? Echt?
Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Also die beiden, die ich habe hier, ich habe zufällig meine,
weil ich eigentlich nur mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs bin, deswegen sind die immer
im Rucksack. Die sind auf jeden Fall zugelassen.
Das weiß ich gar nicht, aber ich glaube, sie sind schon happy,
wenn du was hast. Und für hinten habe ich auch so ein schickes Rücklicht.
Das macht auch ordentlich hell. Also man will da nicht so wirklich reingucken.
Die sind aus Australien.
Ja.
Naja gut, ich habe auch vorne hell.
Also Alu hier ist das, ne? Alu-Gehäuse. Also es sind normale Fahrrad vor und rücklicht.
Das ist jetzt nicht so super special. Aber wenn einer was Schickes haben will,
dann sollte er bei der Firma NOG, also K-N-O-G, sollte er mal danach suchen.
Da gibt es schicke Sachen.
Da gibt es was viel besseres.
Na was denn?
So ein Nabendynamo.
Ja, wollte ich halt eben genau nicht.
Der ist...
Wie? Nee, natürlich.
Das ist unnötiges Gewicht. Ein Verschleißteil.
Was soll da verschleißen? Das ist ja ein Elektromotor, der verschleißt.
Du musst es erstmal haben, wenn du schon ein Rad hast, ohne zum Beispiel...
Ja, aber du musst es nicht laden. Das ist ein weiteres Ladetal.
Ich lade mein Telefon, ich lade mein Telefon.
Das musst du dabei haben.
Hallo, jetzt haben wir schon über vier Stunden auf. Jetzt müssen wir uns doch hier nicht...
Ja, du kannst die per USB laden.
Ja, trotzdem musst du sie laden.
Guck mal, sieh das einfach mal so. Manche Leute kaufen sich ein Nabendynamo
und haben dann auch andere Lampen. Manche Leute mögen kein Nabendynamo.
Die kaufen sich halt sowas.
Was du da machst, ist ja jedem selber belassen. Das wissen ja die Hörer,
können ja alles selber belegen.
Wie viel Output macht die Front bei dir?
400.
Und das Rücklicht, was du da hast, ist das mit diesen kleinen Dingern?
Genau, das hat drei kleine und einen, der so ein bisschen mehr Bums macht.
Das sind einfach so rote Rücklächter.
Du kannst ja auch so einen sparsamen Mod machen. dann gehen nur die zwei kleine
an von den dreien, dann hältst du 20 Stunden, glaube ich, oder waren es 10, ich weiß nicht so genau.
Aber meine Radstrecken sind eigentlich gar nicht so mega lang und nachts fährt
man jetzt ja auch nicht so ewig viel.
Okay, aber haben die Dinger auch Bremslicht?
Nee, die sind ja immer anders, da sind so Dauerlichter.
Die können ja auch heller werden dann.
Nee, nee, nee.
Woher soll denn das Licht wissen, dass du bremst? Das ist ja nur nach der Clip-Lampe.
Beschleunigungssensor.
Gibt es so eine Spielzeuge schon?
Ja, sowas gibt es.
Ja, das gibt es.
Also ein Kumpel von mir hatte vor 40 Jahren schon Blinke an seinem Bonanza-Fahrrad.
Das ist wirklich wahr.
An diese Dinger kann ich mich auch erinnern, ja.
Naja, also ich finde das irgendwie ganz cool.
Also mein Problem, was ich mit diesen Clip-Ons immer habe, also ich habe zwei
Probleme mit den Clip-Ons.
Erstens, du clippst sie an und sie halten einfach ihre Position nicht,
weil die Lenker dann irgendwie schräg sind. und dann hast du den Platz und dann
zeigen sie nicht in die richtige Richtung.
Weil die kannst du nur, wenn der Lenker so ein bisschen schräg ist,
dann zeigen die irgendwie so nach links.
Dann hast du keine Stelle, wo es wirklich geradeaus zeigt. Das heißt,
du brauchst auf jeden Fall eine Stelle an deinem Lenker, die 90 Grad nach vorne ist.
So, wenn du das nicht hast, habt ihr das schon bei Kinderfahrrädern und so weiter,
dass das einfach nicht ging. Wie ist dieser Mechanismus zum Dranmachen?
Ja, dann musst du sie halt immer anklippen.
Der ist so soft, dann vergisst du die Dinger.
Ja, aber das mache ich einmal hinten ran.
Der bleibt dran und den wird vorne.
Der bleibt dran, naja, der klaut sich.
Also ich zum Beispiel mache die nur ran, wenn ich sie echt brauche.
Bei mir sind die immer dran, aber mein Fahrrad parkt in meiner Küche und ich
schließe mein Fahrrad eigentlich auch nirgends an.
Die lebt man über USB oder was?
Ja, genau.
Gibt es extra so ein Kabel dabei, damit es auch passt?
Ach so. Oder du steckst die halt irgendwie hier.
Man kann es auch direkt reinstecken.
Also ich mach das halt dann im Büro oder wenn ich halt irgendwie abends noch
auf der Couch sitze, dann...
Ah, wie lange laden die so?
Die hintere ist ziemlich schnell voll, die vorne braucht einen Moment,
aber die macht auch echt hell.
Und woran sehe ich das?
Die leuchtet dann nicht mehr rot, sondern blöd.
Achso, und kriegt dann auch den gleichen Trojaner dann irgendwie noch?
Ja, sicher.
Kann sein, dass wir jetzt auch erstmal ein Firmware-Update einspielen. Nee, nee, Spaß.
Darf ich nochmal trollen? Gibt's die auch mit USB-C?
Nee.
Aber da gibt's einen Adapter für.
Du hast ja eh einen Adapter, weil du willst ja nicht so direkt ohne Kabel an
deinen Rechner stecken.
Warum?
Ja, weil du USB-C hast. Er hat das gerade hier, so müsste man jetzt eigentlich
mal zeigen, hat jetzt tatsächlich links die Rückleuchter und rechts die vorne.
Aber ich habe USB-C, aber da ist von der Firma auch so ein 10 cm Adapterkabel dabei.
Okay, was auch wieder auf normal USB geht, aber da kann man auch seinen nach
USB-C Adapter dazwischen stecken. Aber ich finde, dass halt schicke Gehäuse
ist so aus Alu, das halt macht so einen wertigen Eindruck.
Ist es halt nicht der billigste Scheiß, aber ich finde...
Die sind schon recht teuer. Also ich habe auch lange gezögert, aber...
Was kosten die?
Die vorne bei mir jetzt hier, die liegt bei 75. Und die hintere, keine Ahnung.
Die liegt bei 57. Das ist schon echt eine ganze Menge Holz.
Deine hintere kostet 57.
Achso. Also bei mir ist vordere wie gesagt irgendwie 75 und ähm.
Dieses Geblinke von den Beamten da draußen, das nervt ein bisschen.
Ja, das hört ja Gott sei Dank keiner an.
Das stimmt.
Aber ich persönlich kann die
auch sehr empfehlen. Also ich hatte vorher so billige Dinger irgendwie.
Und ich habe das ja auch schon als Empfehlung von einem Rennradfahrer bekommen.
Aber was meinen Sie denn?
Ich habe mir die angeguckt und war auch gleich überzeugt.
Also die sind auch dicht, ne? Also ich habe die jetzt auch schon in wirklich
heftigen Regensituationen.
Ja, ich hatte früher auch so eine Plastellampe, habe mir da auch Power-LEDs
eingelötet, damit es richtig schön hell ist und war auch toll,
aber es war halt aus Plastik und dann ist der Deckel immer abgesprungen und
das, ja, das hat irgendwie nicht gehalten so richtig.
Also die hintere kostet auch nochmal ein Fufi.
Also was meinen Sie denn mit Noc-Niner Beleuchtung Unisex Erwachsene?
Bist du in der falschen Kategorie gelandet? Brauchen wir auch andere Sachen?
Die Sven-Praktikant.
Das ist diese rote Rücklichtlampe, die du da drin stecken hast.
Die ist halt weder rosa noch hellblau, deswegen ist sie unisex.
Achso, die weiße vorne ist nicht unisex, oder was?
Das war alles keinen Sinn. Marketing. Die weiße ist auch unisex.
Ich finde die Lampen super.
Ich auch.
Da sage ich jetzt auch mal nichts gegen.
Wie gesagt, die Diskussion, ob Nabendynamo oder nicht, ist ja eine ganz andere.
Dafür sind die natürlich nicht, weil die haben auch keinen Stromanschluss,
dass man die zum Beispiel, wenn man eine Nabendynamo hätte, dass man die irgendwo
anschließt, sondern die gehen wirklich nur per Akku und sonst nicht.
Aber die hintere zum Beispiel bei mir, die kann ich zwei Wochen jeden Abend
fahren und die sagt immer noch alles gut.
Die vordere, wenn ich sie richtig hell mache, dann will die halt schon schneller
mal Strom, aber die taugen wirklich.
Naja gut, ich habe halt nur diesen Nadendynamos, ich kann es nicht ausmachen,
das Licht. Es gibt keinen Schalter, um es auszumachen.
Ist auch nicht schlimm so, aber ich Weil der Naben.
So die modernen Nadendynamos, die machen halt mehr Widerstand,
wenn du das Licht ausschaltest, als wenn es an ist.
Insofern, du merkst den Rollwiderstand von dem Ding nicht.
Naja gut, ich wollte halt an meinem Fahrrad nichts dran haben.
Ich habe halt nur einen Rahmen, zwei Laufräder, eine Kette.
Du bist etwa ein Fixifahrer.
Ich bin Fixifahrer, ja.
Guck an.
Ich wollte halt an meinem Fahrrad nichts abmachen.
Ich mache das eigentlich auch nicht ab.
Da muss einfach alles dran sein im Fahrrad.
Ich bin auch ein großer Freund von so Default. Also ich habe irgendwo ein Fahrrad
gesehen, da war das Rücklicht direkt in die Sattelstange interpretiert.
Musste aber auch die Batterie in der Sattelstange haben.
Kann man sich so Seatposts kaufen, die da so drin haben. Gibt es auch von Trek irgendwie.
Ich glaube dieses Bad Boy Standard Urban Tralala Rad, das hat das alles schon so eingebaut.
Da ist irgendwie Rücklicht im Seatpost und vorne ist Licht in der Gabel,
glaube ich, links und rechts und LED-Streifen.
Das ist schon ganz schön spacig, wenn das das Rad war. Aber ich glaube schon.
Aber ich glaube, wir können zusammenfassen, also wer abnehmbare Lichter an seinem
Fahrrad haben möchte, der kann auf jeden Fall...
Ja, die sehen schon amtlich aus.
Die tun auch weh, wenn man die auf den Kopf kriegt. Mir ist die mal vom Schrank
runtergefallen. Also die vordere vor allen Dingen.
Die vordere ist schon ein bisschen schwer.
Das stimmt. aber,
gut ich möchte auch mal fragen, haben wir noch Themen?
Wolltest du gehen?
Ich bin.
Noch ein paar Tage hier.
So rein theoretisch sehe ich doch bei Roddy ein paar Sachen die,
wir sollten auf jeden Fall nochmal das mit dem mit dem iPad irgendwie erwähnen.
Ja, ich habe ein iPad gekauft. Ein iPad Pro.
Das große, ja?
Nee, das ist das große.
Das mittlere.
Das mittlere, genau. 10, 8. Also es gibt ja diese, die klassische iPad-Größe
sind ja diese 9,7 oder wie viel sind?
Ja, so wie das erste.
Was rauskam.
Genau.
Ja, okay.
Das ist so dieses Format.
Genau. Und irgendwann haben sie also dann das eigentliche iPad Pro mit den 12 Zoll rausgebracht.
Ja.
Das Große. Genau, und jetzt wurde ja vor kurzem dieses, genau,
das Große, wurde jetzt das 10,5.
Was physikalisch so groß ist wie das Original, aber der Bildschirm ist viel größer.
Fast genauso groß. Es ist einen kleinen Tick größer, aber man muss sie wirklich
übereinander legen, um das zu sehen.
Okay, es ist wirklich einen Tick größer.
Aber auf den ersten Blick sieht man es nicht.
Also so ein Zentimeter in der Höhe und irgendwie einen halben in der Breite.
Ja, genau.
Aber das Display ist...
Du kannst ja mal beide anmachen, beide Displays.
Ich sehe es ja hier. Das Display ist noch ein bisschen mehr als einen Zentimeter größer.
Ja, vor allen Dingen ist es dieses True-Tone-Display. Was du jetzt gerade,
wenn du hier anmachst, dieses Apple-Hintergrundbild...
Also was hier die Farbe scannt und sich...
Ja, und halt auch den etwas vergrößerten Farbraum hat. Also ich finde, das sieht man schon.
Das hat das aber auch schon.
Das hat das auch schon?
Das große hat das nicht.
Das große, stimmt, stimmt. Und ansonsten, ich fand das halt sehr, sehr schön.
Bin da irgendwie, also wir hatten in der Firma halt als Testgerät eins bestellt
und dann hatte ich das Teil in der Hand und dachte mir so, ah geil.
Und dann musste ich es haben. Dann bin ich zum Apple Store gefahren und habe einen.
Vierstelligen Befrag auskümmelt.
Achso, eine Sache, gib mir da mal kurz zum Testen bitte, dieses Gerät.
Ja. Willst du den Stift nochmal haben?
Nee, nicht den Stift, sondern ich wollte was anderes.
Kostenpunkt.
Also vielleicht, während ich das noch parallel teste, ich habe das mit dem Stift ausprobiert. Und?
Für brauchbar befunden.
Es ist schon wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Also es ist,
wenn man da jetzt noch irgendwie ein Leg merkt, dann nur so ansatzweise,
wenn man jetzt so richtig wild große Kreise macht, so, wo man ja,
von damaligen Lösungen immer nur noch so einen Hauch eines Echos einer Linie
irgendwie erwartet hat.
Auf gut Deutsch, wenn man es wirklich drauf anlegt.
Na, wir haben ja vorhin mit einer Highspeed-Kamera, also mit dem iPhone hier
in Slowmotion da aufgenommen.
Ja.
Und es war so ein Millimeter hinterher, konnte man sehen, aber da Tim ja den
Stift relativ schnell bewegt hat, also von der Zeit her, das,
ja, hat man in echt nicht gesehen, nur in der Zeitlupe.
Genau, und so das normale Skribbeln und Schreiben und so weiter, dass es,
im Prinzip Real-Time.
Und wenn du schreibst, bist du ja auch nicht so schnell, wie du das da vorhin
gemacht hast, so mit schnell und herzlichen Schreiben.
Genau, aber auch so beim normalen Schreiben habe ich das halt bisher immer bei
allen Systemen gemerkt, so, es ist einfach nicht wie ein Stift.
Also es ist nicht wie ein Bleistift.
Ich wäre jetzt noch ganz froh, wenn es noch irgendwie eine App gäbe,
die also auch tatsächlich funktioniert wie ein Bleistift.
Das habe ich bisher noch nicht gesehen. Die haben halt alle nur diese Pen,
Ballpen und so weiter. Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was in den USA so verwendet wird.
Aber das sind alles so Zeichen-Apps, das ist dann weniger was zum,
beziehungsweise wenn du die Notizen… Ja.
Aber da habe ich noch nicht ein einziges, auch die Notizen machen es halt anders.
Naja, das sieht halt wie ein Bleistift aus.
Nein, nein, das sieht nicht aus wie ein Bleistift. Es verhält sich nicht wie
ein Bleistift. Also, weißt du nicht, was ich meine?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Also geht es um die Haptik oder ums Aussehen?
Nee, es geht um das Überzeichnen. Also wenn du sozusagen irgendwas schon mal
so mit dem Bleistift leicht anschraffiert hast und dann halt da drüber gehst
und dann kannst du ja mit dem Bleistift einfach immer die Fläche immer schwärzer machen.
Ja.
Und auch in Abhängigkeit vom Druck halt mehr oder weniger. Und da habe ich bisher
noch keine einzige Software gesehen, die das auch nur im Ansatz...
Na gut, das ist nicht mein Anwendungsfall, weil ich...
Ja, meiner schon, weil es hat mit Künstlern nicht so viel zu tun,
weil wenn ich jetzt mir eine grafische Notiz mache, also wenn ich wirklich einen Stift nehme.
Ich will ja nicht nur Schreiben abgenommen bekommen, sondern wenn er sagt,
jetzt geht's auch mit dem Stift, dann hab ich natürlich auch dieselbe Erwartungshaltung
wie mit dem Stift und zwar nicht unbedingt nur wie mit dem Ballpen,
sondern dann möchte ich halt gerne das gleiche haben. Was hast du da für eine App gerade?
Kann man mich hören?
Naja, aber du beschwerst dich jetzt, dass da irgendein Feature von letzten Jahrtausend
nicht mehr hast, dafür hast du ja wahrscheinlich 100.000 neue Features, die es vorher nicht gab.
Wie Löschen zum Beispiel.
So, probier mal aus.
Ja, aber es hilft ja nichts, wenn ich nicht dasselbe zeichnen kann wie mit einem Stift.
Ja, aber meinst du nicht, dass der insgesamten Mehrwert größer ist als,
also das eine Feature, was dir fehlt, du hast ja dafür tausende neue, die jetzt gehen.
Ja, aber tausende neue sind ja nicht das, was ich will, sondern ich will ja
erstmal überhaupt das haben, was ich vorher auch hatte, wenn ich schon einen Stift nehme.
Also wenn wir schon die Mühe machen, noch ein extra Device in die Hand zu nehmen,
was nicht meine Finger sind, dann möchte ich auch gerne mindestens dasselbe
Verhalten wie auf Papier haben.
Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, da du das ja noch nicht hattest,
mach das doch erstmal vier Wochen und dann reden wir nochmal drüber.
Wie vier Wochen?
Na du hast doch das jetzt noch gar nicht nie gemacht, oder? Also ist doch jetzt
so ein theoretisches Problem.
Was heißt theoretisches Problem?
Du hast doch jetzt so ein Tablet noch gar nicht benutzt mit diesem Stift.
richtig lange, um mal zu sagen, dass es scheiße ist.
Ich muss das ja auch nicht lange benutzen, weil es hat ja bisher nichts auch
nur im Ansatz so ähnlich verhalten wie ein Bleistift.
Aber du benutzt doch einen Bleistift. Also welches Problem möchtest du lösen?
Also ich zum Beispiel Ja.
Ich möchte das Problem lösen. Es gibt halt bestimmte Scribbles,
die ich einfach auf Papier besser machen kann als auf dem Computer.
Mit Bleistift?
Ja.
Was ist das denn?
Na alles. Alles, was ich mit dem Bleistift zeichne. Linien, ich mal was aus,
mach was dicker, ich hebe was hinvor.
Es soll sich halt so verhalten, wie ein Bleistift, damit es ein mir bekanntes,
Gefühl erzeugt. Wie kann ich das hier dicker machen? Ist das hier hier?
Wir fahren hier mit einer Zehn-Mann-Wanne auf. Was ist los hier?
Ah, hier ist es nice.
Okay, jetzt. Ist aber immer noch sehr klein hier.
So, und der Apple-Pencil, der kann doch eigentlich auch die Schrägstellung,
ne? Ah, Das geht hier sogar. Guck an.
War irgendwie nicht zuverlässig.
Das ist der Druck, den du da machst.
Das ist nur, wenn man ganz schlach macht.
Also du würdest dann ja auch den Stift anfassen.
Aber so verhält sich. Es ist aber auch nicht. Ich meine, so würde sich halt kein Ja.
Es geht so langsam. Sie kommen langsam dahin, aber Bleistift ist das ungelöste Problem.
Was ich empfehlen kann, ist mir leider jetzt kaputt gegangen vor kurzem,
ist einfach eine Display-Schutzfolie drauf zu machen,
weil die tatsächlich beim Schreiben mit dem Stift da drauf nochmal ein bisschen
den Widerstand erhöht, sodass man dieses Gefühl, dieses Kratzige,
wenn man einen Prüller auf einem Papier schreibt.
Obwohl das Problem habe ich nicht, dass mir der Widerstand zu gering ist.
Ich fände es eher angenehm.
Ich inzwischen auch nicht mehr, deswegen habe ich jetzt auch keine neue drauf gemacht.
So eine Umgewöhnung, die man braucht.
Und ich habe halt dieses Gerät jetzt, also ich habe ein 9,7er aus dem letzten
Jahr und ich habe keine Papiernotizen mehr. Das Thema ist absolut abgeschlossen für mich. Also das...
Ja, ich habe jetzt auch angefangen, keine Papiernotizen mehr zu machen, weil...
Also alleine dieses, ich mache ein Foto und male da drin rum und kann mich dann
im Büro hinsetzen und daraus eine Dokumentation irgendwie erstellen oder so,
das ist für mich ungeschlagen und das ist...
Also ich probiere jetzt gerade mal hier dieses Scrollen, da haben ja auch so
viele Leute erzählt, das wäre ja irgendwie so toll, dass jetzt irgendwie der
Browser mit 120 Hertz, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich bin für alt dafür.
Ich sehe das nicht mehr.
Ja, was ich halt auch noch recht geil finde, ist, das Teil hat halt 100,
was, nee, 128, nee, 256 Gig.
Das kommt drauf an, was du kaufst, meins hat 128.
Das mittlere halt.
Das Scrollen siehst du nicht?
Das gibt es halt in 64, in 256 und in 512. Ich habe das mittlere genommen.
Und das ist halt jetzt wirklich jenseits, erst mal jenseits dessen, was ich brauche.
Forst, wie viel?
Keine Ahnung, guck's nach.
Ich guck gerade mal pro 1000er, wird das kosten?
Ja.
Meine Fresse. Ich will auch mal scrollen, Timme.
Naja, und der Stift nochmal oben drauf für 110 oder was?
Also es scrollt schnell. Ich bin mir bloß nicht so richtig sicher, ob ich ...
Aber wer scrollt denn so?
Wenn ich eine lange Seite habe. Aber hier ist jetzt auch schon iOS 11 drauf.
Okay. Es gibt jetzt drei Aspekte. Erstens, wie schnell ist das?
Das hat sich bei iOS 11 jetzt geändert. Jetzt ist es genauso wie in App-Listen.
Vorher war Safari total mega träge. Das hat mich vollkommen genervt.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Du, keine Ahnung.
Das andere war sozusagen, das waren so Berichte, wo ich nicht so richtig was
mit anfangen wusste, dass angeblich diese 120 Hertz beim Scrollen irgendwie
dazu führt, dass es irgendwie besser
aussieht. Jetzt fehlt mir aber so ein bisschen der Vergleich gerade.
Ich will auch mal.
Ja, hier, scroll mal.
Also ich war ja im Apple Store und bin dann an einen sehr netten Verkäufer.
Meinen Kratz ist doch butterweich.
Noch nie ein Android in der Hand gehabt, wa?
Ich hab ja nicht gesagt, dass es nicht butterweich ist. Das Scrolling ist super. Nur ob die 120...
Wir können ja den Vergleich machen.
Ja, aber merkst du doch, wie du es mitlesen kannst. Es wird unscharf.
Dennis, ich rede doch von was vollkommen anderem. Ich rede davon,
ob die 120 Hertz Refreshrate beim Scrollen dazu führen, dass man mehr erkennt
von dem, was man scrollt.
Hab ich doch genau gerade gesagt. Wenn man so hin und her schiebt,
kann man viel besser lesen als vorher. Es wird weniger unscharf.
Meinst du?
Ja, guck doch mal.
Welche Seite?
Muss das jetzt mit einem vergleichbaren Gerät jetzt gerade nicht?
Ja, aber das ist ja auch vom Gefühl schon 120 Hertz.
Vom Gefühl her sieht man das schon.
Ja, ich kenne doch wie 60 oder 30 Hertz.
Jetzt liegen die beiden iPads nebeneinander und du hast da 60.
Siehst du, guck mal an. wieder drrrr.
Ja, das ist ein Unterschied tatsächlich.
Sag noch mal.
Na hier, drrrr. Das ruckelt.
Das ist aber auch noch iOS 10.
Oder?
Ja, aber das ist halt trotzdem der Unterschied. Und guck mal hier.
Das ist doch ein krasser Unterschied, ja.
Männerwischen auf iPads.
Das stimmt.
Also man sieht das tatsächlich.
Guck mal hier mal.
Oh ja.
Ja doch.
Mega-mäßig.
Okay, das war mir bis jetzt nicht so aufgefallen.
Also da geht vielleicht sogar noch was, aber es ist auf jeden Fall viel besser.
Ich glaube auch, der John Gruber hat das schon geschrieben, diese Umstellung,
auch wenn sie wenig beachtet wird, ist fast so krass wie auf Retina.
Ja, da ist fast dran.
Da willst du nie wieder zurück, genau.
Retina-Scrolling.
120 Hertz-Scrolling.
Das will man haben.
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Nee, ich wollte den Verkäufer aus dem Apple Store nochmal grüßen.
Der hat sich zwar nicht zu erkennen gegeben, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass er ein Hörer ist.
Sei gegrüßt, lieber Apple-Store-Verkäufer.
Ja, doch, war sehr nett.
Ist das Wi-Fi-only oder mit,
LTE? Ja, kosten 1000.
Ja, ich kaufe die immer mit LTE, weil ich will dann halt...
Man weiß ja nie in der Zukunft.
Ich benutze mal Navigation da drauf.
Genau, ich will halt auch Karten haben.
Ich kann ja Hotbox von deinem Telefon machen, aber es ist so un...
Und, naja, und...
Zweitkarte oder Extrakarte?
Ich habe eine Extrakarte, die in meinem Festnetz-Tariefschritt drin ist,
nochmal im Gig oder anderthalb, deswegen...
Kostet dann wie viel?
8 Euro.
Echt? Das ist ja nix.
Vielleicht auch 10, aber nicht mehr 4 Euro.
Wenn man sich für 1000 Euro so ein Gerät kauft, kann man sich das auch noch leisten.
Also ich habe die Zweitkarte halt über die Firma bestellt.
Ja, ihr wollt an Firmen immer.
Du, ich bin selbst und ständig. Das trinken wir gar nicht.
Weil die, das sowieso irgendwie mit dabei ist beim Tarif.
Ich finde, wir haben jetzt keine Themen mehr.
Du findest, wir haben keine Themen mehr.
Es sei denn, du möchtest deine noch...
Ich glaube, es sind noch alle eingefallen.
Also sind sie aktuell so, also verdampfen die?
Also das Einzige, was relativ aktuell ist, ist dieses Paper,
über das ich nichts sagen kann, weil ich es nicht verstanden habe.
A Solution to the P versus PN Problem. Es scheint tatsächlich jemand dieses
Ding gelöst und bewiesen zu haben.
Aber das kann man ja vielleicht nächstes Mal besprechen.
Oder? Das kann man eventuell nächstes Mal besprechen. Vielleicht stellt sich
das auch als großer Trugschluss heraus.
Und was ich auch sehr nett fand, war dieser Unclouded Cloud Server von Enzle
oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, wo man tatsächlich ein Stück Hardware bekommt.
Und dieses Stück Hardware ist dann ein Cloud Server, der einem irgendwie virtuelle
Maschinen bereitstellt wie eine Cloud.
ich fand das einfach total witzig wie ich das gelesen habe und dachte mir so der ist.
Denn Bestandteil einer Cloud oder er ist deine eigene Cloud.
Der ist dann da das Teil sieht nicht viel größer aus wie ein Mac Mini und gibt
dir halt die Möglichkeit so Cloud ähnliche Maschinen da so Cloud Maschinen da so ich kann mir.
Auch ein BSD hinwerfen oder ein Debian und da irgendwie vor allem spawnen,
wenn ich es kann ja natürlich.
Wenn du das kannst Ich finde das Ding auch für das, was da an Hardware drin ist, viel zu teuer.
Aber ich fand einfach, dass dieser Cloud-Craze jetzt so groß ist,
dass man tatsächlich den Cloud-Server zum sich auf den Schreibtisch stellen.
Cloud to go.
Wird das da?
Nein.
Aber es ist eigentlich eher so.
Wie Cloud on the Desktop ist es eher so.
Da sollten wir es eher fort nennen, weil das ist die Wolke, wenn sie runterkommt.
Also Enzle, wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Ich fand das einfach nett, mal erwähnenswert, aber es ist irgendwie.
Es ist gar keine Cloud. Hier steht Transition from Cloud to Edge Computing.
Der nächste neue Meidet wegen Edge.
Wie auch immer.
Living on the Edge.
Sicherlich.
Ich bin jetzt schon total on
the Edge. Ich muss ja auch noch diese Sendung auch noch veröffentlichen.
Diesen ganzen,
Sendung.
Diesen ganzen Sendungen muss ich noch veröffentlichen.
In diesem Sinne, drück doch mal die Outro-Taste.
Wir haben nicht wirklich was Wichtiges vergessen oder so?
Bestimmt. Aber das machen wir jedes Mal.
Wir brauchen noch was für die nächste Sendung.
Al, vielen Dank. Sehr kompatibel.
War eine schöne Besichtigung.
Sind die wegen dir hier? Wegen mir, der Sendung gehört?
Die räumen dich jetzt ab.
Die warten nur vor der Tür.
Macht nichts. Ich habe noch die Nummer vom Anwalt gespeichert.
Wir sagen Tschüss.
Bis bald.